CALL FOR MEMBERS OF SENATE
EDUCATION ALRIGHT MARIA ELENA
LOOK AT THAT SHE'S LOOKING BE
SPLIT.
UP WE CAN GET A FEW MORE MEMBERS
WE CAN GET STARTED AS A SUB
COMMITTEE
.
WELL I JUST LOVE THE MEMBERS OF
SAN EDUCATION THEY LISTEN VERY
WELL.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE I'D LIKE
TO CALL THE THIS MORNING'S
HEARING OF SENATE EDUCATION TO
ORDER WE HAVE TWENTY ONE BILLS
ON THE AGENDA TODAY SIX OF THOSE
BILLS ARE ON CONSENT.
WILL BE LIMITING TESTIMONY TO
TWO PEOPLE TWO MINUTES EACH --
WITNESSES THAT EXCEED TWO
MINUTES WILL CAUSE THE NEXT
WITNESS TO HAVE LESS TIME I WILL
REMIND YOU THAT -- WITNESS OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND YOUR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION WE DON'T
HAVE A QUORUM SO WE WILL START
AS A SUB COMMITTEE.
I SEE OUR FIRST AUTHOR WHO IS
VERY PROMPT ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES
COME ON DOWN.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER ONE AB.
SIX GOOD MORNING MADAM MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS.
TODAY PRESENT TO YOU A. B. SIX A
BILL WHICH CREATES THE BRANCH OF
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
INCREASING THE CAPACITY IN
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION FOR ALL
EARLY CHILDHOOD PROGRAMMING.
THIS GOVERNMENT STRUCTURE CAME
AS A RECOMMENDATION FROM THE
SPEAKERS A BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION ON EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION WHICH WORKED
DILIGENTLY FOR TWO YEARS AT
ASSESSING ALL ASPECTS OF THE
VERY COMPLEX.
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
STRUCTURE.
OUT AT ALL IT IT.
IT.
THE STRUCTURE THAT WE HAVE IN
CALIFORNIA AND THERE AFTER THE
PREPARED A VERY COMPREHENSIVE
REPORT.
AS NOTED IN YOUR ANALYSIS THE
COMMISSION RECOMMENDED TO THE
ESTABLISHMENT OR AUGMENTATION OF
AN OFFICE.
OR DIVISION OF EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION.
SB SIX DOES EXACTLY THAT.
THE VERY NATURE OF EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION REQUIRES A
VARIETY OF STATE DEPARTMENTS.
A MIXED METHODS DELIVERY SYSTEM
OF CHILD CARE AND PRESCHOOL AND
THE INCLUSION OF A DIVERSE ARRAY
OF STAKEHOLDERS.
AND WITH PARTICULAR NEEDS.
COORDINATION OF THESE EFFORTS IS
CRUCIAL FOR THEIR SUCCESS THIS
ENHANCED LEVEL OF COORDINATION
WILL HELP ENSURE THE CHILDREN.
FAMILIES AND PROVIDERS AREN'T
SLIPPING THROUGH THE CRACKS IN
THE EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
SYSTEM.
AND IT ENHANCES OUR ENTIRE
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM AS A WHOLE.
INCREASED COORDINATION IN EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION MEANS A
SMOOTHER TRANSITION FOR THE
CHILD AND THE FAMILY'S WITHIN
THE K. THROUGH TWELVE SYSTEM AND
BEYOND.
THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT HIGHER
EDUCATION AND HIGHER HIGHER
QUITE QUALITY EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION ARE THE GREATEST --
GLAZERS THE CALIFORNIA CAM AND
SHOULD PROVIDE FOR OUR FAMILIES
AND CHILDREN AND THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE BRANCH.
OF EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION WAS
SURE THAT WE PROVIE THE SOCIO.
ECONOMICALLY AND DEVELOPMENT
LEAGUE DEVELOPMENTALLY
TRANSFORMATIVE PROGRAMS IN AN
EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT MANNER
TO ACHIEVE EDUCATIONAL GOALS AND
EQUITY AS INTENDED.
HERE WITH ME TO SPEAK MORE ON
THE MATTER IS ERIN GABLE ON
BEHALF OF FIRST FIVE CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU SIMPLY WOMAN BEGIN
WHEN YOU'RE READY THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AARON GABLE ON
BEHALF OF FIRST FIVE CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
AS WE'VE SPOKEN ABOUT MANY TIMES
THIS COMMITTEE THE FIRST FIVE
YEARS OF EVERY CHILD'S LIFE IS
AN INCREDIBLY CRUCIAL TIME FOR
THEIR DEVELOPMENT.
AND ELEVATING EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION TO THIS DEGREE GIVING
IT A BRANCH IN AN ORGANIZED WAY
SOLIDIFIES CALIFORNIA'S
COMMITMENT TO OUR CHILDREN
DURING THIS IMPORTANT
DEVELOPMENTAL TIME.
IF WE TRULY WANT TO EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION SYSTEM TO
WORK MOST EFFICIENTLY AND
EFFECTIVELY FOR CHILDREN
FAMILIES AND OUR CARE PROVIDERS.
IT MAKES SENSE.
TO FIND A WAY TO BETTER ORGANIZE
ACROSS THIS MULTITUDE OF
AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS THAT
ARE SERVING ARE MIXED DELIVERY
SYSTEM.
NO OTHER EDUCATION SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA DEALS WITH THIS LEVEL
OF ADMINISTRATIVE FRAGMENTATION
MAKING IT INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT
FOR FAMILIES TO NAVIGATE THE
SERVICES IN THE PROGRAMS THAT
THEY ARE ELIGIBLE.
FOR AND TO GET THEIR CHILDREN
HIGH QUALITY EDUCATION THAT THEY
DESERVE.
IT IS INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT ALSO
FOR THE EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION PROVIDERS THE SYSTEM
IS EMPLOYING AND SERVING AS WELL.
THE BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION ON
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION HAD
MANY HEARINGS WERE THERE WERE
INCREDIBLE EXAMPLES AND EVIDENCE
THAT BOTH CHILDREN FAMILIES AND
THEN ALSO THERE PROVIDERS.
OR FINDING THE SOULS LOST IN OUR
SYSTEM AT THE LOCAL AND STATE
LEVEL.
SO IT CREATES IT IN THE CREATION
OF A BRANCH OF EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CREATE A COMMITMENT IN
CALIFORNIA TO OUR YOUNGEST IN
OUR MOST VULNERABLE.
ENSURE THAT THE SYSTEM THAT WE
ARE FUNDING WORKS BETTER FOR ALL
OF THEM.
DEVELOPING A STRONG EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION SYSTEM CHECK
CHANGES AND STRENGTHENS THE
ENTIRE EDUCATION SYSTEM ITSELF.
IT MEANS MORE CHILDREN WE READY
AND THRIVING WHEN THEY ENTER THE
TRADITIONAL K. TWELVE AND BEYOND.
IT ALSO MEANS MORE PARENTS CAN
ENTER THE WORK FORCE AND UP WITH
THEIR FAMILIES OUT OF POVERTY.
THE US SENATE MADE A WONDERFUL
FIRST STEP -- IN THE BUDGET IS
SITTING ON THE GOVERNOR'S DESK
AND CREATING MORE CAPACITY FOR
THE CALIFORNIADEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION FOR THE EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION PROGRAMS.
AB SIX IS THIS CRUCIAL SECOND
STEP TO THEN CREATE THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THAT CAPACITY
WE ARE DRIVE UP.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING KRISTIN POWER ON
BEHALF OF THE LIGHTS FOR
CHILDREN'S RIGHTS.
OFFERING OUR SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS A MAIN GUYS ON BEHALF
OF THE CHILD CARE RESOURCE
CENTER OUR CEO DR MICHAEL NEXT
SERVED ON THE BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION.
AND SO WE'RE PROUD TO SUPPORT.
DONNA ARE TO GET **** CALIFORNIA
STATE PTA IN SUPPORT.
MAKE IN THE CHRISTIAN CENTER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
MEN'S WORK ON BEHALF A SOW EWING
OF CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
RON RAP ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND SUPPORT.
YOU DO HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT IS THERE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING AND HEARING THEM WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
THANK YOU WE WE WILL MOVE IT AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
ASSEMBLY ROOM WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
SPECIAL YES FOR YOUR IPHONE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL WE CAN'T
EVEN COVER SORRY WE CAN'T EVEN
VOTE YET BUT WE WILL VOTE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME AND I THINK IT
WILL BE FINE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY WOMAN.
I SEE ASSEMBLY MEN O'DONNELL
PLEASE COME ON DOWN THIS IS ITEM
THREE EIGHTY BE.
FORTY EIGHT WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY THANK YOU MADAM.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS GOOD MORNING
EVERYBODY -- AB FORTY EIGHT IS A
VEHICLE FOR A K. FOURTEEN SCHOOL
FACILITIES ONE TO BE RESENTED
THE VOTERS IN TWENTY TWENTY AND
TWENTY TWENTY TWO THE K..
TWELVE A TO FACILITY PROGRAM IS
A HIGHLY SUCCESSFUL AND
TECHNICAL I THINK YOU WOULD
AGREE MADAM CHAIR PROGRAM.
THAT IS BASED ON PART OF A
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE STATE
STATE SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
AND AND STATES THE STATE'S
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND DEVELOPERS.
STATE BOND FUNDS HAVE BEEN
MATCHED BY BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
AND LOCAL BOND FUNDS AND
DEVELOPER FEES TO CONSTRUCT NEW
SCHOOL FACILITIES ACROSS OUR
STATE.
TOGETHER THESE FUNDS TO BUILD
NEW SCHOOLS MODERNIZE AGING
FACILITIES TO ENSURE THAT THEY
ARE SAFE AND UPDATED AND
SUPPORTED VOCATIONAL EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMS.
THESE FUNDS OF ALSO HELP THE
ECONOMY BY GENERATING TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF JOBS.
OVER THE PAST TWENTY YEARS
VOTERS HAVE SUPPORTED MULTIPLE
STATE BONDS FOR SCHOOLS THE LAST
ONE PROPOSITION FIFTY ONE FROM
TWENTY SIXTEEN WAS PASSED TEN
YEARS AFTER THE PRIOR BOND.
DUE TO THE LIKE THE GAP NEW
CONSTRUCTION AND MODERNIZATION
FUNDS FOR PROPOSITION FIFTY ONE
ARE ALREADY DEPLETED.
IN FACT FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN APPLICATIONS HAVE
BEEN SUBMITTED BEYOND THE
PROPOSITION FIFTY ONE FUNDING
AVAILABILITY.
THE NEED IS GREAT.
IN ADDITION TO THE BASIC
PROGRAMS NEW CONSTRUCTION
MODERNIZATION CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION AND CHARTER SCHOOLS
THIS BILL ADDRESSES MORE RECENT
NEEDS INCLUDING.
PROVIDING FACILITIES FOLLOWING A
DISASTER REMEDIATION OF LEAD --
IN WATER FOUNTAINS REPLACEMENT
OF SEVENTY FIVE YEAR OLD
BUILDINGS PRESCHOOLS AT SCHOOL
SITES.
AND SUPPORT FACILITIES SUCH AS
GYMNASIUMS LIBRARIES OR SCHOOL
KITCHENS AS A MEMBER OF THE
STATE BOARD OF ALLOCATION ON THE
BOARD WE HAVE SEEN CHALLENGES
EXPRESSED BY SMALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
IN THESE DISTRICTS THE
SUPERINTENDENT MAY ALSO BE THE
PRINCIPLE OF THEIR ONLY SCHOOL
THE FACILITIES DIRECTOR THE BUS
DRIVER THE JANITOR ECCENTRICITY
WHAT THEY NEED IS TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. TO HELP THEM APPLY
AND SECURE BOND FUNDS.
THIS BILL ESTABLISHES A SMALL
SCHOOL DISTRICT ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM.
THAT WILL PROVIDE SMALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ACCESS TO TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE RESERVATION OF FUNDS.
AND GIVE EXTRA TIME TO DESIGN
PLAN AND SEEK STATE AGENCY
APPROVALS VERY NECESSARY FOR
SMALL TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS WHERE
THAT TECHNICAL -- EXPERTISE MAY
NOT BE HOUSE.
UNDER THE CURRENT PROGRAMS
DISTRICTS THAT ARE NOT ABLE TO
MEET A LOCAL MATCH CAN SEEK
FINANCIAL HARDSHIP ASSISTANCE.
THIS MEANS THAT DISTRICTS CAN
RECEIVE UP 21100% OF FUNDING FOR
A PROJECT FULLY FUNDED BY THE
STATE BOND FOR THOSE HARDSHIP
DISTRICTS.
THIS BILL I JUST FINANCIAL
HARDSHIP TO INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS ELIGIBLE TO
RECEIVE 1100%.
A FUNDING SO THEY THERE THERE'S
EQUITY PROVISIONS IN THE IN THIS
BILL AS WELL.
THE PROGRAM FOR THE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO BOND IS CURRENTLY
LEFT BLANK FOR CONTINUE
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT IMPROVEMENTS
TO THE PROGRAM.
WE ALL KNOW FACILITIES MATTER IN
STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT AND STUDENT
MOTIVATION.
IN FACT THEY SET THE TONE FOR
THE SCHOOL NAME.
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
IS ERIC BAKI WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BOARDS ASSOCIATION A
KATHY ALLEN WITH THE SACRAMENTO
CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
MANAGER.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PLEASE FOR SEE
WHEN YOU'RE READY TO MINUTES
EACH.
A GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS KATHY ALLEN
I'M THE CHIEF OPERATIONS OFFICER
OF FACILITY SUPPORT SERVICES FOR
THE SACRAMENTO CITY UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND I' ALSO
PASSED CHAIR.
OF THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS OF THE
COALITION FOR ADEQUATE SCHOOL
HOUSING.
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT THE
STATE'S GULF SOLELY PROGRAM HAS
PROVIDED OVER FORTY TWO BILLION
AND ASSISTANCE TO LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES.
AB FORTY EIGHT MAINTAINS THE
CORE THE PROGRAM WHILE ADDING
NEW TOOLS TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR
DISTRICTS TO ACCESS THE PROGRAMS
SUCH AS A FIVE YEAR RESERVATION
OF FUNDS.
AND PROJECT MANAGEMENT
MANAGEMENT GRANTS FOR SMALL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
WE APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
INCLUSION OF LANGUAGE IN AB
FORTY EIGHT THAT STATES THAT THE
SECOND BOND IN THE BILL THE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO BOND.
WILL BE ADMINISTERED IN
ACCORDANCE WITH THE PROGRAM AS
IT STANDS THEN GIVING US
ADDITIONAL TIME TO CONTINUE
IMPROVING UPON THE PROGRAM.
CAPTION OTHER STAKEHOLDERS HAVE
PROPOSALS THAT EITHER DIDN'T
RISE TO THE LEVEL OF BEING PLACE
BEFORE THE VOTERS OR WEREN'T
ABLE TO BE VETTED IN TIME. TO
MEET THE LEGISLATIVE DEADLINES
SO THEY'RE NOT IN AB FORTY EIGHT
BUT WE REMAIN COMMITTED TO
STREAMLINING AND CONTINUING TO
IMPROVE ACCESS TO THE PROGRAM.
UNFORTUNATELY WE CAN'T AFFORD TO
WAIT FUNDS FROM PROP FIFTY ONE
THE LAST STATE SCHOOL FACILITIES
BOND FOR THE CONSTRUCTION AND
MODERNIZATION.
OF K. TWELVE SCHOOLS HAS BEEN
FULLY CLAIMED.
AND THERE IS ALREADY A GROWING
BACKLOG OF QUALIFIED SCHOOL
PROJECTS THAT WILL GO UNFUNDED
IN LESS AB FORTY EIGHT IS
APPROVED.
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE
DEPEND ON THESE FUNDS TO BUILD
NEW SCHOOLS TO ACCOMMODATE
GROWTH. TO REPAIR AGING
FACILITIES AND TO CREATE SPACES
THAT ARE CONDUCIVE TO TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY AND EDUCATIONAL
STANDARDS AND TEACHING METHODS.
AB FORTY EIGHT IS A CRITICAL
PART OF THE SUPPORT CALIFORNIA'S
STUDENTS NEED IN ORDER TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IN COLLEGE AND THEIR
CAREERS AND IN LIFE.
ON BEHALF OF CASH I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
THANK YOU PLEASE PROCEED --
PARKER THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
BOARDS ASSOCIATION I JUST LIKE
TO BEGIN BY THANKING SOMEONE A
DOLLAR FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD -- HE IS THAT TIME AND
TIME AGAIN BUT A CHAMPION ON
SCHOOL FACILITIES ISSUE STUFF
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OUR RESEARCH SHOWS THAT ADEQUATE
MODERN FACILITIES ARE ESSENTIAL
TO STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT.
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS SIMPLY
CANNOT FULFILL THEIR ACADEMIC
POTENTIAL IF ATTENTION IS NOT
GIVEN TO ENSURE THE FACILITIES
ARE CLEAN SAFE AND SECURE.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE HAVE PARTICIPATED THE
STATE FACILITIES PROGRAM AND
HAVE DONE SO IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
STATE OVER THE YEARS.
THIS PARTNERSHIP HAS BENEFITED
MORE THAN SIX MILLION STUDENTS.
AND TALK WITH OUR MEMBERS
THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT NEED FOR
A. B. FORTY EIGHT IF YOU LOOK AT
THE PASSAGE OF LOCAL BONTA
REVIEW LOCAL FACILITIES.
YOU WILL QUICKLY RECOGNIZE THE
VOLUME WORK THAT STILLIS
OUTSTANDING AND NEEDED
THROUGHOUT ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES.
SCHOOL DISTRICT SEVEN NEED TO
CONSTRUCT NEW FIFTH S. SCHOOL
BUILDINGS AN AREA OF WHETHER
STUDENT GROWTH.
BUT THERE ALSO IS NEED TO
RECONFIGURE EXISTING FACILITIES
GREAT LEARNING ENVIRONMENTS THAT
MEET SCHOOLS FOR THE NEXT
GENERATION.
OR UPDATE SCHOOL BUILDINGS WERE
PROVIDE SAFETY IMPROVEMENT IN
THE LIST GOES ON THE PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN THE STATE AND LOCAL
SCHOOL DISTRICT IS A CRITICAL
ELEMENT IN SUPPORTING OUR
STUDENTS.
AND FOR THAT WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB.
FORTY THANK YOU ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING PATTY HER ON BEHALF
OF THE CORONA NORCO UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING JEFF FROST HERBS IN
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SUBURBAN SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
THE CENTRAL VALLEY EDUCATION
COALITION IN SUPPORT.
JEFF FLOCK ON BEHALF OF THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS AND THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SCHOOL DISTRICT
SUPERINTENDENTS IN SUPPORT.
LARA PRESTON OF THE ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS
AND SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING DEREK CLINICS ON
BEHALF THE SMALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS SAYS HE ISSHIN IN
SUPPORT AS WELL AS THE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS OF SCHOOLS.
IN CINEMA COUNTY SOLANO COUNTY
NAPA COUNTY SACRAMENTO COUNTY
FRESNO COUNTY AND SAN DIEGO
COUNTY.
MORNING ALSO WORKED ON BEHALF OF
THE ANAHEIM UNION HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICT COAST COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT WRENCHES SANTIAGO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT AND
THE ORANGE COUNTY COMMUNITY
COLLEGE LEGISLATIVE TASK FORCE
IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING REBEKAH CURLY ON
BEHALF OF THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FACILITY COALITION AND THE
COUNTY SCHOOL FACILITIES
CONSORTIUM AND SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING DEBORAH BROWN WITH
CHILDREN NOW IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING SERRA BOTCHES WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SCHOOL BUSINESS OFFICIALS IN
SUPPORT.
CAITLYN YOUNG ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA EDUCATIONAL
TECHNOLOGY PROFESSIONALS
ASSOCIATION THE SAME DISCO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN THE
SAN MEDINA COUNTY JUST ADVOCATE
FOR BETTER SCHOOLS AND SUPPORT.
ASHLEY WALKER WITH NOTHING AND
ON BEHALF OF MOUNT SAN ANTONIO
COLLEGE AND NORTH ORANGE COUNTY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT.
ERICA ROMERO BEHALF THE HISPANIC
ASSOCIATION OF COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING IAN PITY ON THE
HAVE A BEHALF OF THE SCHOOL
ENERGY COALITION AND THE SCHOOL
FACILITY MANUFACTURERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING JAKE WAS SORRY ON
BEHALF OF HEAD START CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING RICHARD LYING ON
BEHALF OF THE HOME BUILDERS
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION NEWS MR O'DONNELL
NOTED -- FUNDING PARTNER IN THE
PROGRAM FULLY SUPPORTED THAT THE
BILL.
SAM NOT SURE WITH THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION SUPPORT.
I THANK YOU TURN MEMBERS MARK
MCDONALD ON BEHALF OF THE
FOOTHILL DE ANZA KERN.
SAN FRANCISCO IN YUBA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
SISTER IDEAS ON BEHALF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL ALSO A STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING IMAN MAJID WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CHANCE OFFICE OUR OFFICE DOES
NOT YET HAVE A FOR PRESENT
POSITION ON THIS BILL BUT WE'RE
SUPPORTER OF THE OFFICE INTENT
AND HOPE TO HAVE A FORMER
SUPPORT POSITION NEXT MONTH.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MONEY GRANDMA'S ON
BEHALF OF FIRST FIVE
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING JENNIFER BAKER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING STEPHANIE GOLDEN OF
THE FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ARE BOARD JUST VOTED TO SUPPORT.
DONNA ARE TO THE **** CALIFORNIA
STATE PTA IN SUPPORT.
RON RAP ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND SUPPORT.
DINA MALONEY ON BEHALF OF EL
CAMINO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
OKAY SHAILA LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
CAROL GOLDSMITH FRESNO CITY
COLLEGE ON SUPPORT FOR STATE
CENTER COMMUNICATES TO STRICT.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
BEFORE WE GET TO OPPOSITION I
NOTICE A QUORUM SIMON HAVE MADAM
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
LEYVA LEYVA HERE WILK.
WELL CARE CHIANG LASSELL.
WHO DOES SO HERE GLAZER MCGUIRE
CAN?
AND HERE.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
ANY OPPOSITION SEEING AND
HEARING THAT WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE DOCTOR PAN.
THANK YOU AND NOW I THINK YOU --
SUMMER MCAULIFFE BRING THIS --
BILL FORD AND BOND BUT I KNOW WE
SERVED ON THE STATE ALLOCATION
BOARD TOGETHER AND THEY KNOW
WHAT YOU'RE LEYVA HAS IS IS.
NOT CURRENTLY SERVING AS WELL
AND WE'VE CENTURY EXHAUSTED I
MEAN WE'VE ALLOCATED DAY --
FUNDING THAT DEFINITELY LESS
BOND IN THE LAST BOND THERE WAS
SOME FUNDING SPECIFICALLY BUT
FOR CHARTER SCHOOLS I DON'T KNOW
FOR THIS BOND IS -- IS IS THAT A
END OF PARTICULAR FOLDER
SEPARATE FUNNY IT WASN'T CLEAR
AS FAR AS WHAT WAS THE SITUATION
WITH -- CHARTER SCHOOLS IN THE
SEER INCLUDED IN THE BOND OKAY
SAYS MONEY FOR CHARTER SCHOOLS
IS THAT SPECIFIC ALLOCATION
DATES GET A GENTLE PULL THINK
IT'S YET TO FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
FOR CHARTER SCHOOLS OKAY.
ALL RIGHT SO -- YEAH I THINK I
THINK THAT -- WELL CERTAINLY --
YOU KNOW WE'RE DOING OKAY POLICY
AROUND THE ROLE CHARTER SCHOOLS
AND SO FORTH THAT -- WE DO HAVE
A LOT OF KIDS WHO ARE IN THOSE
SCHOOLS AND THAT -- THERE NEEDS
TO BE SOME MECHANISM TO BE SURE
THAT -- WE SHOULD INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR ALL KIDS -- ARE ARE THERE
AND CERTAINLY -- WE NEED TO BE
SURE THAT -- WE HAVE THE KIND OF
SUPPORTS THAT WE NEED -- FOR AND
DID FOR ALWAYS FINISH COLLEGES --
THE CONTRADICTION ALL DOWN THE
PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND SO FORTH OKAY
THANK YOU. FOR THANK YOU THINK
IS UNDERPANTS CENTER ALSO BEFORE
I GET TO I THINK WE HAVE A A
COUPLE MAY BETWEEN HOURS AT THE
MICROPHONE [inaudible]
GO AHEAD.
INDEED THANK YOU SENATOR --
KATHY SURE ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU
OF CALIFORNIA -- WE WANT TO IT
WE HAVE A SUPPORTIVE AMENDED
POSITION ON THE BILL -- AT FIRST
WE WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR --
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD DADDY
AND AND RECOGNIZE THE THE
IMPORTANCE OF GETTING ADDITIONAL
BOND FUNDING FOR SCHOOL
FACILITIES -- OUR ONLY CONCERN
IS AND WHAT WE ALSO APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR'S EFFORTS IN THE AREA
OF GREDDY GREATER EQUITY AS TO
HOW BOND FUNDING IS DISTRIBUTED --
WE'RE CONCERNED THAT MORE WORK
THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE -- AND
WOULD LIKE TO SEE A STATEMENT OF
INTENT IN THIS BILL -- FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO RETURN TO THAT
ISSUE -- NEXT YEAR SUB SO THAT
OTHER TWENTY TWENTY TWO BONDS IN
PARTICULAR -- WE CAN LOOK AT THE
ISSUE OF EQUITY IN DISTRIBUTION
OF THE THAT FUNDING.
THANK YOU NEXT WIENER.
HELLO I'M GLORIA CHAN WHO I'M
THE VICE PRESIDENT OF FOR
ADVOCACY FOR THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN
VOTERS.
THE LEAGUE HAS SUPPORT EVERY
SCHOOL BOND MEASURE FOR THE LAST
THIRTY YEARS HOWEVER WE HAVE
LONG BEEN CONCERNED ABOUT SOME
OF THE IN EQUITIES WE FIND IN
THE FUNDING FORMULA VERTICALLY
FOR FACILITY MODERNIZATION.
ALL WE UNDERSTAND IT'S A COMPLEX
ISSUE AND THEY'LL TAKE SOME TIME
TO COME UP WITH A MORE EQUITABLE
FORMULA BUT I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT THAT WE DO THAT.
AND ESPECIALLY THAT MAY BE
PLACED BEFORE IT'S ON THE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AND THAT WE CAN
RESOLVE THAT ISSUE BEFORE IN
TIME FOR THAT.
ALL THE JOINTS ACLU IN ASKING
THAT INTENT LANGUAGE BE PLACED
ON THE BILL NOW.
SO THAT THE PLAN TO AMEND THE
CODE OF TIME TO ADDRESS THE
FORMULA OF FOOT FUNDING FOLLOW
WILL HAPPEN FOR THE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO BOND WE THINK THAT'S
VERY IMPORTANT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
I'D LISKI AND WITH PUBLIC
ADVOCATES -- WE SUBMITTED A
LETTER JOINT -- WITH THE
AMERICAN CIVIL LIBERTIES UNION.
AND I CONCUR WITH ALL THE
STATEMENTS THAT MEASURE ME THANK
YOU [inaudible]
VERY MUCH.
ANOTHER TWEENER WE GOT A WHOLE
NEW GROUP FOLKS HERE GO AHEAD
ADAM CAITLYN ON BEHALF OF THE
ADVANCE AND PROJECT TO SACK OF
THE PREVIOUS COMMENTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SENATOR DORADO.
WELL THEY BEAT ME TO THE PUNCH.
FIRST I DO WANT TO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH -- OF ASSEMBLYMAN AND
NOT ONLY FOR YOUR WORK AND YOUR
DEDICATION BUT EVERYONE ELSE HE
COULD SEE THAT YOU BUILT UP AN
EXTRAORDINARY COALITION -- I
ALSO WANNA RAISE CONCERN -- I'M
NOT THE EXPERT IN THIS BUT I DO
BELIEVE I'VE SEEN.
ENOUGH. TO RAISE CONCERNS ABOUT --
EQUITY -- THERE'S SOME
INFORMATION AND STUDIES HAVE
BEEN BROUGHT TO MY ATTENTION
THAT THE US SCHOOL FACILITIES
FUNDING FORMULAS ARE NOT
EQUITABLE -- AS APPLIED TO HIGH
WEALTH AND LOW WELL DISTRICTS SO --
I JUST WANT TO ASK YOU AS YOUR
BILL BILL MOVES FORWARD WHICH I
EXPECT THAT IT WILL -- WILL YOU --
MAKE AN EFFORT TO LOOK INTO THIS --
BECAUSE AS WE KNOW -- ISSUES OF
EQUITY -- COME UP AND THEY COME
UP MUCH TOO LATE IN THE GAME AND
WE'VE GOT TO BE MUCH MORE
DELIBERATE AND CONSCIOUS ABOUT
ADDRESSING THAT -- ESPECIALLY
WHEN THERE'S FUNDING INVOLVED SO.
I JUST WANNA.
YOU KNOW.
ECHO THAT THAT CONCERNED -- AND
ASK IF YOU WOULD LOOK INTO THAT
OR KEEP THAT INFORMATION -- OR
BRING THAT INFORMATION -- TOWARD
TENSION AND WORK SPECIFICALLY ON
EQUITY ISSUES -- AND AS FAR AS
THIS FUNDING GOALS.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE IT WILL JUST LET ME
SPEAK TO THE TO THE TO THE
EQUITY ISSUE THERE ACTUALLY ARE
EQUITY PROVISIONS BUILT IN. TO
THIS EFFORT THERE'S A MONEY FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT ARE
CLASSIFIED AS HARDSHIP WHERE
THEY CAN ACTUALLY GET A 100% OF
THE PROJECT FUNDED.
THOSE DISTRICTS THAT HAVE LOW
VALUATIONS CANTLEY FLOAT A BIG
BOND -- PUT THE PROPOSAL'S WE
SEEN THUS FAR ACTUALLY FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE WOULD CREATE MORE IN
EQUITY IN FACT IT WOULD TAKE A
LOT OF MONEY AWAY FROM LA U. S.
T. AWAY FROM SAMMER DINO -- WAY
FROM OTHER ANTELOPE VALLEY
EXCEDRIN I DON'T THINK WOULD
PROVIDE EQUITY THE PROPOSES
WE'VE SEEN AS A GIVE EVERY
STUDENT A SET AMOUNT OF MONEY.
AND PASS THAT AROUND THE STATE
WILL DISTRICTS MIGHT SAVE THAT
MONEY WE SHOULDN'T HAVE
DISTRICTS SAVING BOND MONEY --
DISTRICTS MIGHT NOT IN FACT NEED
THAT MONEY.
SO WHAT WE'VE GOT TODAY IS A
MODEL THAT I THINK IS WORKABLE
FOR NOW CERTAINLY I'M.
ALWAYS -- OPEN TO CONVERSATIONS
WITH WITH ANY OPPOSITION SIR --
ANY GROUPS THAT HAVE INTEREST IN
THE BILL BUT AGAIN THERE IS
PLACE HOLDER LANGUAGE IN THE IN
THE EXISTING BILL WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE THOSE CONVERSATIONS
WITH THIS AGAIN IS A VERY
COMPLEX ISSUE.
AND THE PROPOSAL'S I'VE SEEN
THUS FAR I THINK WOULD REALLY
CREATE MORE IN EQUITY THAN
EQUITY.
A CLASS FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK
YOU SIR HOW DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
SO MOVED ALL RIGHT.
THE MEMBER MEMBER THE BILL HAS
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR WILK MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM THREE AB FORTY EIGHT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE LEYVA BY LEYVA AYE
WILK.
WILK I CHIANG LASSELL WHO DOES
SO I GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN HI CAN I
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WE WILL LEAVE
THAT BILL OPEN FOR OTHER MEMBERS
TO ADD ON ALL RIGHT.
WE'VE GOT MORE BILLS MONTH
SERVICE.
LET'S TO ITEM TEN AB SOME FIFTY
ONE BUT BEFORE WE GET TO THAT
WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK SINCE WE
HAVE A QUORUM AND WE'RE GONNA
VOTE ON AB.
SIX ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAY AS MEN
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WE HAVE A MOTION FOR A. B. THANK
YOU MOVED BY SENATOR PAN PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ITEM ONE EIGHTY
SIX THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
HUMAN SERVICES LEYVA HI LEYVA
AYE WELL.
WILK AYE CHIANG LASSELL I WOULD
ALSO AYE GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN.
PAN AYE.
WE WILL LEAVE THAT BILL OPEN TO
LET OTHER ADDITIONAL MEMBERS AT
ON AND BEFORE WE START ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MAY TAKE A QUICK MOMENT
OF PERSONAL PRIVILEGE -- TEAM
LEYVA HAS THEIR YOUNG SENATORS
UP HERE IN SACRAMENTO TODAY IF
YOU COULD ALL STAND I'D LIKE
EVERYONE TO SEE YOU WOULD LIKE
TO RECOGNIZE YOU.
THIS IS PART OF OUR FUTURE HERE
WE'RE VERY PROUD OF THEM.
THEY JUST COMLETED A TEN MONTH
PROGRAM AND UP HERE AT THE
CAPITOL TO SEE WHAT WE DO
WELCOME YOUNG SENATORS.
WITH THE ASEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL ITEM TEN AB SEVEN
FIFTY ONE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HAPPY TO PRESENT MANAGER AS A
YOUNG ASSEMBLY MEMBER ABOUT HE
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB SEVEN FIVE
ONE A BILL THAT WILL ALLOW
COLLEGE PREPARATION OF FURTHER
BECOME PART OF OUR HIGH SCHOOL
CULTURE.
IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO ALLOW LOCAL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THE OPTION.
OF ADMINISTERING A NATIONALLY
RECOGNIZED CALL UNIT COLLEGE
READINESS EXAM.
IN LIEU OF THE S. BACK TEST IN
THAT ELEVENTH GRADE YEAR THAT IS
SO IMPORTANT AND SO BUSY.
THIS BILL IS ABOUT SMARTER
TESTING NOT MORE TESTING.
IT'S ABOUT STUDENTS ALSO BEING
INVESTED IN A TEST.
ASSESSMENT AB SEVEN FIVE ONE
WILL INCREASE THE PATHWAY TO
COLLEGE BY PROVIDING ELEVENTH
GRADE STUDENTS ACCESS TO A
REQUIRED COLLEGE READINESS EXAM.
DURING THE SCHOOL DAY AND ON THE
DURING THE SCHOOL TIME AND ON
THE SCHOOL DIANNE HOW ABOUT THAT.
CURRENTLY STUDENTS IN GRADE
THIRD THROUGH EIGHTH AND THEN
ELEVENTH.
ARE REQUIRED TO TAKE THE ASPECT
THAT'S THE SMARTER BALANCED
ASSESSMENT.
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW AYE SCHOOL
DISTRICT TO CHOOSE TO ADMINISTER
A COLLEGE ENTRANCE EXAM SUCH AS
THE SAT OR THE ACT INSTEAD OF
THE STATE REQUIRED ASSESSMENT
FOR ELEVENTH GRADE STUDENTS.
A LOCAL DISTRICTS COULD CHOOSE
EITHER WOULD HAVE TO DO ONE BUT
NOT BOTH.
THE ALTERNATIVE ASSESSMENT WILL
BE OFFERED DURING THE SCHOOL DAY
AT NO COST TO STUDENTS AND IT
WON'T TAKE. THREE WEEKS TO
ADMINISTER.
AND IF YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH HOW
TESTING WORKS AT A SCHOOL SITE
OFTEN YEARS YOUR SCHEDULES ARE
TIED UP FOR THREE WEEKS BECAUSE
YOU HAVE TO GET ALL THE STUDENTS
AND AND TO TEST THEM.
AND IT REALLY IMPACTS
INSTRUCTION THIS BILL REQUIRES
ASSESSMENT TO BE ALIGNED TO THE
STATE STANDARDS MEET FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS AND ENSURE THAT
ACCOMMODATIONS ARE PROVIDED I'M
GONNA REPEAT THAT.
THIS BILL REQUIRES THE A SEVEN
ASSESSMENT BE ALIGNED TO THE
STATE STANDARDS MEET FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS AND ENSURE THAT
ACCOMMODATIONS ARE PROVIDED.
NEARLY FORTY FIVE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS INCLUDING OAKLAND SAN
JOSE AT LOS ANGELES SACRAMENTO
AND LONG BEACH AND MANY OTHERS
OF COURSE ARE CURRENTLY OFFERING
THE SAT OR THE ACT DURING THE
SCHOOL DAY FOR FREE.
IN AN EFFORT TO INCREASE THE
COLLEGE ATTENDANCE RATE.
IN FACT LONG BEACH UNIFIED WHICH
IS ADMINISTERED THE SAT FOR FOUR
YEARS NOW HAS SEEN AN INCREASE.
IN THE DISTRICTS COLLEGE
ATTENDANCE RATE.
THIS BILL IS GOOD FOR STUDENTS.
TEACHERS AND PARENTS AND GOOD
FOR THE CALIFORNIA ECONOMY.
THIS BILL WILL REDUCE THE AMOUNT
OF TESTING GIVE GIVE STUDENTS
AND TEACHERS MORE TIME FOR
INSTRUCTION.
THE SAT IS MORE USEFUL TO TO
TEACHERS I CAN ASSURE YOU OF
THAT.
THEY'RE SMALLER NOW THIS IS A
KEY POINT THIS IS WHY I LIKE
THIS THE SUPERINTENDENTS GONNA
SURE OF THE REASONS THEY MY LIKE
THIS.
A LOT OF PEOPLE SAY THIS IS ONLY
ABOUT GETTING MORE KIDS INTO
COLLEGE YES IT IS BUT THIS IS
KEY TO ME AS A CLASSROOM TEACHER.
THE SMARTER BALANCED TESTS THE
SMARTER BALANCED ASSESSMENT IS
ATTACHED IS A TEST THE SAT IS AN
INCEST THE SAT OR ACT IS AN
ASSESSMENT SYSTEM. TO HELP STE
TO HELP ADDRESS GAPS IN STUDENT
LEARNING THE PSA T. OR SAT OR
ACT RATHER.
GUY CAN BE GIVEN IN THE EIGHTH
GRADE AND SO BASICALLY WHAT YOU
STARTED JUST YOU GIVE TO KIDS IN
EIGHT GRADE NINE GRADE TEN GRADE.
AND YOU CAN SEE.
WHERE THE GAPS ARE YOU CAN WORK
TO CLOSE THEM DURING THOSE HIGH
SCHOOL YEARS?
THE ASPECT TEST WE GIVE NOW IS
NOT AN ASSESSMENT SYSTEM IT'S A
SUMMATIVE TEST AT THE END OF THE
YEAR.
THIRD THROUGH EIGHTH AND THEN
ELEVEN BUT THE PAC TEAR THE SAT
YOU CAN GIVE AGAIN AND EIGHTY
NINETY TEN THE PRETEST IN YOUR
AGAIN YOU CAN IDENTIFY.
THOSE ACHIEVEMENT GAPS NOW AS
ORIGINALLY CONTEMPLATED THE
ASPECT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE AN
ASSESSMENT SYSTEM YOU LOOK AT
THE ORIGINAL CODE SECTION.
IT TALKS ABOUT IT BEING
ASSESSMENT SYSTEM IT IS NEVER
DEVELOPED INTO AN ASSESSMENT
SYSTEM THAT'S VERY UNFORTUNATE
THAT REALLY IMPACTS STUDENT
LEARNING AS A CLASSROOM TEACHER.
ALSO GETTING AT THE END OF THE
YEAR TASK FOR THE ASPECTS SYTEM
THAT'S NOT GOOD FOR US BUT WE
NEEDED SOMETHING THAT WOULD AND
THAT WE CAN -- THAT WE CAN
EMPLOY THROUGHOUT THE YEARS THAT
WE CAN ASSESS STUDENTS AND AGAIN
HOPE CLOSE THOSE ACHIEVEMENT
GAPS AND THE THE PS EIGHTY
EIGHTY EIGHT THE PAC TEAR THE
ACT OR THE ACT REALLY IS AN
ASSESSMENT SYSTEM THAT BUT
THAT'S WHY THIS IS IMPORTANT. TO
ME BECAUSE I CAN IDENTIFY MUCH
EARLIER THAN JUST THAT THAT ONE
YOUR TEST WHAT I NEEDED TO LIVE
BY STUDENTS TO HELP THEM CLOSE
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS.
LET ME ADDRESS SOME CONCERNS
CONCERN NUMBER ONE THE SAT OR
ACT DOES NOT ALIGN.
WITH THE STATE'S CONTENT
STANDARDS UNDER THIS BILL THE
STATE SUPERINTENDENT MAY NOT
AUTHORIZE AN ALTERNATE
ASSESSMENT UNLESS IT HAS BEEN
DEEMED. TO MEET THE STATE'S
CONTENT STANDARDS BASED ON
APPROVAL FROM THE US DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION THEY HAVE TO
APPROVE THIS.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
THERE IS NO ONE TEST NOT EVEN
THE S. BACK.
THAT IS COMPLETELY ALIGNED TO
COMMON CORE STANDARDS.
EACH OF THE THIRTEEN COMMON
COURTS STATES MAY HAVE CHANGED
OR ADDED TO THE STANDARDS BUT
THE S. BACK IS THE SAME TEST.
FOR ALL THOSE STATE EVEN THOUGH
THEIR STANDARDS MAY NOT BE THE
SAME.
A STUDY BY MICHAEL KERR LANDER
AND KRAMER CONE FROM UC DAVIS
I'M PREDICTING COLLEGE SUCCESS.
CONCLUDES THAT THE S. BACK AND
SAT ARE ALIGNED.
SMARTER BALANCED ASSESSMENT
SCORES DO NOT PREDICT FIRST YEAR
DO NOT PREDICT FIRST YOUR GPA
AND SECOND YOUR EXPERIENCE RATES
AS WELL AS S. A. T. SCORES.
BUT THE DIFFERENCE A MAGNITUDE
IS TRIVIAL.
SO THEY BOTH WORK ONE OTHER
POSSIBLE X. AN EXPLANATION FOR
THESE FUNDAMENTAL SIMILAR IS IS
THAT THERE IS AN OVERLAP AND THE
KNOWLEDGE AND SKILLS ASSESSED BY
THE SMARTER BALANCED ASSESSMENT
AND SAT.
THEY HAVE CONCLUDED.
IN TERMS OF ACCOUNTABILITY.
THIS BILL REQUIRES THE SAME
REPORTING FOR ALTERNATIVE SCORES
AS THE ASPECTS SCORES THE SCORES
CAN BE A LINE THROUGH CONCORD
AND SAY SO THE STUDIES TO ALIGN
THE SCORES. TO GET A SAT OR ACT.
SCORE FOR EACH S. BACK
PERFORMANCE LEVEL.
IF IT CANNOT BE DONE THIS BILL
CANNOT BE IMPLEMENTED PER THE
BILL -- CONCERN NUMBER TWO THE
SAT IS CULTURALLY BIASED AND
GRADES ON BUILDERS.
THE SAT RESERVE WAS REDESIGNED
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN TO ALIGN WITH
THE COMMON CORE STANDARDS.
AS AN ACHIEVEMENT TESTS THE
SCORES ARE NOT A SIGN ON A BELL
CURVE TWENTY SIXTEEN IT STOPPED.
WE SHOULD NOT EXPAND THAT ONE OF
THE OTHER ARGUMENTS WE SHOULD
NOT EXPAND THE USE OF ADMISSION
TESTS.
M. I'M NOT HERE TO ADVOCATE FOR
ONE TEST OR ANOTHER BUT AS LONG
AS IT'S A REQUIREMENT FOR
COLLEGE ADMISSIONS.
THIS BILL IS ABOUT LEVELING THE
PLAYING FIELD AND PROVIDING
OPPORTUNITIES TO ALL STUDENTS
REMEMBER KIDS GO TO SCHOOL OUT
OF STATE THEY MIGHT ALWAYS NOT
ALWAYS GO TO A CSU YOU'RE OR YOU
SEE.
AND AT GOING TO GPO GPA ONLY --
CREATES A LOT OF ACTIVITIES
BECAUSE NOT EVERY SCHOOL HAS THE
SAME GRADING SCALE NOT EVERY
SCHOOL HAS HONORS CLASSES
INTERNATIONAL BACCALAUREATE AP
CLASSES TO BOB.
THATTHAT GPA ABOVE THAT FOUR
POINT OH LEVEL.
CONCERN NUMBER FOR THE SAT ACT
DO NOT PROVIDE PROPER
ACCOMMODATIONS.
THIS BILL AND FEDERAL LAW
REQUIRE ACCOMMODATIONS
ACCOMMODATIONS ARE PART OF THE
PEER REVIEW PROCESS REQUIRED FOR
APPROVAL BY THE US DEPARTMENT.
OF EDUCATION.
ACCOMMODATIONS ARE BASED ON A
STUDENT'S I EP OR FIVE OH FOUR
PLAN ON ARE COORDINATED BY A
SCHOOL STAFF MY SCHOOL STAFF OR
COUNSELOR IT'S BETTER TO HAVE.
SOMEONE -- FROM THE SCHOOL STAFF
A COUNSELOR -- MAYBE SOONER
ACTION WITH THE WITH WITH
SPECIAL EDUCATION TEAM WHEN WHEN
IMPLEMENTING THESE TESTS ARE
TAKING THESE TESTS OF THE SCHOOL
LEVEL WHY HAVE A PARENT TRYING
TO GO SHEET THAT ON A SATURDAY
MORNING.
AT A PLACE FAR AWAY FROM THE
HIGH SCHOOL.
IF ALL THE REQUIREMENTS ARE NOT
BAD.
THE STATE THE THE SUPERINTENDENT
WILL NOT APPROVE THE ALTERNATE
ASSESSMENT.
THE CURRENT COLLEGE ADMISSIONS
SCANDAL MAKES THE CASE FOR AB
SEVEN FIVE ONE BY ENSURING THAT
ALL STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS TO THE
TEST.
AND PROVIDING A SIX SECURE
ENVIRONMENT FOR THAT TEST I KNOW
FROM MY OWN PERSONAL EXPERIENCE
THURMOND QUESTIONS ABOUT S. BACK.
DIA SAFETY ASSOCIATED WITH THE
THE S. BACK TEST AS WELL.
SO THIS BILL IS ABOUT EQUALITY
EQUITY AN OPPORTUNITY.
PEOPLE ON THE GROUND NEED THIS
TOOL STUDENTS NAY THIS TOOL
TEACHERS NAY THIS TOOL PARENTS
NEED THIS TOOL CALIFORNIA NEEDS
THIS TOOL I TURN IT BACK TO YOU
MANAGER WITH ME TODAY IS A
DOCTOR ROSANNA MACHETE -- FROM
THE SUPERINTENDENT OF THE NAP
ALL NAPA VALLEY UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND JASON CHAN IS HERE --
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF STUDENT COUNCILS.
THANK YOU SIMPLY MEMBER WELCOME
TO WITNESSES TWO MINUTES EACH.
GOOD MORNING MADAM MADAM CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AGAIN MY NAME
IS DOCTOR ASSIGNMENT -- SETTING
I CURRENTLY SERVE AS A
SUPERINTENDENT OF THE NAPA
VALLEY UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND I'M JUST COMPLETING MY FIRST
YEAR IF TENURE THERE AFTER
SERVING ALSO FIVE YEARS AS THE
DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT OF THE
FAMILY UNDER UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
I'M HERE TODAY BOTH ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS AND ON
BEHALF OF Y DISTRICT IN SUPPORT
OF AB SEVEN FIFTY ONE AFTER
IMPLEMENTING THE SAT DAY AS A
COLLEGE READINESS INITIATIVE IN
BOTH THE FAMILY UNDER UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND NOW AND NAPA
VALLEY.
I KNOW COLLEAGUES DISTRICT AND
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS ACROSS THE
STATE OR SUPPORTIVE OF AB SEVEN
FIFTY ONE BECAUSE IT ADDRESSES
THE COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY GAP.
THAT PLAGUES ARE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC SCHOOL SSTEMS BY OPENING
DOORS TO HIGHER EDUCATION. FOR
STUDENTS THROUGH OFFERING A
COLLEGE ENTRANCE TESTS LIKE THE
SAT OR S. H. A. B. C. T. DURING
THE SCHOOL DAY AGAIN AT NO COST
FOR ALL STUDENTS.
AS LONG AS HE'S TO SERVE AS A
CRITICAL COMPONENT OF THE
COLLEGE ADMISSION PROCESS HOW
CAN SCHOOL SYSTEMS NOT OFFER.
THIS OPPORTUNITY WITHIN THE
CONTEXT OF THEIR OWN HOME HIGH
SCHOOL ENVIRONMENT IF WE ARE
SERIOUS ABOUT COLLEGE AND CAREER
AT THE STATE LEVEL THIS
INITIATIVE NEED YOUR SUPPORT AND
YOUR APPROVAL.
IT'S REALLY PROBLEMATIC IF WE
CONTINUE TO SUSTAIN THE STATUS
QUO REALITY WHERE BY IT IS UP TO
FAMILIES AND STUDENTS ALONE
OUTSIDE OF THE SCHOOL TO FIND
THEIR WAY TO THIS IMPORTANT
COMPONENT OF THE COLLEGE PATHWAY.
THIS COLLEGE ADMISSION
REQUIREMENTS SHOULD NOT HAPPEN
FOR STUDENTS DESPITE THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT BUT RATHER BECAUSE OF
THEIR SCHOOL DISTRICT.
LIKE I MENTIONED I SUCCESSFULLY
ABOUT SCALED PSC TI IN AS EIGHTY
DAYS IN SAN LEANDRO CONDUCTED A
PILOT THIS YEAR IN ENVY YOU ES
DE AND I WILL BE SCALING IT NEXT
YEAR IN THE TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY TWENTY SCHOOL YOUR FOR
ALL OF MY HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS.
YOU MAY I ASK WHY A NEW
SUPERINTENDENT.
WOULD PRESENT THIS INITIATIVE AS
A NON NEGOTIABLE TO THEIR LOCAL
SCHOOL BOARD STAFF AND PARENT
COMMUNITY SIMPLY PUT
IMPLEMENTING THE S. E. T. DAY
HAS BEEN ONE OF THE MOST
TRANSFORMATIONAL INITIATIVES.
OF MY PROFESSIONAL TWENTY YEAR
CAREER HERE'S THE BOTTOM LINE BY
ENSURING.
I'M SORRY BY ENSURING TRUE
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO THE S.
EIGHTEEN THE SCHOOL SETTING TO
ALL STUDENTS PARTICULARLY THOSE
WHO'VE BEEN HISTORICALLY UNDER
SERVED.
THIS SIMPLE SYSTEMIC ACT
PROVIDED THE KEYS TO THE DOOR
THAT HAVE NOT ALWAYS BEEN OPENED.
IN MY EXPERIENCE IT EXPERIENCE
SUDDENLY A SIGNIFICANT MAJORITY
OF STUDENTS WERE TALKING ABOUT
COLLEGE THE SAT DAY OPENS THE
DIALOGUE ACROSS ALL OF YOUR HIGH
SCHOOL CAMPUS.
STUDENTS WHO MAY NOT HAVE BEEN
AGGRESSIVELY PURSUING THE
COLLEGE OPTION SUDDENLY ARE
EXPLORING THE COLLEGE OPTION
THIS IS ALSO TRUE FOR PARENTS
IMMIGRANT PARENTS OF POTENTIAL
FIRST GENERATION STUDENTS LIKE
MINE THREE DECADES AGO ALSO
SUDDENLY HAVING CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT COLLEGES THEY RECEIVE
LITERATURE AT THEIR HOMES.
AND ASK QUESTIONS ABOUT THE BIG
TEST DAY ON CAMPUS AS WE
STRATEGICALLY MARKET EFFORTS TO
OUR PARA COMMUNITIES
PARTICULARLY THOSE THAT ARE
CULTURALLY AND LINGUISTICALLY
DIVERSE.
IF WE WANT TO QUICKLY CREATE A
COLLEGE GOING CULTURE AND ON OUR
HIGH SCHOOL CAMPUSES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND REMOVE ENTRENCHED
BARRIERS LIKE I DID FOR MY
STUDENTS AT ALL OF MY HIGH
SCHOOLS.
I SAY ADMINISTER THE S. C. T.
DAY IF LOCAL DISTRICTS AND
SCHOOL BOARDS LIKE MINE DECIDE
TO LEAD FROM THE PRINCIPLES OF
EQUITY AND SOCIAL JUSTICE.
I SAY IMPLEMENT THE SAT DAY.
Q. SHEET IN YOUR TIME SEE OF ONE
MINUTE THANK YOU -- SORRY.
MADAM CHAIR -- GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS JASON CHAN AND I'M A
HIGH SCHOOL JUNIOR FROM -- SAN
FRANCISCO -- MOST OF THE
GOVERNMENTAL AFFAIRS POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF STUDENT COUNCILS
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
PATHWAYS TO COLLEGE ACT BECAUSE
IT INCREASES ACCESS TO A CRUCIAL
ABOUT -- ARE CRUCIAL ASPECT OF
COLLEGE ADMISSIONS THE SAT AND
ACT.
SAT AND ACT OR SUPPORTED BY
MARRIOTT A FREE TEST PREPARATION
RESOURCES FOR THE COLLEGE WERE
ITSELF OR FROM SERVICES LIKE
KHAN ACADEMY WHICH MAKES DURING
PREPARATION FOR THE EXAM MORE
EQUITABLE AND EASY ACCESS.
AND BECAUSE THE SCORE THAT
STUDENTS EARN ON THE ACT AND SAT
CAN BE USED TO APPLY TO COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES AROUND THE
COUNTRY STUDENTS RECOGNIZE THE
WRECKED BENEFITS FROM THE
RESULTS AND ARE GREATLY.
INCENTIVIZE TO DO THEIR BEST
RESULTING IN A MORE ACCURATE AND
POSITIVE ASSESSMENT OF STUDENTS
AND THEIR SCHOOLS.
THE S. EIGHTY PROVIDES USEFUL
CALLED SEARCH SERVICES AND
ALLOWS COLLEGES TO REACH OUT TO
STUDENTS DIRECTLY OFFERING
CAMPUS INFORMATION AND
SCHOLARSHIPS AND STUDENTS WHO DO
NOT THINK COLLEGES FOR THEM WILL
BE MORE LIKELY TO APPLY FOR
COLLEGE AN OPPORTUNITY WE WANT
ALL STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA TO
HAVE.
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF STUDENT COUNCILS
AND AS A STUDENT I HOPE THE
COMMITTEE VOTES I ON THE
PATHWAYS COLLEGE ACT TO THE
EVERY CALIFORNIA STUDENT HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DEMONSTRATE THEIR
ACADEMIC EXCELLENCE AND GO TO
COLLEGE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR JEFF FROST
REPRESENTING THIS THE IDEA.
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SUBURBAN SCHOOL DISTRICTS THE
CENTRAL VALLEY EDUCATION
COALITION SAN JOSE UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LATINO
SUPERINTENDENTS.
AND ADMINISTRATORS IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
RON WRAPPING BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND SUPPORT.
CAITLYN JOHN ON THE OF THE
SENSES GOOD UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN THE SAN BERNADINO
COUNTY DISTRICT ADVOCATE FOR
BETTER SCHOOLS AND SUPPORT.
ERICA HOFFMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE A CO SPONSOR
THIS MEASURE AND WE GREATLY --
DR -- THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING DEREK CLINICS ON
BEHALF OF THE SMALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION THE POUNDS
FOR HIS PENINSULA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS JEFF BACA
REPRESENTING THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS
AND SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING KYLE HELENA BEHALF
FOR THE AVID CENTER SEX CITY
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
TORRANCE UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AMY BROWN REPRESENTING THE CITY
OF LONG BEACH IN SUPPORT.
PATTY HERRERA REPRESENTING SAN
DIEGO OAKLAND A CURRENT IN ARCO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
SUPPORT.
KEVIN FROM ROOM HALF THE
CONTINUED FIGHT SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
BLACK SCHOOL EDUCATORS AND
STRONG SUPPORT.
MARTEL BUT ON THE OTHER
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS A CO SPONSOR IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
BETTER MORE TEAR THREADING
NATION ON BEHALF OF COALITION OF
BUSINESS LEADERS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SIR ANY ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT.
THOSE IN OPPOSITION.
COME ON UP.
YOU CAN SIT RIGHT OVER HERE.
BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY TO
WITNESSES TWO MINUTES EACH.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS I'M BRIAN
RIVAS REPRESENTING THE EDUCATION
TRUST WEST.
OF CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
INTENT.
AND APPLAUD EFFORTS LIKE THE
ONES THAT WE JUST HEARD ABOUT
ABOUT FREE AS THE T. DAY.
OF THE CONCERN WE HAVE WITH THIS
BILL I'LL I'LL.
LIFT UP TO CONCERNS THAT WE
THINK -- RESULT IN A NET
NEGATIVE WHEN YOU DO WHEN YOU
LOOK AT ALL THE TRADE OFFS
INVOLVED WITH THIS BILL.
FIRST HAS TO DO WITH
COMPARABILITY OF SCORES.
WE ARE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
UNDERMINING THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
OUR NEW ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM IN
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL DASHBOARD.
AND THAT RELIES ON BEING ABLE TO
COMPARE STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT
ACROSS DISTRICTS AND THEN
HOLDING DISTRICTS ACCOUNTABLE TO
COMMON STANDARDS. FOR STUDENT
ACHIEVEMENT.
SO WHAT THIS DOES IS IT SAYS
THAT WE'RE GOING TO USE ONE SET
OF TESTS AND SOME DISTRICTS IN
THE DIFFERENCE THAT.
IN OTHERS.
IN PROPONENTS MAY ARGUE THAT THE
THE SCORES CAN BE CORRELATED AND
WE CAN USE THEM INTERCHANGEABLY.
WE DISAGREE WITH THAT AND WE
THINK LOTS OF THINGS CAN BE
CORRELATED -- BUT STILL BE VERY
DIFFERENT HEIGHT AND WEIGHT CAN
BE CORRELATED BUT THE
OBSERVATION OF WHAT YOU'RE
LOOKING AT IS STILL VERY
DIFFERENT.
SO WE THINK IT'S A MISTAKE TO
SAY THAT WE'RE GONNA USE
DIFFERING TESTS FOR THE SAME
PURPOSE IN THE DASHBOARD AND
THAT'S GOING TO WEAKEN OUR
ABILITY TO SEE WHAT'S GOING ON
IN DISTRICTS AND SEE.
WHETHER DISTRICTS ARE PREPARING
STUDENTS NOT ONLY TO TAKE THE
TEST BUT GAME ADMISSION AND
SUCCEED AT THE POST SECONDARY
LEVEL -- AND REMEMBERED THE NEW
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM IS A
PASSIVE ONE TRANSPARENCY IS
REALLY ALL WE HAVE GOING FOR IS
THAT.
THINGS ARE NOT GOING WELL IN A
DISTRICT THE ABILITY TO SEE THAT
IS REALLY ALL WE'VE GOT.
AND IT'S GOING TO CLOUD THE
ABILITY OF THE STATE TO DIRECT
SUPPORTS WHAT WE THINK IT'S
NEEDED.
SECONDLY WE SEE BIG PROBLEMS
WITH THE S. A. T..
THE DATA DON'T LIE WHEN YOU LOOK
AT OUTCOMES AFRICAN AMERICAN AND
LATINO STUDENTS SCORE BELOW.
ASIAN AND WHITE PEERS.
WHAT THIS BILL WOULD
DRAMATICALLY TO IS THE ESCALATOR
OR INCREASE THE USE OF THE S. A.
T. IN PUBLIC EDUCATION BOTH BOTH
AT THE HIGHER EDUCATION LEVEL?
AND A KEY -- TWELVE WE THINK
THAT'S A MISTAKE.
WE THINK THAT -- THE RECENT
COLLEGE ADMISSIONS SCANDAL JUST
KIND OF REMINDED US WHAT MANY
RESEARCHERS HAPPENS TELLING US
FOR A LONG TIME IS THAT.
OTHER MEASURES ARE VALUE
AVAILABLE LIKE HIGH SCHOOL GPA
OR EVEN HIGH SCHOOL GPA IN
COMBINATION WITH S. BACK WERE
RIGHT NOW WHAT YOU'RE DOING WITH
THIS BILLS PROLIFERATING -- A
BARRIER TO HIGHER EDUCATION BIG
BY BOLSTERING THE S. A. T. THAT
DATA SHOW ARE.
THE SAT IS KEEPING STUDENTS OUT
WHO HAVE DEMONSTRATED A HIGH
PROBABILITY FOR SUCCESS -- WE
THINK A DIFFERENT APPROACH LIKE
WHAT'S EMBODIED IN A RESOLUTION
BY MR MCCARTY IS A PREFERABLE
WAY TO GO YOU OUGHT TO BE ASKING
THE SYSTEMS TO TAKE A LOOK AT
BEST A TEA IN ITS SHORTCOMINGS.
AND IF THEY FIND WHAT
RESEARCHERS HAVE BEEN TELLING US
FOR QUITE SOME TIME PHASE THAT
OUT.
SO.
WE WOULD ASK THAT YOU YOUR THREE
MINUTES SO SHE HAS ONE MINUTE
[inaudible]
NO PLEASE.
NEXT WITNESS YOU HAVE ONE MINUTE.
YES THANK YOU MADAM TURN MEMBERS
LISKI AND WITH PUBLIC ADVOCATES --
WE OPPOSE THE MEASURE ALONG WITH
OUR COMMUNITY PARTNERS
CALIFORNIANS FOR JUSTICE AND
CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER.
STUDENT ORGANIZATIONS IN AN
ORGANIZATION OF FOCUSING ON THE
SUCCESS OF ENGLISH LEARNERS --
WE OPPOSE BECAUSE WE THINK THAT
WE SHOULD NOT A PRIVILEGE THE
SAT AND THAT A WHILE WE CAN'T
CHANGE.
OUT OF STATE COLLEGES
REQUIREMENTS WE CAN USE OUR
POWERS AS A NATIONAL LEADERS FOR
GOOD BY SETTING THE THE STANDARD
THAT WE WON'T PRIVILEGE THIS --
THE THE LET THE PLAYING FIELD
FOR LOW INCOME STUDENTS ABILITY
TO ACCESS PREPARATION RETAKING
THE EXAM WHEN NECESSARY WE DON'T
BELIEVE THAT'S GUARANTEED IN THE
BILLAND WE ALSO HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT ACCOMMODATION.
THE ACCESSIBILITY OF FOR ALL
LANGUAGE AND ABILITIES IS REALLY
NOT PART OF THE GOAL OF THE ACT
OR SAT.
AND FOR THESE REASONS -- WE
OPPOSE AND WE URGE AND NO VOTE
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING -- MADAM
CHAIRPERSON MARK THIS YEAR AGO
CITY AS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
BILINGUAL EDUCATION AND
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIANS
TOGETHER.
AND WE OPPOSE FOR THE REASONS
ALREADY GIVEN A PROVIDED BY
PUBLIC ADVOCATES AND THE
REPRESENTATIVE FROM A TRUST WEST
THANK YOU [inaudible]
YOU.
GOOD MORNING PARTIAL TRAVIE WITH
THE UC SANTA SO SOLUTION WITH A
CORD THE CONCERNS ARE THE
BROUGHT UP AND ALSO SEND
OPPOSITION.
REPORTER AT THAT WE ALREADY ARE
QUESTIONING THE THE USE OF A C.
T. AS AN ADMISSIONS PROCESS AT
ALL UNIVERSITIES AND GIVEN ALL
OF THE DATA THAT'S OUT THERE WE
DON'T THINK IT'S TIME TO EXPAND
THE USE OF THESE TEST SCORES.
THANK YOU.
IMAN MAJID WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES CHANCES
OFFICE WE DON'T HAVE A FORMAL
POSITION ON THIS BILL BUT WE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT EXPANDING THE
USE OF STANDARDIZED TESTING WHEN
IT'S BEEN SHOWN THAT THESE TESTS
HAVE A WEAK RELATIONSHIP WITH
FUTURE STUDENT SUCCESS.
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
HAVE ALREADY REMOVED ASSESSMENT
TESTING OR ALREADY REMOVING
ASSESSMENT TESTING AS A MEANS OF
COURSE PLACEMENT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION.
SEEING AND HEARING THEN WE'LL GO
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
CENTER DURACELL.
YES -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER CAN.
ESCAPE COULD YOU RESPOND TO TO
THE ISSUES THAT WERE RAISED ON
THE COMPATIBILITY ACROSS
DISTRICTS AND SECOND IS -- SAT
SCORES BIAS AGAINST --
COMMITTEES OF COLOR OR LOW
INCOME STUDENTS AGAIN THIS BILL
IS IN ABOUT.
WHETHER OR NOT THE SAT OR ACT
SHOULD BE USED FOR COLLEGE
ENTRANCE -- AS A MEASURE OF
COLLEGE ENTRANCE THIS IS AS LONG
AS IT'S GOING TO BE REQUIRED.
WHY WOULDN'T WE GIVE OUR
STUDENTS THIS OPPORTUNITY TAKEN
AT THE HIGH SCHOOL LEVEL?
NOW AGAIN -- WITH SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS RAISED -- THIS BILL
CHARGES THIS THE THE THE
SUPERINTEND WOULD HAVE TO
APPROVE.
ALTERNATIVE ASSESSMENTS AND THE
ASSESSMENTS MUST MEET SPECIFIED
REQUIREMENTS THEY MUST BE
ALIGNED TO THE STATE --
STANDARDS MUST BE -- CON KOREAN
STUDIES -- TO ENSURE THAT THIS
IS A FAIR TEST TO ENSURE THIS
TEST ALIGNS.
WITH OUR ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM.
CAN.
CAN I JUST ALL OF THESE -- FIVE
AS THOSE QUESTIONS COME UP
OBVIOUSLY RAISES A A BIT OF A
RED FLAG WHICH I'M SURE YOU'VE.
DONE A LOT OF WORK WITH -- WHAT
APPEALS TO ME IS THAT -- THERE
IS THERE ARE A NUMBER OF THINGS
THAT HAVE TO BE DONE BEFORE --
THIS IS ACTUALLY IMPLEMENTED ONE
AND SECOND -- YOUR THINKING OUT
OF THE BOX AND I THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT IN EDUCATION PUBLIC
EDUCATION RIGHT NOW WE HAVE GOT
TO TAKE.
UP MORE DRAMATIC STEPS.
IN THE DIRECTION OF NOT THE SAME
OLD SAME OLD BECAUSE IT'S IT'S
JUST NOT WORKING -- FOR TWO DAYS
NEEDS AND FOR TODAY STUDENTS SO
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS REALLY
APPEALED TO ME AND JUST TO WATCH
OUT FOR THE THINGS THAT ARE
BROUGHT UP BY BUT OTHER FOLKS
BECAUSE I DO THINK THAT THEY'RE
VALID.
GENERALLY VALID CONCERNS AND
JUST TO KEEP US ON OUR TOES AS
TO WATCH OUT FOR THEM.
LISTENING TO STANDARD RAZA GO
AHEAD YOU'RE FINE.
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS CENTER CHIANG.
APOLOGIZE THERE HAD A FLIGHT IN
THIS MORNING BUT I JUST WANT TO
COMMEND THE AUTHOR.
FOR THIS BILL AND I'D LOVE TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME [inaudible]
ABSOLUTELY.
THANK YOU CENTER CHIANG ANYONE
ELSE.
SOME OF WHICH I TO CLOSE I JUST.
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE I APPRECIATE
THE SENATOR'S COMMENTS ABOUT
REALLY HIGHLIGHTING TO ME THAT'S
WHY IT'S SUCH A BIG DEAL TO ME
AS A CLASSROOM TEACHER.
IS A CLASSROOM TEACHER I LONG
FOR AN ASSESSMENT SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA AND MAYBE MAN CHAIR
YOU AND I CAN WORK ON THAT GOING
FORWARD -- BUT AGAIN -- WHAT THE
FOLKS OF YOUR LONG FOR IS
COLLEGE ENTRANCE FOR ALL
STUDENTS SO I I ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE?
THANK YOU SOME A MEMBER AS
SOMEONE MOVE THE BILL.
THE BILL THANK YOU THE BILL'S
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR WELL
BOUNCE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ITEM TEN AB SEVEN FIFTY ONE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA.
LEYVA I WILL TRY WILK I CHIANG
CHIANG I'D RUSSELL RUSSELL AYE
GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN.
WE WILL LEAVE THAT BELONG CALL
FOR ADDITIONAL VOTES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE WE ARE MOVING
TO ITEM FOR AB ONE NINETY SEVEN
BEGIN WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU AND GOOD MORNING --
MADAM CHAIR AT ME AND MEMBERS
I'M HERE TO PRESENT TO YOU A. B.
ONE NINE SEVEN WHICH REQUIRES
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT OFFER A
KINDERGARTEN PROGRAM. TO
IMPLEMENT AT LEAST ONE FULL DAY
OF KINDERGARTEN.
ACCORDING TO THE EDUCATION
COMMISSION OF THE STATES.
FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN ATTENDANCE
CAN HELP THOSE ACHIEVEMENT GAPS
EARLY ON IN A CHILD'S EDUCATION.
LONGER SCHOOL DAYS IN ABLE
CHILDREN TO RECEIVE MORE
INDIVIDUALIZED ACADEMICALLY
FOCUSED AND MEANINGFUL
INSTRUCTION FROM TEACHERS AS
WELL AS MORE TIME INTERACTING
WITH THEIR PEERS.
THIS CAN LEAD TO INCREASED
SCORES AND GREATER LONG TERM
ACHIEVEMENT.
THE POSITIVE EFFECTS OF THE FULL
DAY KINDERGARTEN ARE EVEN MORE
PRONOUNCED FOR MINORITY AND LOW
INCOME CHILDREN.
HOWEVER A TWENTY SEVENTEEN ITS
SOURCE REPORT STATES THAT ONLY
70% OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS
SERVING KINDERGARTEN AGE
CHILDREN ARE OFFERING FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN.
CALIFORNIA LEADS BEHIND MANY OF
THE STATES THAT OFFER FULL DAY
PROGRAMS FOR A LARGER PORTION OF
THEIR KINDERGARTEN POPULATION.
BECAUSE MORE AND MORE CHILDREN
PARTICIPATE IN PRESCHOOL IT
EARLY EDUCATION PROGRAMS
KINDERGARTEN IS NO LONGER THERE
FIRST SCHOOL EXPERIENCE.
MANY ARE USED TO A FULL DAY
PROGRAM AND READY FOR A FULL DAY
OF KINDERGARTEN.
THE DIESEL HOURS PROVIDED AND AB
ONE NINE SEVEN WOULD EXPAND
INSTRUCTION TIME FOR ALL
STUDENTS GIVE TEACHERS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE AN
ACADEMICALLY RICH EXPERIENCE FOR
EVERY YOUNG LEARNER.
SOME OF YOU MAY KNOW THAT WE IS
THAT AS A AS A STATE DID A STUDY
ON ON ALL DAY CAN ABOUT ALL FULL
DAY KINDERGARTEN SOME YEARS AGO
AND FOUND IT.
THAT AS IS POINTED OUT ONLY 70%
OF OUR SCHOOLS ARE OFFERING IT --
THAT IT HAS A TREMENDOUS AND
POSITIVE EFFECTS ON ON CHILDREN
PARTICULARLY THOSE OF LOW INCOME
AND OBVIOUSLY IT HELPS IN TERMS
OF WHAT WE HAVE NOW WHICH IS TO
WORKING FAMILIES.
AND HAVING A THREE HOUR
KINDERGARTEN EXPERIENCE AS AN
ADVERSE AFFECT ONE CHILD CARE
AND OTHER KINDS OF THINGS THAT
ARE THERE.
SO THIS -- THIS BILL HAS BEEN --
OBVIOUSLY IT'S A PRIORITY FOR
GOVERNOR MORE RECENTLY -- LAST
YEAR WE PUT A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS INTO A TO HELP SCHOOLS
MAKE THE TRANSITION ISSUES BUT
IT HAS THREE HUNDRED MILLION AND
IT.
SO WE NEED TO REQUIREOUR SCHOOL
DISTRICT TO AT LEAST OFFER ONE
PROGRAM A FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
BOTH.
THANK YOU SIMPLY MEMBER AS THEIR
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
HI MAKE IT THE CHRISTIANS AND ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATE PAYMENT PROGRAM
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
MONEY GRAMS ON BEHALF OF FIRST
FIVE CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT --
HAIRS WITH DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
ALEXANDER CONTENT AS ON BEHALF
OF THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
THE INJURY ON BEHALF OF PROJECT
LEAD THE WAY AND THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR THE GIFTED IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
DONNA ARE TO GIVE WHICH
CALIFORNIA STATE PTA IN SUPPORT.
BETTER MORE TEAR ON BEHALF OF
FIGHT CRIME INVEST IN KIDS AND
BRING NATION AND WE'RE IN
SUPPORT.
JERRY FORESIGHT A BAND OF VOTERS
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MARTHA'S THEIR AGO CITY AREAS
CITY OF REPRESENTING THE DELTA
KAPPA GAMMA CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
DEONTIC JACKSON REPRESENTING
FRESNO STATE AND OF LACI P.
SUPPORT.
ELIZABETH ASK ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
BUSINESS OFFICIALS WE ACTUALLY
HAVE A SUPPORTIVE AMENDED
POSITION WE'RE ASKING TO PUSH
BACK THE IMPLEMENTATION DATE WE
BELIEVE THAT SCHOOLS THE MORE
THAN TWO YOURSELF SCALLOP THE
PROGRAMS BILL COMPLY
INFRASTRUCTURE IN A TRUCK THE
WORK FORCE TO TEACH THESE
CLASSES.
SO WE HOPE THAT WITH AN EXTENDED
TIME FRAME AND IN LINE WITH THE
THREE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
THAT WAS APPROVED BY THE BUDGET
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE.
SCHOOL DISTRICT WILL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BETTER TRANSITION
TO A FULL DAY PROGRAM THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY THOUGHT ABOUT IT
AND WE HAVE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS
AXALTA SUPPORTIVE AMEND THAT ON
THE BILL I'LL BE COMING DOCTOR
WEBER FOR THE EFFORTS TO TRY TO
INCREASE ACCESS FOR KINDERGARTEN
ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
OUR PROPOSED AMENDMENTS IN
ADDITION TO THE TIMELINE
EXTENSION IS REALLY THINKING
ABOUT HOW TO MITIGATE ANY IMPACT
ON SMALL RURAL AND REMOTE SCHOOL
DISTRICT CALIFORNIA WHO MAY NOT
HAVE CREDENTIALED TEACHERS OR
THE ABILITY TO CONVERT HALF THE
PER AND INTO FORTY PROGRAMS.
AND WE LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH
AUTHORS OFFICE TO ADDRESS SOME
OF THESE ISSUES AND OTHERS THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING AND HEARING MEN WILL COME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE OUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I APPRECIATE ALL THE
COMMENTS AND WE HAVE BEEN
LOOKING INTO THE AREAS THAT HAVE
BEEN MEANT TO MENTION TO THEIR
THEIR GENERAL AREAS THAT CAN.
EASILY BE ACCOMMODATED -- BUT WE
DO BELIEVE THAT ALL DAY
KINDERGARTEN AT LEAST AN OPTION
AT MOST SCHOOLS IS IT NECESSARY
OF KIND OF THING THAT WE NEED TO
HAVE -- BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT IT
HAS A POSITIVE EFFECT ON OUR
CHILDREN PARTICULARLY THOSE WHO
IN LOW INCOME NEIGHBORHOODS AND
COMMUNITIES -- AND MOST OF OUR
STUDENTS ARE READY FOR FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN BECAUSE THEY'VE
ALREADY DONE ALMOST OF THEM FULL
DAY PRE SCHOOL.
AND BECAUSE ESPECIALLY WOOD
WORKING FAMILIES AND SO WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YA VOTE ON
THIS MATTER AND WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU SAM A MEMBER WEBER DO
WE HAVE A MOTION FOR THE BILL.
MOVED BY SENATOR CHIANG MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM FOUR AB LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE WILK HI WILK I CHIANG.
CHIANG I'D RUSSELL RUSSELL AYE
GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN.
ALL RIGHT WILL BE THAT ON CALL
FOR MEMBERS AT ON THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
I SEE ASSEMBLYMEMBER SMITH COME
ON DOWN.
WE ARE GOING TO GO TO ITEM
FIFTEEN A. B..
NINE SIXTY SEVEN ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BEGIN WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
GREAT GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME AT THIS HEARING THIS MORNING
FOR THIS MEASURE.
AB NINE SIX SEVEN INCLUDES
CHARTER SCHOOL COMMUNITIES IN
THE EL CAP PROCESS THE LOCAL
CONTROL ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN
PROCESS AND SUPPORTS THE
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR'S GOAL
OF ALIGNING CHARTER SCHOOL
TRANSPARENCY.
AND ACCOUNTABILITY WITHOUT OF
ALL STATE LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES. FIVE YEARS CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN TASKED WITH
DEVELOPING DATA DRIVEN AND
RIGOROUS LOCAL ENGAGEMENT AND
MEANINGFUL STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT PROCESS SEES IN EL
CAP DEVELOPMENT AND DELIVERY.
THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING RECORD
FORMULA REQUIRES THAT ELEAZAR
CONSULT WITH PARENTS STUDENTS
AND THE COMMUNITY AS THEY
DEVELOP THEIR L. CAPS AND
STUDIES HAVE DEMONSTRATED THAT
SCHOOLS THAT HAVE MEANINGFUL
ENGAGEMENT WITH THOSE
COMMUNITIES.
HAVE HAVE BEEN THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL AT ELIMINATING THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
DURING MY TENURE AS A SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBER WE HAD AN EXTREMELY
ROBUST EL CAP PROCESS.
IN DOING SO WE WERE ABLE TO
ENGAGE PARENTS AND STUDENTS AND
STAFF IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF A
USEFUL PLANNING TOOL.
UNFORTUNATELY AT PRESENT NOT ALL
PARENTS AND STUDENTS HAVE THE
ABILITY AND MEANS TO ACCESS
THEIR LOCAL SCHOOL BOARD
LEADERSHIP AND GOVERNING
STRUCTURES TO PARTICIPATE IN
THIS IMPORTANT PROCESS.
AB NINE SIX SEVEN BRINGS CHARTER
SCHOOLS INTO ALIGNMENT WITH ALL
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND
PROVIDES THE EL CAP AS A UNIFORM
AND STANDARD BASIS OF COMPARISON
TO MONITOR STUDENT OUTCOMES
ACROSS THE EIGHT STATE
PRIORITIES.
AND ESPECIALLY AMONG TARGETED
SUBGROUPS ACROSS ALL PUBLIC
SCHOOLS.
I AM CONFIDENT THAT THIS
CONSISTENCY WILL LEAD TO GREATER
COMMUNITY SUPPORT FOR ELLIE
EIGHT AND CHARTER ENDEAVORS A
CLEAR ROAD MAP FOR LEN CHARGER
BUDGET PRIORITIES.
AND AN ONGOING FOCUS ON
IMPROVING OUTCOMES FOR ALL OF
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS.
WITH ME TODAY A RIGEL SPENCER
MASSARO FROM PUBLIC ADVOCATES
SPONSOR OF THE BILL AND ROBSON
SWIFT A RECENT GRADUATE FROM
WEST CONTRA COSTA UNIFIED.
THANK YOU SIMPLY WOMAN -- TO
WITNESSES TWO MINUTES EACH
PLEASE.
THE MORNING SENATORS RACHEL
SPENCER MASSARO WITH PUBLIC
ADVOCATES.
AT TWO YEARS AGO CHARTER SCHOOL
PARENTS AND RICHMOND --
REQUESTED A TRAINING ON THE EL
CAP FOR CHARTER SCHOOLS THEY'D
SEEN US DELIVER MANY SUCH
TRAININGS TO DISTRICT PARENTS
OVER THE YEARS THIS THIS TASK
COVER PROVED MORE DIFFICULT THAN
ANTICIPATED WE HAD A HARD TIME
FINDING MANY OF THE CHARTER
SCHOOL ALL CAPS.
A SOMEWHERE IN DRAFT FORM AND
OTHERS DIDN'T CONTAIN ALL OF THE
SUPPLEMENTAL IN CONCENTRATION
FUNDS GENERATED BY THE HIGH NEED
STUDENTS IN THE CHARTER SCHOOL.
AT THE TRAINING PARENTS DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND WHY THE SCHOOLS HAD
FEWER OR NO REQUIREMENTS RUN EL
CAP ENGAGEMENT.
TRANSPARENCY ACCOUNTABILITY AS
COMPARED WITH THE DISTRICT
COUNTERPARTS.
AFTER THIS TRAINING PUBLIC
ADVOCATES CONDUCTED AN ANALYSIS
OF SEVENTY CHARTER SCHOOL --
CAMPS PUBLISHED IN AUGUST OF
LAST YEAR.
WE FOUND THAT ONE THIRD OF THE
CHARTER SCHOOL EXAMINED HAD NO
EL CAP ON LINE EVEN AFTER EMAIL
REQUESTS TO THE SCHOOL WE WERE
NOT ABLE TO OBTAIN THEM.
OF THE ALL CAPS WE COULD FIND
MORE THAN TWO THIRDS OF THE
STATE FUNDS GENERATED BY HIGH
NEED STUDENTS OVER THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS WAS UNACCOUNTED.
FOR ONLY 20% CLEARLY MEASURED
HOW THE ENGAGED PARENTS AND
SCHOOL DECISION MAKING AND ONLY
37% DESCRIBE COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT HOW COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT HAD IMPACT THEIR COP.
91% OF CHARTER SCHOOLS SERVING
15% OR MORE ENGLISH LEARNERS DID
NOT POST THEIR CAPS IN A
LANGUAGE OTHER THAN ENGLISH.
AND NONE OF THE CHARTER SCHOOLS
EXAMINED PROPERLY DOCUMENTED HOW
THEY WERE INCREASING ARE
IMPROVING I SERVICES FOR HIGH
NEED STUDENTS AS A LAW REQUIRES.
THREE GAUGE MEANT TRANSPARENCY
ACCOUNTABILITY AB NINE SIXTY
SEVEN WOULD ADDRESS THESE ISSUES
BRING PARITY AND EQUITY TO THE
CHARTER SCHOOL EL CAP PROCESS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ROBIN
SAID I JUST GRADUATED FROM DE
ANZA HIGH SCHOOL IN WEST CONTRA
COSTA UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
AND I WAS AN EXECUTIVE MEMBER OF
MY DISTRICTS.
LOOK CONTROL ACCOUNTABILITY
PARENT AND STUDENT COMMITTEE WHO
CUT THAT ALLAH -- BECAUSE
STUDENTS AT MY DISTRICT AND IN
GENERAL I'M NOT HEARD IN
DECISIONS THAT DIRECTLY IMPACT
THEIR FUTURE.
AND THEIR EDUCATION AND THIS IS
ESPECIALLY TRUE OF THOSE
STUDENTS THE AND DUPLICATED
COUNT.
I ALONG WITH PUBLIC ADVOCATE
SUPPORT AB NINE SIX SEVEN
BECAUSE I WANT STUDENTS AND
PARENTS AND CHARTER SCHOOLS TO
HAVE THE SAME OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE THEIR VOICES HEARD.
I WENT TO THE FIRST MEET MEETING
OF MY DL CAP COMMITTEE ABOUT TWO
YEARS AGO.
WHERE COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS
AND PARENTS CAME TOGETHER TO
HOLD THE DISTRICT ACCOUNTABLE
AND TO IMPROVE OUR DISTRICTS
SERVE OUR SCHOOLS?
AND ONCE I SAW THAT I KNEW I
WANTED TO JOIN ON THAT ALL CAP I
WAS ABLE TO ORGANIZE MY FELLOW
STUDENTS INTO A CAUCUS THAT
VOTED IN ACTED TOGETHER.
IN THIS WAY WE ARE ABLE TO
SAFEGUARD STUDENT AS ENTRANCE
AND EMPOWER STUDENTS TO SHARE
THEIR OPINIONS AND WE'RE ABLE TO
GET MANY RECOMMENDATIONS -- AT
TO THE SCHOOL BOARD.
BUT AS A COMMITTEE OVERALL WE
HAD CHALLENGES WE HAVE LONG
FIGHTS OF OUR BY LAWS WE HAD
TROUBLE GETTING DATA THAT WE
NEEDED FROM RECOMMENDATIONS TO
MAKE COUNTS.
CONFLICTS OVER TOWN HALLS BY NO
MEANS IS THE EL CAP PROCESS
PERFECT.
BUT DESPITE THE CHALLENGES WE
ARE ABLE TO HOLD THE DISTRICT
ACCOUNTABLE FOR ITS DECISIONS
AROUND THE BUDGET AND WE ARE
ABLE TO ENGAGE THE DISTRICT
AROUND THE BUDGET WHICH FORCED
THEM TO BE TRANSPARENT AND HOW
THEY FORMULATED THEIR DECISIONS.
I CANNOT IMAGINE OUR DISTRICTS
EL CAP WITHOUT THE COMMITTEE'S
INVOLVEMENT AND THEIR WORK.
THIS YEAR'S SUPPORTED BY
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
THE COMMITTEE DELIVERED CLEAR.
I'LL CAP RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
DISTRICT INCLUDING INCREASED
ACADEMICS APART FOR AFRICAN
AMERICAN STUDENTS TO CLOSE THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN.
ACHIEVEMENT GAP IN OUR DISTRICT
AND MANY OTHER PRO AND WE
SUPPORT AND MANY OTHER PROGRAMS
THAT.
BENEFIT OUR STUDENTS.
THE DISTRICT RESPOND IN A
WRITING AS REQUIRED BY LAW.
I'M NOT SURE HOW STUDENTS AND
PARENTS IN CHARTER SCHOOLS MEAN
PHILLY ENGAGE IN THE EL CAP
PROCESS WITHOUT STAKEHOLDER
COMMITTEES.
THAT MEET THEM WITH THE
MINISTRATION THROUGHOUT THE YEAR.
AND I DO NOT KNOW HOW THEY GET
EL CFF TRAINING ARE EL CAP
TRAINING I DON'T KNOW HOW THEY
ASK QUESTIONS AND I DON'T KNOW
HOW THEY MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS.
AS SADDENS ME THAT THE FIVE
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND MY DISTRICT
DON'T HAVE THE SAME OPPORTUNITY
FOR STUDENTS AND PARENTS TO
ADVOCATE FOR THEMSELVES AND HAVE.
AGENCY AND HOW THEY'RE EDUCATED
AND HOW THEIR CHILDREN ARE
EDUCATED.
THANK YOU.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
LIZ BUT THAT'S OF ALL OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
BUSINESS OFFICIALS IN SUPPORT.
CAITLYN JENNER ME AFTER THE SAN
BENITO COUNTY JUST A GOV GETS A
BETTER SCHOOLS AND SUPPORT.
PAMELA GIVES REPRESENTING THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION AND WE SUPPORT THE
BILL.
CARLOS MICHELLE WITH CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BOARDS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
KATHY SURE FOR THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THE INJURY ON THE OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
I PATRICK FORTY WITH FIGHT CRIME
INVEST IN KIDS AND READY NATION
AND MORE IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MARK OUT OF ITS ON
BEHALF BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS RATIONALE
SUPPORTIVE I'M IN THE POSITION
ON THE BILL WOULD WORKING WITH
THE AUTHORS OFFICE WE SUPPORT.
ALL OF THE PUSH ON THE BILL THE
ONLY CONCERN WE HAVE IS ABOUT
THE IMPACT THE WOULD HAPPEN
CHARTER SCHOOL AUTHORIZED
RESPECT PARTICULAR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
OUT WHEN HE COMES TO YOU IN THE
L. CAPS WE BELIEVE THAT THEY
DON'T HAVE THE STAFFING OR THE
FUNDING TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT
ADDITIONAL OVERSIGHT.
OF REVIEWING ALL CAPS BUT WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR TO MITIGATE THOSE
CONCERNS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
ANSWER ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. TWO WITNESSES TWO MINUTES
EACH BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
GOOD MORNING I'M CALLING MILLER
THE CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION WHERE UNFORTUNATELY
OPPOSE THIS BILL -- I WOULD NOTE
THAT -- THE EDUCATION TRAILER
BILL THAT YOU'LL BE --
CONSIDERING DOES ADDRESS ON ALL
THE ISSUES AROUND TRANSPARENCY
THEY'RE INCLUDED IN THS BILL A
WE DO SUPPORT -- INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY IN MAKING SURE THAT
TURNER SCHOOLS ARE ENGAGING
THEIR COMMUNITIES IN THE IN
THESE PROCESSES -- THE EL CAP IS
AN EVOLVING PROCESS IS YOUR YOUR
OWN STAFF ANALYSIS NOTES THERE A
LOT OF ISSUES WITH DISTRICTS IN
TERMS OF HOW THEY'RE ENGAGING
THEIR COMMUNITIES AS WELL.
SO WE THINK THAT ADDING CHARTER
SCHOOLS TO ALL THOSE LAWS AND
VERY PRESCRIPTIVE PROCESSES --
THAT DISTRICTS ARE APPLYING ARE
REALLY NOT A SOLUTION TO THIS
ISSUE OF IN OUR COURAGE IN MORE --
BORN GAUGE WENT -- THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE HAS
ALSO RECENTLY -- GOOD CONTRACTED
TO OF THE BSA FOR AN EVALUATION
OF THIS ISSUE AS WELL -- PUBLIC
ADVOCATE'S REPORT DID NOT
INCLUDE DISTRICTS SO WE DON'T
KNOW HOW OF PERVASIVE THESE
ISSUES ARE AT THE DISTRICT LEVEL
AS WELL -- BUT WE DO BELIEVE
THAT -- IN ADDITION TO YOUR OWN --
AS BE ONE TWENTY SIX THE
TRANSPARENCY ISSUES IN CHARTER
SCHOOLS ARE IMPROVING -- THIS
BILL WE THINK IT JUST GOES TOO
FAR IN TERMS OF CREATING SOME
VERY PRESCRIPTIVE --
REQUIREMENTS ON CHARTER SCHOOLS
THAT HAVEN'T YET BEEN -- BEEN --
PROVEN TO BE EFFECTIVE -- ALSO
JUST TO BE CLEAR CHARTER SCHOOLS
ARE DIFFERENT THAN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THEIR SCHOOL LEVEL
ACCOUNTABILITY -- THERE ALSO
HAVE BEEN DOING ACCOUNTABILITY
BASED ON GOALS AND OUTCOMES FOR
FOR MANY MANY YEARS THE CAP
ADDED ON TO THAT PROCESS.
THE BIGGEST CONCERN WITH THIS
BILL AS IT ACTUALLY ELIMINATES
THE THE SECTION OF LAW THAT
WOULD INCLUDE CHARTER SCHOOLS --
THAT THAT REQUIRE CHARTER
SCHOOLS TO ALIGN THEIR CHARTERS
WITH THEIR ALL CAPS BY LIMITING
THAT SECTION LOG COMPLETELY.
IGNORES THE FACT THAT CHARTER
SCHOOLS ARE ALREADY DOING THIS
KIND OF ACCOUNTABILITY THROUGH
THEIR CHARTER PROCESS.
THAT ARE APPROVED BY THEIR
DISTRICTS AND AND AND OUR LOCAL
BASED ACCOUNTABILITY SO SO WE WE
REALLY ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
ELIMINATION OF THAT THAT
CONNECTION BETWEEN THE CHARTER
AND THE ALL CAP IN THIS BILL.
YOUR NEXT WITNESS HELLO HALLERAN
WITH THE CHARTER SCHOOLS
DEVELOPMENT CENTER SO I ECHO
EVERYTHING THAT MY COLLEAGUE
SAID IN ADDITION I JUST REALLY
WANT TO EMPHASIZETHE FACT.
THAT PRIMARILY CHARTER SCHOOLS
ARE BEHOLDEN TO THEIR CHARTER
AND THAT CHARTER HAS ALL SORTS
OF PUBLIC HEARINGS AND TIME FOR
INPUT.
THAT'S THE DOCUMENTS THAT
CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE BEHOLDEN TO
UNLIKE TRADITIONAL PUBLIC
SCHOOLS SO WHEN WE ADD ON
ANOTHER DOCUMENT THAT IS
DIFFERENT IN LOTS OF WAYS FROM
THE CHARTER DOCUMENT.
IT DOES LEAD TO SOME CONFUSION
AS TO WHAT DOCUMENT REALLY
CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE BEHOLDEN TO
AND IF THE EL CAP CHANGES -- THE
THE REQUIREMENTS OF THE CHARTER
TRADITIONAL SCHOOLS DON'T GO
THROUGH THAT PUBLIC HEARING
PROCESS OR WRITE A CHARTER SO
IT'S IT NEEDS TO BE REALLY CLEAR
AND AND WHEN THE ORIGINAL EL CAP --
LEGISLATION WAS WRITTEN IT
TALKED ABOUT THE FACT THAT --
THAT IT LOOKS TO THE CHARTER
DIFFERENTLY THAN TRADITIONAL
SCHOOLS IN TERMS OF PRESENTING
THAT AL CAPP DOCUMENT.
SO -- I I JUST THINK WE NEED TO
WE NEED TO RECOGNIZE THAT I
THINK THAT THIS THIS PARTICULAR
BILL FAILS TO RECOGNIZE THAT.
A CHARTER SCHOOLS DO -- CAPS NOW
THEY JUST DON'T HAVE THIS MORE
ELABORATE PROCESS.
THANK YOU FOR CLARIFYING THAT
BECAUSE I WAS GOING TO SAY SCOTT
HER SCHOOLS ALREADY DO YOU HAVE
TO DO AN EL CAP I THINK WITH
THIS BILLS TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH
IS MAKING SURE THEY'RE ACTUALLY
GETTING DONE.
AS WE HEARD THAT SO MANY OF THEM
ARE BEING DONE SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS CONCERNS.
ALL RIGHT WOULD YOU LIKE TO COOK.
I SEVEN WILK I'M USED TO HAVING
DOCTOR PAN THERE SO.
AND THOSE YOU SAID IN HERE EVERY
WEEK KNOW THAT -- COM AND THEN
MAYBE MAYBE QUESTIONS COULD BE
IN THIS SO -- FOR ME CHARTER
SCHOOLS ARE LIGHT DIFFERENT
BECOMES.
THE FOCUS ON HOW COME BASS AND
AS MENTIONED -- BY THE OPPONENTS
THAT'S ALL DONE TO THE CHURCH
THROUGH THE CHARTING PROCESS AND
SEEMS TO ME THAT WE'RE TRYING.
TO TAKE -- WHAT'S OUTCOME BASE
AND AND TRY TO MAKE IT RULES
BASE WHICH IS.
REALLY PART OF PROBABLY THE
GENERAL EDUCATION SYSTEM I MEAN
I THINK WE GOT GREAT TEACHERS
ADMINISTRATORS CLASSIFIED
COMMITTED WITH A SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBERS.
THE CHALLENGE THAT WE HAVE.
IT IS JUST A STEPPING THE I
DON'T KNOW WHAT WE DO ABOUT IT
IT'S ONE SIZE. ONE SIZE FITS ALL
YOU KNOW TOP DOWN DRIVEN.
AND I DON'T THINK IT'S
NECESSARILY BENEFITING -- OUR
OUR STUDENTS IN A WORLD WHERE
THEY DON'T HAVE TO NOW NO ONE
THING THEY HAVE TO BE PREPARED
FOR ANYTHING.
AND IT'S A REAL CHALLENGE AND I
THINK YOU KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF
DIVERSITY IN CHARTER SCHOOLS AND
I LIKE TO SEE CHARTER SCHOOLS
CONTINUE TO PROSPER.
I ALSO LIKE TO SEE A REGULAR
SCHOOLS DO DO BETTER.
SOMEONE I WAS READING THE BILL
ARCHER I JUST HAD AN EPIPHANY
AND SO WHAT THROUGH IT OUT THERE
NOT FOR NOW BUT FOR NEXT YEAR
AND I'D LOVE TO WORK WITH YOU ON
IT BECAUSE I THINK OU.
ARE UNIQUELY POSITIONED TO DO IT
BASED UPON YOUR YOUR EXPERIENCE.
MAYBE INSTEAD OF TRYING TO MAKE
CHARTER SCHOOLS MORE LIKE
REGULAR SCHOOLS MAYBE WE SHOULD
MAKE GREATER SCHOOLS MORE LIKE
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND MAYBE WE
COULD SIT DOWN.
AND TRY TO COME UP WITH THINGS
THAT HELP REGULAR SCHOOLS.
THAT MAKES THE THE BECAUSE I
HEAR A LOT THAT THE PLAYING
FIELD IS NOT LEVEL MAYBE THERE'S
THINGS THAT WE COULD DO THAT
WOULD MAKE THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
FEEL LIKE YOU KNOW.
THEY CAN BE MORE COMPETITIVE AND
ULTIMATELY I THINK THAT HELPS
STUDENTS SO I CAN'T I CAN'T BE
WITH YOU ON THIS BILL TODAY I
DON'T THINK IT'S THE RIGHT
APPROACH.
BUT I KNOW YOU'RE COMMITTED.
TO FIND EDUCATION FIRM FOR EVERY
STUDENT AND I'M INTERESTED IN
INTERESTED IN WORKING WITH YOU
IF YOU ARE.
NEXT YEAR ON THINGS.
THAT RELIEVES THE REGULATORY
BURDEN WHEN APPROPRIATE ON
REGULAR SCHOOLS -- THANK YOU
SENATOR WILK ASSEMBLY WOMAN LIKE
CLUBS I'M SURE I I'D ACTUALLY
LOVE TO ADDRESS AND MY MY
OVERLAPPING SENATORS CONCERNS IN
THIS MATTER.
I I APPRECIATE THAT AND THE
REASON THAT I WAS VERY WILLING
AND EXCITED TO SPONSOR THIS BILL
IS IT IS BECAUSE EXACTLY THIS
KIND OF STANDARDIZED REPORTING.
THAT ALLOWS US TO GET TO THOSE
CONVERSATIONS BECAUSE THE NEXT
IMPORTANT PIECE MOVING BEYOND
MEASURES THAT ARE GONNA BE
COMING BEFORE THIS BODY IN A FEW
WEEKS ON CHARTER SCHOOL
TRANSPARENCY.
IS HOW DO WE HAVE ANY STANDARD
MEASURE OF LOOKING AND EFFECTIVE
OUTCOMES.
THIS LEVEL OF REGULATION FOR
LACK OF A BETTER WORD BUT IT IS
SIMPLY A REPORTS THAT EVERY
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOL IS
REQUIRED TO DO HOW ARE YOU
SPENDING TAXPAYER MONEY STATE
RESOURCES.
IN SUPPORT OF THE EIGHT STATE
PRIORITIES SPECIFICALLY AIMED AT
CLOSING THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP
CHARTERS ARE IN FACT OUTCOME
BASED.
OUTCOME DID DRIVEN DATA AND A
PROCESS FOR ENGAGING PARENTS
SUPPORTING AND PROVIDING AN EL
CAP THAT IS ACCOUNTABLE AND AND
VISIBLE TO THE PUBLIC SHOULDN'T
BE PROBLEMATIC AT ALL.
IT SHOULD BE A MEASURE OF THE
WORK THAT THEY'RE ALREADY DOING
AND IN SO DOING IT ALLOWS US TO
TAKE THAT STANDARDIZED DOCUMENT
ACROSS ALL STATE ELEAZAR AND THE
CHARTER SCHOOL COMMUNITY.
THAT ALONG WITH DASHBOARD DATA
COMPARE THOSE TO AND FIND OUT
WHAT IS GETTING US THE MOST BANG
FOR OUR BUCK IN PUBLIC EDUCATION
DOLLARS REGARDLESS OF THE KIND
OF EDUCATIONAL ENVIRONMENT IT'S
HAPPENING IN.
AND SO PART OF THIS IS TO
ESTABLISH A COMMON SET OF DATA
AND THEN WE ARE ABLE TO MOVE ON
AND HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS
WHICH I'D BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO
HAVE WITH YOU IN THE FUTURE --
YOU KNOW IN LIGHT OF THAT I I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST DRIVE
OUT THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN WE HAVE A MOTION
ONE MORE CALL THAT'S WHAT WOULD
GO GO RIGHT AHEAD.
I THINK I THINK THE POOREST
REACHED CHARTER SCHOOLS AND
REGULAR SCHOOLS IS.
THAT THEY ARE HELD ACCOUNTABLE
BECAUSE THEY'RE ACTUALLY IN THE
MARKET SO IF YOU ARE STUDENT IN
YOUR IN A FAILING SCHOOL AT
REGULAR PUBLIC SCHOOL.
YOU ARE MOST LIKELY STOCK
WHEREAS IF YOU'RE IN A CHARTER
SCHOOL YOU AT THE STUDENT
PARKING ASIDE THIS DOES NOT WORK
FOR ME AND WE GO BACK SO I THINK
THERE'S MORE COUNT ABILITY IN
THAT PARTICULAR SYSTEM BECAUSE
IT'S MORE MARKET BASED STAND IN
THE GENERAL.
POPULATION WITH THE EXCEPTION
THAT I DON'T THINK THAT WE'VE
MOVED TO THE PERSPECTIVE THAT WE
ARE IN A FREE MARKET ECONOMY AND
EDUCATION EDUCATION IS A PUBLIC
GOOD.
IT IS SUPPORTED BY TAXPAYER
RESOURCES AND THEREFORE STANDARD
PRINCIPLE OF ACCOUNTING AND DATA
PROVISION I THINK IS A
COMPLETELY APPROPRIATE MOVE.
THANK YOU CENTER THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY WOMAN THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY CENTER DORADO MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM FIFTEEN AB NINE SIXTY SEVEN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE WILK NO WILK NO CHIANG
LASSELL. TO WRESTLE AYE GLAZER
MCGUIRE PAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL
LEAVE THAT BILL OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS TO VOTE THANK
YOU.
ALL RIGHT I SEE ASSEMBLY WOMAN
PETRIE-NORRIS SO WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO FILE ITEM.
FOURTEEN AB.
NINE SIXTY THREE THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY WOMAN PLEASE BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY.
IN THE MORNING YOUR NUMBERS I'M
HERE TODAY TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB NINE SIXTY THREE
THE STUDENTS CIVIC AND VOTER
EMPOWERMENT TAX.
THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE PUBLIC
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES TO
DESIGNATE A SPECIFIC AND VOTER
EMPOWERMENT COORDINATOR ON EACH
CAMPUS WILL BE TASKED WITH
DEVELOPING A PLAN TO INCREASE
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT AND DEMOCRATIC
PARTICIPATION.
AVAILABLE DATA SHOWS THAT WHEN
COLLEGE CAMPUSES DIVERT
RESOURCES INTO DEVELOPING A PLAN
FOCUSED ON CIVIC AND VOTER
EMPOWERMENT.
IT RESLTS IN STRONG VOTER
TURNOUT FOR EXAMPLE AT UCLA
WHICH VOLUNTARILY TAKES PART IN
THE ALL IN CAMPUS DEMOCRACY
CHALLENGE WHICH ARE BILL IS
PARTLY MODELED ON AFTER
PARTICIPATING IN THE PROGRAM
UCLA REPORTED A FIVE HUNDRED AND
37% INCREASE.
IN PERSON STUDENT VOTERS DURING
THE TWENTY EIGHT MID TERMS
COMPARED TO TWENTY FOURTEEN EVEN
GIVEN THE THE HUGE INCREASE IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN TO TWENTY
EIGHTEEN GENERALLY THAT'S PRETTY
INCREDIBLE.
THERE AN ESTIMATED THREE POINT
ONE MILLION STUDENTS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA'S HUNDRED AND FORTY
SEVEN PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES AND
COLLEGES UNIVERSITIES CAN AND
SHOULD PLAY A PIVOTAL ROLE IN
ENCOURAGING CIVIC ENGAGEMENT.
AND INVOLVING OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
IN OUR DEMOCRACY RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE
STUDENTS CIVIC IN VOTER
ENGAGEMENT TACT.
AND IN PLEASED TO INTRODUCE TO
SUPPORTERS HERE TODAY TO TESTIFY
GOT DOWN TO THE JACKSON FROM THE
IN THE LACI P. AND JULIE
FORESIGHT FRIEND AT THE END OF
VOTERS.
THANK YOU WELCOME TO WITNESSES
TWO MINUTES EACH LA YOU DECIDE
WHO GOES FIRST.
IF IT'S OKAY I THINK OF SENATORS --
AWESOME HELLO MY NAME IS JOHN TO
JACKSON -- I'M A THIRTY A MAJOR.
NOW IN THE FOURTH YEAR MAJOR THE
YEAR JUST ENDED AT CSU FRESNO
MAJORING IN PSYCHOLOGY IN DOUBLE
MINORING IN CRIMINOLOGY IN
POLITICAL SCIENCE.
I'M THE NEWLY ELECTED VICE
PRESIDENT AND CO MEMBERSHIP
CHAIR OF THE FRESNO STATE
CHAPTER OF THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION FOR THE ADVANCEMENT
OF COLORED PEOPLE -- ALSO KNOWN
AS THE END OF THE C. P. AS WELL
AS ONE OF TWENTY NATIONAL CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT TRAINERS FOR THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION.
I'M ALSO HERE REPRESENTING
STUDENTS AT FRESNO STATE AND I
AM SO GRATEFUL TO BE JOINED HERE
TODAY BY ELIZABETH RUSSIA'S
UNITA AND THE CROWD -- SHE'S A
NEWLY ELECTED VICE PRESIDENT OF
EXTERNAL AFFAIRS FOR MY STUDENT
BODY GOVERNMENT ON CAMPUS.
AND I AM A STUDENT AT END -- I
IS A STUDENT AND A MEMBER OF MY
CAMPUS AND W. C. P. WITH THE
SPORT SUPPORT OF OUR INABILITY
PEAS -- STATE PRESIDENT ALICE
HOFFMAN STRONG SUPPORT AB.
NINE SIXTY THREE MY GENERATION
HAS NOT BEEN PROPERLY PREPARED
TO COMPLETELY AND COP AND
CONCISELY NAVIGATE OUR GREAT
NATION'S CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
PROCESS.
THIS IS NO FAULT OF OUR OWN WE
SPEND FOUR YEARS IN HIGH SCHOOL
AND GOVERNMENT IS ONLY REQUIRED
FOR ONE SEMESTER.
THIS IS A RESULT IN HUGE IN A
HUGE NUMBER OF COLLEGE STUDENTS
LIKE ME WHO ENTERED ADULTHOOD AN
EDUCATED ABOUT CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
AND CIVIC DUTY.
I KNOW WHERE THE POWER OF OUR
VOICE TO VOTING AND THE
IMPORTANCE INTANGIBILITY OF
THEIR INVOLVEMENT WITH IN OUR
SOCIO POLITICAL SYSTEMS.
I AM GRATEFUL TO BE ONE OF
TWENTY NATIONAL SEVEN GAVE AND
TRAINERS FOR THE END OF A C. P..
SPECIFICALLY MY EXPERIENCES HAVE
TAUGHT ME IN THIS ROLE -- MY
EXPERIENCES IN THIS ROLE HAVE
TAUGHT METHAT STUDENTS AT
FRESNO STATE ARE HUNGRY FOR
CHANGE THAT STUDENTS WITHIN THE
CSU SYSTEM ARE THIRSTY FOR CIVIC
SUPPORT AND EDUCATION.
STUDENTS PURSUING HIGHER
EDUCATION THROUGHOUT OUR STATE
OUR NATION ARE ACHING FOR
GUIDANCE AND A MORE UNIFORM
SYSTEM BUT ARE UNAWARE OF HOW TO
MAKE THIS POSSIBLE.
THIS BILL WOULD BE A STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION.
THE STATUS QUO OF ACADEMIA HAS
CHARLIE TAUGHT STUDENTS ABOUT
HOW OUR POLITICAL SYSTEM WORKS
BUT NOT ABOUT THE CIVIC WE
ENGAGE VOTERS AND THE GRASSROOTS
ORGANIZER TO MAKE THE SYSTEMS
WORK.
IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN ONLY
EIGHT POINT 2% OF OUR YOUNG
VOTERS TURNED OUT WE WERE ABLE
TO SEE A TWENTY POINT INCREASE
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AND
WITH THE HELP OF THIS BILL WE
HOPE TO SEE MORE OF AN INCREASE
GOING FORWARD -- I WILL CONTINUE
TO TO PUSH ON BUT I WOULD JUST
LIKE TO CLOSE IN SAYING THAT AS
A COLLEGE STUDENT AND ON BEHALF
OF THE END OF A C. P..
AS WELL OF AS WELL AS MY A. S.
I. OUR STUDENT BODY GOVERNMENT
OUT FRESNO STATE -- WE WOULD
REALLY ENCOURAGE YOU TO FULLY
SUPPORT EIGHTY NINE SIXTY THREE
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT WITNESS I I MY NAME IS
JOEY FOR SIDE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR LISTENING TO ME TODAY --
I AM ONE OF THE SPONSORS ON THIS
BILL I'M AN ARTIST A FILMMAKER
I'M ALSO THE FOUNDER OF A BAND
OF VOTERS.
A NONPROFIT NONPARTISAN
ORGANIZATION THAT PARTNERS WITH
STUDENT LEADERS -- TO AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND STATE
UNIVERSITIES TO HELP THEIR PEERS
BECOME ACTIVE PARTICIPANTS IN
THEIR DEMOCRACY.
IN A TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN AS WE
KNOW TO A 52% OF COLLEGE
STUDENTS REGISTERED ONLY 8%
VOTED ONE OF THE WORST RATES IN
THE COUNTRY.
WELL MAJOR EFFORTS HAVE BEEN
MADE TO REGISTER VOTERS IS
CLEARLY NOT ENOUGH TO GET THEM
TO THE BALLOT BOX.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN I
CREATED AN INTERACTIVE ART
INSTALLATION ABOUT VOTING IT WAS
SEEM OVER FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
AND I HAD DIRECT CONVERSATIONS
WITH UNDREDS OF YOUNG PEOPLE
MANY OF THEM LOW INCOME YOUNG
PEOPLE.
ABOUT WHY THEY DIDN'T VOTE
COUNTRY WHAT MANY PEOPLE THINK I
LEARN THESE YOUNG PEOPLE WANT TO
VOTE.
WHAT WAS HEART BREAKING IS THAT
THEY WERE OFTEN ASHAMED TO ADMIT
THAT THEY DIDN'T KNOW HOW HOW
THE GOVERNMENT WORKS HOW TO FIND
NONPARTISAN INFORMATION HOW TO
VOTE BY MAIL AT CETERA?
MANY THOUGHT IT WAS THEIR FAULT.
THIS IS OUR FAULT.
IN A RECENT STUDY CALIFORNIA
RANKED THIRTY EIGHTH IN A P. A
P. CIVICS EXAM.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WE
APPROACHED OVER TWENTY FIVE
COLLEGES OFFERING A GRANT OF
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS EACH.
TO GIVE TO STUDENT LEADERS TO
HOLD EDUCATION EVENTS IT HAD TO
BE NON PARTISAN OFFER FREE FOOD
AND HELP EDUCATE AND INFORM
STUDENTS DURING THE LAST WEEKS
OF THE ELECTION.
WHEN WE CONTACTED VARIOUS
DEPARTMENTS OF THESE UNITS OF
THESE COLLEGES NO ONE KNEW WHERE
TO SEND US WITH NO ONE IN CHARGE
ONLY EIGHT COLLEGES PARTICIPATED
AFTER TWO MONTHS OF REPEATED
OUTRAGE?
AND YET DURING THE TWENTY TWO
EVENTS WE SUPPORTED WE FOUND
STUDENTS EAGER TO VOTE AND
EMPOWERED BY THE KNOWLEDGE OF
THE GAME.
MY HUSBAND WAS THE DEAN OF THE
ARTS PROGRAM AT PASADENA CITY
COLLEGE I KNOW HOW HARD FACULTY
AND ADMINISTRATION WORK THAT'S
WHY WE'RE ASKING FOR A FUNDED
PERMANENT PART TIME POSITION.
WHAT WE ALSO KNOW IS THAT WHEN
STUDENT LEADERS ARE INVOLVED IN
PLANNING AND HOSTING EVENTS THEY
SUCCEED OF THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TESTIFIED ABOUT UCLA AND I CAN
TESTIFY ABOUT DION'S WORK?
AT THIS TIME IN PARTICULAR WITH
THE VOTERS CHOICE ACT THE CENSUS
AND THE EARLY PRIMARIES THERE'S
MUCH FOR STUDENTS TO LEARN AND
THEY ARE OFTEN THE ONES TO TEACH
THEIR FAMILIES.
WE ARE ALSO VERY EXCITED THAT
THIS BILL IS TO FULL TIME
POSITIONS TO THE SECRETARY OF
STATE'S OFFICE SO THEY CAN
EXPAND THEIR OWN VERY IMPORTANT
STUDENT VOTE PROJECT.
AT LESS THAN SIXTY FIVE CENTS
PER STUDENT WE HOPE YOU'LLAGREE
IT'S A SMALL PRICE TO PAY FOR
FULL TIME VOTERS AYE WILK I WILL
END HERE.
BUT TO SAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR LISTENING TO US.
I HOPE YOU'LL SUPPORT OUR BILL
VERY GOOD JOB THANK YOU
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
IF SOMEONE THE LONG ON BEHALF OF
SECRETARIES DAY ALEX BUT THE AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
TELL TROUT NUMBER HAVE
CALIFORNIA LEAVE CONSERVATION
VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
SELENA PRIOR CALIFORNIA STATE
AND DOUBLE ACP IN SUPPORT.
THE MEN'S WORK ON BEHALF A SOW
YOU OF CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MS FISHER WITH THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
ELIZABETH BIRCH'S ANY GOT A
SURPRISE FOR THE INTERNAL
AFFAIRS -- HAVE A SIDE BY THE
FEDERAL STATE WE FULLY ENDORSE
AND SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
SEEING HEARING THAT WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE SENATOR
RUSSELL.
YES I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
AND THANK THE WITNESSES FOR
BEING HERE ESPECIALLY THE YOUNG
WOMAN FROM -- FRESNO STATE
THOUGH IT IS THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR INTEREST AND I JUST
WANT TO ADD ON IT'S IT'S NOT
ONLY BECAUSE WE WANT MORE OF OUR
YOUNGER VOTERS TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE SYSTEM.
BUT WE ALL GET HURT.
BY THE LACK OR THE LOWER --
PARTICIPATION RATES OF YOUNG
ADULTS IT'S ON ALL OF US WE DO
NOT WANT WE CAN HAVE THE MOST
DEMOCRATIC SOCIETY WHEN A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER.
OF PART OF OUR COMMUNITY --
STAYS OUT OF THE PROCESS BESIDES
THAT YOU ALL HAVE VERY CREATIVE.
A VERY INNOVATIVE VERY PRO
ACTIVE IDEAS -- AND I THINK
THOSE ARE THE KINDS OF THINGS
THAT WE NEED MORE OTHERWISE
WOULD BECOME VERY STALE SO --
AGAIN I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU
AND WILL BE SUPPORTING OF THE
PROBATE TIME LIKE TO MOVE.
THANK YOU CENTER DORADO CENTER
WILK OKAY VERY GOOD A SALOON
WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU ADD TO ME WITNESSES
FOR JOINING ME TODAY THANK YOU
SENATOR FOR YOUR COMMENTS.
YOU KNOW I THINK SOMETIMES IT'S
EASY FOR US TO BUY MY OWN SORT
OF YOU KNOW AN APATHY AND IN THE
YOUNGER GENERATION -- YOU
WEREN'T PEOPLE GETTING INVOLVED
I THINK AS WE SEE THERE ARE A
LOT AS INCREDIBLY SMART
INCREDIBLY MOTIVATED YOUNG
PEOPLE THAT DO YOU WANT TO GET
INVOLVED AND IT'S ABOUT
INCREASING PARTICIPATION IN OUR
CIVIC LIFE AND IN OUR DEMOCRACY
SO RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SIMPLY WOMAN THE BILL
HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR DORADO
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ITEM FOURTEEN EIGHTY NINE SIXTY
THREE THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
ELECTIONS AND CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENTS LEYVA.
LEAVE THE I WILL.
WILK I CHANGED THE ASAL LASSELL
AYE GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN.
BELIEVE THAT BILL ON CALL FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS ADD ON THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
YOU'RE WELCOME.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN COME ON
DOWN HE SNUCK IN.
JUST AFTER ASSEMBLY WOMAN
PETRIE-NORRIS OR WE WOULD HAVE
STARTED WITH YOU.
YOU HAVE TO BILLS WOULD YOU LIKE
TO START WITH FILE ITEM.
SIX WHICH PHONE NUMBERS THAT ARE
THAT IS THREE OH TWO WOULD BE
HAPPY TO VERY GOOD.
I'M SURE AND I ALWAYS ENJOY
HEARING ABOUT WAYS THAT WE'RE
GONNA HELP YOUNG PEOPLE VOTE SO
I WAS HAPPY.
TO SIT THROUGH THAT PRESENTATION
VERY GOOD AND BEFORE YOU GET
STARTED I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR DILIGENT WORK WITH THIS
COMMITTEE ON THIS BILL I KNOW
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO YOU AND
ALL OF US.
AND I APPRECIATE YOU WORKING
WITH THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND AND I APPRECIATE
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE AS
WELL AND AND WITH YOU -- WE ALL
SEE EVIDENCE OF THE HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES EVERY DAY.
WHETHER IT WAS THE HEPATITIS A
OUTBREAK IN SAN DIEGO WHICH
KILLED TWENTY PEOPLE AND INJURED.
SIX HUNDRED THE TENT CITIES THAT
ARE GROWING THROUGHOUT LOS
ANGELES THE HOMELESS PEOPLE WE
INTERACT WITH JUST ACROSS THE
STREET FROM THE CAPITOL HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. FOR MY DISTRICT THE
ROWS OF OUR VIS THAT LINE EL
CAMINO RIEL ON THE BORDER OF
STANFORD UNIVERSITY.
WE TALK ABOUT HOW IT'S IMPACTING
A WORKING POOR OR A RETIREES.
BUT UNTIL RECENTLY WE DIDN'T
REALIZE TO WHAT EXTENT
HOMELESSNESS WAS IMPACTING A
VERY DIFFERENT GROUP OF
CALIFORNIANS.
WHICH IS OUR COLLEGE STUDENTS.
HOUSING AND FOOD AND SECURITY
AMONG COLLEGE STUDENTS ALSO
KNOWN AS BASIC NEEDS AND
SECURITY IS FINALLY GETTING THE
ATTENTION IT DESERVES.
STUDENTS OF COLOR FIRST
GENERATION COLLEGE STUDENTS
FINANCIAL AID RECIPIENTS AND
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH ARE AT MUCH
HIGHER RISK OF EXPERIENCING
BASIC NEEDS AND SECURITY.
A RECENT REPORT RELEASED BY THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND THE HOPE
CENTER FOR COLLEGE COMMUNITY AND
JUSTICE WHICH SURVEYED NEARLY
FORTY THOUSAND STUDENTS AT FIFTY
SEVEN COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
FOUND THAT 19% OF RESPONDENTS
EXPERIENCED HOMELESSNESS IN THE
PRIOR YEAR.
IF YOU EXTRAPOLATE THAT THE
CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITY COLLEGE
POPULATION OF TWO POINT ONE
MILLION STUDENTS THIS MEANS THAT
ALMOST FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
STUDENTS STATEWIDE HAVE
EXPERIENCED HOMELESSNESS.
IN THE LAST TWELVE MONTHS.
THIS NUMBER IS NOT ONLY SHOCKING
ALARMING AND TRAGIC BUT IT MUST
BE A CALL TO ACTION.
I INTRODUCED AB THREE OR TWO
AFTER HEARING FROM MY FORMER
DISTRICT OFFICE INTERN WHO SHARE
WITH ME HER FRIENDS EXPERIENCE
WITH HOMELESSNESS.
AB THREE WHICH WOULD REQUIRE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO PROVIDE A
SAFE PARKING LOT ON CAMPUS FOR
THE HOMELESS STUDENTS TO SLEEP
IN THEIR VEHICLES.
EXISTING LAW ALREADY REQUIRES
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO GRANT
HOMELESS STUDENTS ACCESS TO
CAMPUS OUR FACILITIES.
AB THREE OH TWO IS THE NEXT STEP
IN HELPING THIS GROWING
POPULATION.
UNDER AB THREE OR TWO EACH
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT WILL
BE PROVIDED BROAD FLEXIBILITY TO
DEVELOP AN IMPLEMENTATION PLAN
THAT MEETS THEIR LOCAL NEEDS AND
CIRCUMSTANCES.
AB THREE OR TWO ALSO IMPORTANTLY
SPECIFIES THAT IT IS THE INTENT
OF THE LEGISLATURE THAT HOMELESS
STUDENTS WHO USE THE OVERNIGHT
PARKING FACILITIES.
CONNECTED TO AVAILABLE STATE
COUNTY COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT AND COMMUNITY BASED
HOUSING FOOD AND FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE RESOURCES.
LET ME BE CLEAR.
AB THREE OR TWO IS NOTHING TO
CELEBRATE [inaudible]
IT'S SAD.
THE FACT THAT WE'RE EVEN
ISCUSSING THIS IS A REFLECTION
OF CALIFORNIA'S FAILURE OVER THE
LAST THIRTY YEARS TO BUILD A
HOUSING NECESSARY TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF OUR GROWING POPULATION.
BUT WE CAN'T LOOK AWAY OR AVOID
THIS ISSUE JUST BECAUSE IT MAKES
US FEEL AWKWARD.
THE REALITY IS THAT STUDENTS ARE
SLEEPING IN THEIR VEHICLES OR
EVEN OUT ON THE STREET.
TONIGHT.
AND WHEN WE DON'T TO PROVIDE A
SAFE PLACE FOR THEM TO SLEEP.
WITH A MOAN AND OPPOSE A SHORT
TERM SOLUTION LIKE SAFE LOTS
BECAUSE WE SAY WE'RE WORKING
TOWARDS THE LONGER TERM SOLUTION
OF BUILDING HOUSINGFOR THEM.
AND THREE TO FIVE YEARS.
WE FORCE THEM INTO THE SHADOWS.
IN THE DARK ALLEYS AND
INDUSTRIAL PARKS WHERE THE
STUDENTS ARE MOST VULNERABLE.
AS I MENTIONED I I WANNA THINK
THE CHAIR IN HER COMMITTEE STAFF --
FOR WORKING WITH MY STAFF AND ME
ON THIS BILL.
I APPRECIATE OUR CONVERSATIONS
AND BELIEVE THAT AB THREE OR TWO
WITH THE PROPOSED COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS IS A CRITICAL FIRST
STEP TO TAKING STATEWIDE ACTION.
TO ADDRESS THE HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS THAT MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS FACE.
I'LL BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS WHICH INCLUDE THE
FOLLOWING KEY COMPONENTS.
ADDING A MINIMUM NUMBER OF UNITS
THAT A STUDENT MUST BE ENROLLED
IN TO USE THE OVERNIGHT PARKING
FACILITIES.
ADDING A SUNSET DATE OF DECEMBER
THIRTY FIRST TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
TWO WITH REPORTING.
AND ADDING AN OPT OUT FROM THE
BILL'S PROVISIONS FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WHO IMPLEMENTS BEST THE
SPECIFIED HOUSING ASSISTANCE
ACTIVITIES FOR STUDENTS WERE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
I ALSO WANT TO BE SURE TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS BILL IS A
DOS WANNA BE SURE TO RECOGNIZE
AND ACKNOWLEDGE.
THAT THIS BILL IS ASKING
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO DO MORE
THAN THEY EVER HAVE HAD TO IN
THE PAST.
BUT WE'RE AT A SITUATION IN
CALIFORNIA WHERE WE ALL HAVE TO
DO MORE THAN WE EVER HAVE IN THE
PAST. ONE OF MY LOCAL COMMUNITY
COLLEGES FOR HILL HOW THE
HOMELESSNESS SUMMIT THIS PAST
FRIDAY.
AND I REALLY WISH EVERYONE COULD
HAVE BEEN THERE TO HEAR THE
TESTIMONIALS FROM STUDENTS WHO
EXPERIENCED HOMELESSNESS WHAT
GOING TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
INCLUDING TO HEAR TODAY -- THE
THE STUDENTS ARE MILITARY
VETERANS THEIR FOSTER YOUTH THE
LGBT Q. YOUTH AND AND AND OTHER
SITUATIONS THAT THAT THEY'VE
GONE THROUGH GROWING UP.
THEY ARE SO STRONG AND SO
PASSIONATE ABOUT GETTING AN
EDUCATION AND HAVING A BRIGHTER
FUTURE.
AND IT WAS AMAZING TO SEE THE
TURN OUT FROM THE COLLEGE'S
FACULTY AND STAFF.
INCLUDING THE SCHOOL'S PRESIDENT
AND A FEW DISTRICT BOARD MEMBERS
WHO WORKS SO HARD EVERY DAY TO
HELP THEIR STUDENTS.
I REALLY WANT TO ENCOURAGE EVERY
COLLEGE ACROSS CALIFORNIA TO
HOLD THIS TYPE OF AN EVENT. TO
LISTEN TO YOUR STUDENTS AND A DE
STIGMATIZE THE ISSUE OF STUDENT
HOMELESSNESS.
AND HEAR ABOUT WHAT THEY CAN DO
TO HELP THEIR HOME THE STUDENT
POPULATION.
SORT OF INCLUDED AB THREE OR TWO
IS NOT A SOLUTION TO THE
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS.
BUILDING MORE HOUSING IS.
BUT THAT WLL TAKE YEARS AND
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
AND IN THE MEANTIME THERE ARE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS RIGHT
NOW [inaudible]
TONIGHT.
AND WE SHOULD DO EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO MAKE THEIR SITUATION A
LITTLE BETTER.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE -- AND I'M HONORED TO BE
JOINED BY TWO COURAGEOUS
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS WHO
TRAVEL TO BE HERE TODAY TO SHARE
THEIR STORY AND EXPERIENCE.
I'VE MATTHEW BOTO STUDENT AT
FOOTHILL COLLEGE IN MY DISTRICT
WHOSE EXPERIENCE LED TO THE
INTRODUCTION OF THE BILL.
AND ANTHONY WHITE THE SECOND A
VETERAN AND STUDENT AT PALOMAR
PALOMAR COLLEGE IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY AND AND BOTH OF THESE
STUDENTS HAVE BECOME LEADERS IN
THE STATE -- IN IN RAISING UP
THESE ISSUES AND TRYING TO FIND
CONSTRUCTIVE SOLUTIONS I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR BEING HERE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WELCOME GENTLEMEN TWO WITNESSES
TWO MINUTES EACH TELL YOU DECIDE
WHO STARTS.
AGAIN I MATH DEVOTO I'M A TWENTY
ONE YEAR OLD FOOTHILL COLLEGE
STUDENT AND I SPENT ABOUT TWO
YEARS.
HOMELESS SLEEPING IN MY CAR
PRIMARILY.
I WAS A FULL TIME STUDENT DURING
THAT TIME AND WORKED A FULL TIE
JOB.
TRYING TO PACK IN MY CLASSES --
AROUND MY WORK SCHEDULE AND IT
UP WORKING FOURTEEN HOUR DAYS TO
MAINTAIN A FULL TIME JOB.
BUT EVEN WITH OVER TIME IN
DOUBLE TIME DURING THAT.
I WAS STILL NOT ABLE TO AFFORD.
A HOUSE A PLACE TO LIVE IN AND
PAY RENT.
I WASN'T WELCOME TO SLEEP ON
CAMPUS WHEN I WAS SLEEPING IN MY
CAR I WAS ASKED TO LEAVE SEVERAL
TIMES BY POLICE AND AS A RESULT.
I WOULD SLEEP IN THE NEARBY
COMMUNITIES.
A WHICH WAS NOT WELL RECEIVED BY
THE RESIDENTS OF THE AREA.
MY CAR MY HOME.
THE ONLY THING I HAD TO MY NAME
WAS DAMAGED.
PENALIZED BY PEOPLE IN THE AREA
AND I REALIZED I WAS NO LONGER
SOMEWHERE SAFE AND AS TAKE IT'S
PILED UP I REALIZED I WAS NOT
SOMEWHERE LEGAL.
I ENDED UP PARKING FURTHER AND
FURTHER FROM CAMPUS.
BUT EACH MORNING I WOULD TRAVEL
BACK TO SHOWER TO START MY DAY
BEFORE WORK AND CLASS.
HAD AB THREE TWO BEEN IN EFFECT
I WOULD HAVE A LOT I WOULD HAVE
BEEN ALLOWED TO STAY NEAR THE
RESOURCES THAT EXIST ON CAMPUS.
SUCH AS FOOD PANTRIES SHOWERS
AND HEALTH SERVICES.
SHOULD HAVE CUT DOWN MY COMMUTE
TIME ALLOWED ME TO SLEEP MORE
AND BE IN A SAFE ENVIRONMENT.
THERE FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
OTHER STUDENTS THAT ARE IN NEED
OF THIS BILL.
OFTEN THE STUDENTS ARE ATTENDING
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO TRYING TO
SKATE.
FROM POVERTY AND HOMELESSNESS.
WITH SCHOOLS BEING ONE OF THE
FEW STABLE AND SAFE ENVIRONMENTS
THAT CAN ALLOW STUDENTS TO
OBTAIN THE ACADEMIC SKILLS.
THEY NEED TO ESCAPE FROM POVERTY
AND HOMELESSNESS SOMETIMES AN
ASSOCIATE'S DEGREE CERTIFICATE --
EVENTUAL BACHELOR'S DEGREE.
CAN MEAN THE WORLD TO THEM.
THIS BILL WILL BE PROVIDING
STUDENTS HOMELESS STUDENTS A
SAFE PLACE TO SIMPLY EXIST IN AN
ENVIRONMENT THAT SUPPORTS THEM
AND PROVIDE SOME WITH MANY
RESOURCES. TO RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR I'VE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
HELLO GOOD MORNING HOW TO START
BY SAYING ALL THANKFUL I AM TO
BE HERE SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE NEARLY FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
STUDENTS WHO FACE HOMELESSNESS
LAST YEAR.
MY NAME IS ANTHONY WHITE I'M
TWENTY EIGHT YEARS OLD I'M A
FATHER A HUSBAND.
A STUDENT AND A VETERAN.
I'M ALSO FORMALLY HOMELESS.
SURELY AFTER LEAVING THE MARINE
CORPS MY PLANS DID NOT WORK OUT
AND I FOUND MYSELF LIVING IN MY
TRUCK FOR MY PICKUP TRUCK FOR
ABOUT EIGHT MONTHS IN THE NORTH
SAN DIEGO COUNTY AREA.
I WORK DURING THE DAY WOULD
ATTEND CLASSES IN THE EVENING.
I WORKED HARD TO GET OTHER
SITUATION I WAS IN WHAT WAS A
CONSTANT STRUGGLE. ONE OF THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGES I FACED WAS
FINDING A SAFE PLACE TO SLEEP AT
NIGHT.
I ONLY WANTED TO BE SAFE SO I
CAN SLEEP UNDISTURBED AND ON
DISTURBING.
I WOULD PARK IN FRONT OF LOWS
BECAUSE THE WIFE I REACHED THE
PARKING LOT.
SO I COULD DO MY HOMEWORK.
OR I WOULD PARK BEHIND
WAREHOUSES IN THE BUSINESS PARK
IN OCEANSIDE BOULEVARD BECAUSE
THEY WERE WELL LET CLOSE TO
CAMPUS.
IF AB THREE TWO HAD BEEN LAW.
I WOULD HAVE HAD ACCESS TO MY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TO PROGRAM
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN LIFE
CHANGING.
AND MAY HAVE MEANT THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN ME STAYING IN
SCHOOL OR DROPPING OUT.
WHICH ULTIMATELY DID BECAUSE OF
THE STRESS OF THE SITUATION I
WAS IN.
THANKFULLY IS A VETERAN I HAVE
ACCESS TO RESOURCES THAT MOST
STUDENTS DON'T.
AND I WAS ABLE TO FIND STABLE
HOUSING.
SINCE THEN I'VE BEEN ENROLLED IN
SCHOOL AND ON MY WAY TO COMPLETE
MY BACHELORS IN BUSINESS.
BUT TONIGHT MANY STUDENTS WILL
STILL BE IN THEIR CARS.
FACED WITH THE CHOICE OF WHERE
TO PARK FOR JUST ENOUGH TIME TO
CLOSE THE RICE AND FILL THAT
MOST BASIC HUMAN NEED OF A SAFE
NIGHT'S SLEEP.
I'M HERE TODAY TO DISPEL SOME OF
THE STIGMA SURROUNDING
HOMELESSNESS.
I AM HERE AS A TRUE TO LIFE
EXAMPLE OF THE KIND OF STUDENTS
WHO NEED AB.
THREE OH TWO THESE ARE THE SAME
STUDENTS THAT ARE IN OUR
CLASSROOMS.
THEY'RE ON OUR CAMPUSES
INTERACTING WITH US EVERY DAY.
THEY'RE NOT DRUG ABUSERS FOR THE
SEVERELY MENTALLY ILL.
BUT YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN WHO WANT
A BETTER WAY OF LIFE.
LIKE MANY OF YOU I BELIEVE THAT
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SHOULD BE A
GATEWAY TO A BETTER FUTURE.
AND THAT BASIC NEEDS SHOULDN'T
BE A BARRIER TO EDUCATION.
BEING HOMELESS IS EXTREMELY
LONELY.
AND I OFTEN SAY BEING HOMELESS
MEANS BEING IN THE COMMUNITY
WITHOUT BEING A PART OF IT.
BUT AT COMMUNITY COLLEGES THAT
SHOULD BE TAKEN TO HEART.
IT'S BECAUSE OF THIS THAT I HOPE
YOU'LL SUPPORT AB THREE OH TWO
AND IN DOING SO REMIND MY
BROTHERS AND SISTERS YOUR SONS
AND DAUGHTERS ARE FELLOW
CALIFORNIANS.
BUT THEY HAVE NOT BEEN FORGOTTEN.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO BOTH OF
YOU.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'VE
BEEN ALL TOMORROW ON BEHALF OF
LOS ANGELES COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
JESSICA BARTOLO WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY -- ON
BEHALF OF THE WESTERN CENTER BUT
ALSO -- MYSELF WHO IS A COLLEGE
STUDENTS UP IN MY CAR DURING THE
BREAKS NEXT TO MY PARENTS WHO
SLEPT IN THE CAMPER.
AT THE PARK.
WE ARE DRIVE OKAY THANK YOU.
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS TONY
RICE ABOUT THE LOS ANGELES AREA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND VERY
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DENNY BERRICLE WITH THE STUDENT
CENTER FOR CALIFORNIA MANY
COLLEGE IN SUPPORT.
AND YOUR DAILY ON WITH THE
STUDENTS AND FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND SAN
JOAQUIN DELTA COLLEGE IN SUPPORT.
INTERNET CAN DISSOCIATE IS TO
INSTRUCTOR LISTED REFERS FORCE
MY COLLEGE IN SUPPORT.
CATHERINE SQUARE WITH THE SENATE
SENATE FOR CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND ASSOCIATES STUDENTS
OF SAN JOAQUIN DELTA COLLEGE IN
SUPPORT.
TONY SHIFT MEYER WITH THE
STUDENT SENATE FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN SUPPORT.
KRISTIN PARALYZED TO CHILDREN'S
RIGHTS IN SUPPORT FOR A FORMER
FROSTY.
I AM GOING TO ADDRESS ON BEHALF
OF THE NATIONA ASSOCIATION
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
SONG OR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
STILL SHE MISAKI ON BEHALF TO
CLIENTS LOS RIOS COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT HAS THE SUPPORT
OF FERMENTED PURSUIT.
OF POSITION TO REMOVE A MANDATE
FROM THE BILL I AND THEN FOR THE
LOS ANGELES COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT WE HAVE A SUPPORT OF
FERMENTED POSITION -- WE REVIEW
THEME OF THE AMENDMENTS ON THE
OPT OUT PROVISION IN BUT WE
SUPPORT THE NOTION OF THE OPT
OUT BUT THE DETAILS -- WE DON'T
FULLY SUPPORT ALL THE DETAILS
THAT WEE.
DESIGNED IN THE ANALYSIS FOR THE
OPT OUT.
LOUIS MARIN DAY WITH CALIFORNIA
BE IN STRONG SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY.
DEBORAH BROWN WITH CHILDREN
ALLEN SUPPORT. SEVEN A GOLDEN OF
THE FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN
SUPPORT.
MARIO GUERRERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT.
MARTHA'S THERE GOES A DAIS ON
BEHALF OF THE DELTA KAPPA GAMMA
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
I'LL HAVE ANOTHER NUMBER PER SE
NEXT AND CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THE ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
TILLMAN HERE THE TABLE WAS GOING
TO ASK YOU TO MOVE ONE SEAT OVER
A LITTLE CLOSER TO THE EITHER
THERE WE GO THAT'S FINE. TWO
WITNESSES GOOD MORNING TO
WITNESSES TWO MINUTES EACH BEGIN
WHEN YOU'RE READY I'LL LET YOU
DECIDE WHO STARTS.
GOOD MORNING -- I FIRST I LIVE
THAT NEVER IT WITH ME COLLEGE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA.
FIRST WE BEGIN BY THINKING ALL
THE MEMBERS THAT WE MET WITH --
AND REALLY THINKING THE STAFF
FOR TAKING THE TIME AN A VERY
THOUGHTFUL ANALYSIS.
AS YOU KNOW NEARLY SIXTY YEARS
AGO CALIFORNIA APPROVED THE
CALIFORNIA MASTER PLAN.
A PLAN THAT WOULD RESOURCE THIS
THE STUDENTS AT THE HIGHEST
LEVEL OF OUR UNIVERSITIES BUT
THE GREATEST AMOUNT OF RESOURCES.
AND THIS SYSTEM THAT SERVICE THE
LARGEST PROPORTION OF
CALIFORNIANS WITH THE LOWEST
LEVEL OF RESOURCES.
TODAY THIS AN EQUITABLE AN
ANTIQUATED SYSTEM CONTINUES TO
BE AN ISSUE AMOUNTS ARE COLLEGES.
AND A MICRO AGGRESSION AMONGST
MANY OF THE BILLS THAT YOU
CONSIDER SUCH AS AB THREE OF TWO
AB THREE OH TWO PERPETUATES.
THE STRUCTURAL INEQUITIES BY
SAYING THAT.
STUDENTS THAT ATTEND THESE
COLLEGES A STUDENT A COLLEGE
SYSTEM THAT SERVES THE GREATEST
PROPORTION OF VETERANS THE
GREATEST PORTION OF LOW INCOME
STUDENTS.
THE GREATEST PROPORTION OF
STUDENTS OF COLOR PARENTS AND
OTHERS SEEKING A BETTER LIFE.
GET PARKING LOTS.
THE POLICY YOU'RE CONSIDERING
DOES NOT RESOURCE OUR COLLEGES
TO ADEQUATELY SERVE AND ADDRESS
THE CHALLENGES THEIR STUDENTS
FACE.
IT DOES NOT PROVIDE A REAL
SOLUTION TO HOUSING.
IT ALSO MATH TO THE REAL
CHALLENGES THEIR STUDENTS FACE
AROUND FINANCIAL AID.
AROUND A SYSTEM THAT IS UNDER
FUNDED.
ARE THAT SOMETIMES WE JUST NEED
BETTER SERVICES FOR STUDENTS --
AS THE ONES THAT WE WERE --
MENTIONED BY OUR WITNESSES.
THAT ACTUALLY HELP THEM COMPLETE
THEIR DEGREE [inaudible]
SO.
WE ASK YOU.
TO INSTEAD TO CONSIDER THE REAL
SOLUTIONS THAT ARE COLLEGES NEED
IN ORDER TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE
FOR EXAMPLE FINANCIAL AID SUCH
AS SB -- TWO NINETY ONE AND THAT
YOU DON'T DISMISS THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE STATE'S
RESPONSIBILITY TO TRULY ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE.
WE ASK THAT ARE WE TO LEAVE YOU
WITH A CALL TO ACTION. TO FIND A
REAL SOLUTION FOR THE HOUSING
AND HOMELESS CHALLENGES THAT OUR
STUDENTS FACE.
AND THAT ARE YOU CONSIDER WHAT
THIS BILL IS ACTUALLY ASKING.
AND THAT COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS DESERVE MORE THAN
PARKING LOTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU -- CHAIR MEMBERS MARK
MCDONALD MCCALLUM GROUP ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN BERNADINO KERN.
AND SAN DIEGO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT AND WE HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED -- POSITION WOULD
LIKE TO SEE THE BILL MORE LIKE A
PILOT PROJECT WHERE DISTRICTS
COULD OPT IN AND PRE PROVIDED
WITH FUNDING IF THEY WERE TO DO
THAT -- THERE ARE NUMBER OF
ISSUES WITH THE BILL -- DOES
INCLUDE FUNDING SAFETY CLEAN UP
AND OVERALL IMPLEMENTATION OF
SECURING THE PARKING LOTS -- BUT
I WANT.
TO I WANT TO COMPLIMENT THE
ANALYSIS BECAUSE THE REAL POLICY
QUESTION IS IN THE ANALYSIS ON
PAGE.
FIVE WHERE IT SAYS COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ARE NOT TRADITIONALLY
EQUIPPED TO HOUSE SUITS STUDENTS
IN THIS MANNER -- COULD THE
ACTIONS ABOVE MEANING THE RAPID
RE HOUSING AND SENATOR YOUR BILL
SB TWO NINETY ONE BE BETTER
SOLUTIONS AND WE WOULD SAY THAT
THOSE ARE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
KLAY WALKER WITH NASA MEN ON
BEHALF OF MOUNT SAN ANTONIO
COLLEGE AND NORTH ORANGE COUNTY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT.
ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH THE
LEAGUE AND WOULD HOPE THAT THIS
WOULD BE AMENDED TO A PILOT
PROGRAM TIED TO FUNDING THANK
YOU.
AWESOME WEBSTER WITHOUT THE
PUBLIC PURSE ON BEHALF OF THE
NOR ARE START THE ORANGE COUNTY
LEGISLATIVE TASK FORCE THE COAST
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT IN
THE RANCHO SANTIAGO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT WILL ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITH THE A PREVIOUS
SPEAKERS.
KILEY WE HAVE A SELF RESPECT IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CAROL GONZALEZ
ANSWER AND WE HAVE A SOUTH
ORANGE COMMITTEE COUNTY UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT WITH AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION THANK
YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS DOCTOR KEVIN
TRIED THEM THE SUPERINTENDENT
PRESIDENT FOR FEATHER RIVER
COLLEGE WHERE WE DO RECEIVE SNOW
AND THIS WILL BE AN ISSUE FOR
OUR STUDENTS.
I TO A SPENT DAYS IN MY CAR AND
WE ARE OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED.
GOOD MORNING CAROL GOALS WITH
PRESIDENT FRESNO CITY COLLEGE
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF STATE
CENTER COMMUNICATIVE IN THE
DELTA AREA WE HAVE HEAT AND HI
HUNDREDS.
UNLESS THIS IS A AMENDED WE
OPPOSE -- HARNISCH US IN A CREE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
CULTURE THE CANYONS WE'RE OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED.
GOOD MORNING MARLIN MARTINEZ
PRESIDENT OF THIS YEAR -- BOARD --
WERE ALSO IN OPPOSITION A CEMENT
IT THANK.
JUSTIN SELMA COMBAT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNICABLE JUST
CHANCES OFFICE WE DO NOT HAVE AN
OFFICIAL POSITION ON THE BILL AT
THIS TIME.
WE DO APPRECIATE THE AUTHORS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS CRITICAL
ISSUE -- BUT I WOULD POINT TO
SOME OF THE COMMENTS MADE BY THE
LEAGUE REGARDING THE THE LOW.
PER STUDENT FUNDING RATES THAT
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES RECEIVE
COMPARED TO OTHER SEGMENTS AS
WELL AS THE THE DEARTH OF CAL
GRANT FUNDS THAT OUR STUDENTS
RECEIVE.
THE LEGISLATURE WISHES --
SOMETHING LIKE THIS TO HAPPEN
THERE SHOULD BE FUNDING -- TO TO
ALLOW US TO FILL THIS SORT OF
MANDATE AND ALSO.
THEY NEED MORE IMPORTANTLY TO
GET MORE FINANCIAL AID RESOURCES
INTO OUR STUDENTS HANDS THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
OPPOSITION.
REFER BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE I'D LIKE TO MAKE A
COUPLE COMMENTS.
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR AGAIN
HE AND I HAD SOME LONG
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THIS.
AND IT IS NOT A SOLUTION AS YOU
SAID BUT IT IS HOPEFULLY GOING
TO SERVE AN IMMEDIATE NEED.
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO PUT THE
ONEROUS ON ALL OF US IN THE
LEGISLATURE REALLY ALL OF US TO
CHANGE THE SITUATION.
WHEN I WENT TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
IN WAS AN EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD
WORKING STUDENT IT WASN'T LIKE
THIS BUT I WOULD ALSO CHALLENGES
NOT ONLY ARE HOUSING PRICES HIGH?
WE NEED BETTER JOBS AND UNTIL WE
CHALLENGE CORPORATE AMERICA I
HAD A GOOD UNION JOB IN IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT THIRTY ONE
YEARS AGO I ME TWELVE FIFTY AN
HOUR.
SO I COULD SUPPORT MYSELF AND I
COULD GO TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE SO
UNTIL WE HAVE WAGES THAT ARE
COMMENSURATE WITH WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN SOCIETY I THINK
WE'LL CONTINUE TO FIND OURSELVES.
IN THE SITUATION BUT I THINK YOU
OUGHT TO THE AUTHOR TO THE
WITNESSES FOR COMING FORWARD AND
TELLING YOUR STORIES --
SOMETIMES UP HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
WE DON'T SEE YOU AND I THINK
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT FOR EVERYONE
TO SEE BOTH OF YOU AND KNOW THAT
THIS IS A VERY REAL PROBLEM SO I
THINK YOU I THINK THE AUTHOR --
MY COMMITMENT TO YOU I HOPE I
HOPE I GET TO BE HERE FOR EIGHT
MORE YEARS AND LET'S NOT LET'S
MAKE THIS A SHORT TERM FIX.
AND TRY TO FIND A LONG TERM
SOLUTION WITHOUT ALL OPEN UP TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS CONCERNS CENTER DRAWS A
YES -- THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF
ALL OF YOUR REMARKS DIGITAL --
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF OF WHAT YOU
ALL LAID OUT RIGHT NOW AND I
ALSO HAD CONVERSATION WITH THE
AUTHOR THANK YOU.
AND THANK YOU TO OUR OUR
WITNESSES FOR FOR BEING HERE --
I DO HAVE SIMILAR CONCERNS --
ABOUT WHAT THIS ALL MEANS AND
THE IMPACT THAT WORKED WERE
TRYING TO HAVE -- THE ISSUE OF
NOT THIS NOT BEING A SOLUTION
HOW DO WE USE OUR DOLLARS -- HOW
ARE THEY BEST SPENT -- WITH
REGARDS TO GETTING STUDENTS OUT
OF THEIR CARS.
AND IT'S NOT A IT'S NOT A GOOD.
DOG GOAL TO HAVE IS TO GET OUT
OF HERE YOU KNOW TO HAVE A PLACE.
TO PARK YOUR CARS.
THE GOAL NEEDS TO BE TO GET YOU
OUT OF YOUR CARS AND INTO AN
APARTMENT INTO A HOME.
THAT'S THAT'S THE GOAL SO I
GUESS I'M A CONCERNED ABOUT HOW
DOES THIS.
LEAD TO THE REAL GOAL HOW DOES
THIS HELP CHANGE -- OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN SUCH A WAY
THAT THEY CAN DO THAT -- AND NOT
JUST OKAY HERE'S A BANDAID AND
LET'S PRETEND WE REALLY DID
SOMETHING TO CHANGE -- CHANGE
THE DIRECTION THAT WE SHOULD BE
IT -- GOING IN SO I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT ARE THESE IS THIS THE
BEST WAY TO SPEND OUR DOLLARS --
HOW DO WE HELP OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES GET THE RESOURCES THAT
STUDENTS NEED TO GET OUT OF
BEING HOMELESS AND HAVING TO
LIVE OUT OF THEIR CARS -- HOW DO
WE HAVE RELIABLE FUNDING IF IT'S
A MANDATE HOW DO WE MAKE SURE
THEY HAVE THE RELIABLE FUNDING
AND THAT IT DOESN'T TAKE AWAY
FROM SOMETHING ELSE THAT WERE
ALSO FIGHTING?
FOR AND THAT WE FALL SHORT OF
OUR MANY TIMES BUT A MANDATE
WITHOUT RELIABLE FUNDING SOURCE
I THINK IS A IS A HUGE PROBLEM
IT
WHO MAKES THE DECISION BOUT HOW
TO WHAT DO YOU TAKE AWAY FROM?
IN ORDER TO FULFILL.
THIS MANDATE.
AND THE AND THIS PARTICULAR
QUESTIONS BUT I I THINK THOSE
ARE THE THE PRIMARY ISSUES.
OF A PARTICULAR QUESTIONS ABOUT
HOW WILL FAMILIES THERE ARE
STUDENTS I'M SURE BECAUSE THIS
IS A COMMUNITY COLLEGES SERVE
WORKING CLASS.
ADULTS -- MANY OF WHOM HAVE --
FAMILIES HOW WILL THEY BE DEALT
WITH IN THIS KIND OF SITUATION --
WITH THE NEEDS THAT THEY HAVE SO --
I URGE YOU TO PLEASE CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH COMMUNITY COLLEGE I
KNOW OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
LA OR MANY OF THEM ARE WORKING
REALLY HARD. TO A BE ABLE TO
CONNECT THE STUDENTS WITH THE
RIGHT RESOURCES -- SO OVERALL
HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THIS IS
REALLY SERIOUSLY A PART OF THE
BIGGER GOAL THAT WE HAVE.
ON AND NOT ONLY OKAY.
ADDRESS THIS VERY REAL NEED BUT
IN AN ISOLATION AND NOT AS A
PROP A REAL ALL PART OF THE THE
SOLUTION.
THANK YOU.
AS A MEMBER DID YOU WANT TO
RESPOND.
CLOSE VERY GOOD CENTER PAN.
THANK YOU AND SUMMER BERMAN
FIRST WELL I THANK YOU FOR
MEETING WITH ME AND SPEAKING
ABOUT YOUR BILL AND AND FRANKLY
I WANT TO SAY THAT -- THE CHAIR
IS VERY WELL ARTICULATED I THINK --
TRULY MY FEELINGS ABOUT THE BILL --
IS THAT AND I THINK AS WE TALKED --
YEAH THIS IS NOT A BILL THAT I
THINK -- WE REALLY ONCE IN ONE
HAND AND I KNOW THAT -- IT'S
BECAUSE WE HAVE. TO COME UP WITH
SOME STE -- IMMEDIATE SOLUTIONS
TO A PROBLEM THAT'S VERY PRESENT
RIGHT NOW IT'S NOT THE SOLUTION
AND BY ANY MEANS IT'S FACT IT'S
SHOULDN'T BE THE SOLUTION -- IN
THE LONG TERM -- BUT AND I'M I
ALSO KNOWLEDGE YOU KNOW THE WORK
THAT COMMITTEE COLLEGES
VERTICALLY THOSE IN MY DISTRICT
I KNOW ACROSS THE STATE HAVE
BEEN WORKING ON THIS ISSUE OF
HOMELESSNESS -- AND TRYING TO
APPROACH THAT -- WOULD ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT AS WE'RE GOING
TO THE BUDGET PROCESS IN THE
GOVERNOR'S LEADERSHIP -- AND AS
WELL AND TRYING TO PUT MRE
RESOURCES TOWARD HOMELESSNESS
AND IT IS -- UNITED IT'S PART OF
A LARGER PROBLEM IS NOT JUST
ABOUT COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
STUDENTS COMMUTE BECAUSE BUT WE
NEED TO CREATE -- THOSE SPACES
SO -- I L. B. PLEASE TO VOTE FOR
YOUR BILL TODAY BECAUSE WE NEED
TO CONTINUE TO HAVE THIS -- THIS
OPTION -- I'M SURE YOU'LL BE
WORKING WITH -- THE OPPOSITION
TO MAKE OUR TREES I THINK WE'RE
TAKING SOME GOOD AMENDMENTS CELL
WE HAVE A SUNSET BECAUSE AGAIN
THIS ISN'T.
THE LONG TERM SOLUTION -- BUT I
I CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THAT --
USE STEPPING UP AND SAYING WELL
WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING TO TRUST
IMMEDIATE PROBLEMS LOW LIKE
TRIAGE RATED SAYS THAT'S NOT THE
FINAL TREATMENT BUT YOU GOT TO
DO SOMETHING. TO STAUNCH THE
BLEEDING RIGHT NOW AND WITH THAT
IF YOU SEE SOME OF THE BUILT
APPROPRIATE TIME.
THANK YOU CENTER PAN ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS SENATOR WILK
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I WANT I
WANT TO THANK -- OUR SPEAKERS
YOU BOTH PHENOMENAL VERY
ARTICULATE AND AND AND MADE THAT
MADE THE CASE.
AND HOW DARE YOU SEE SOME IN
BERMAN YOU'VE NOT SOLVE THE
WHOLE HOUSING -- CRISIS IN THIS
BILL MY NAME ON YOU FOR BRINGING
IT ON COULD PROPOSAL TO THE
SENATE.
LOOK IT AND I AGREE DOCTOR PAN.
WE WISH WE WEREN'T HAVING TO DO
THIS BUT I REMEMBER FIVE YEARS
AGO BECAUSE CO AUTHOR ON THE
BILL THAT OPEN UP SHOWERS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
THAT BILLS AUTHORED BY DAS
WILLIAMS WHO HIMSELF WAS
HOMELESS WHEN HE WAS IN
COMMUNITY COLLEGE -- I HAD AS A
COMMITTEE FOR YEARS AGO SAYING
YOU A WAY TO CREATE BETTER
STABILITY FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS IS TO HAVE.
COLLEGES OFFER PO BOXES FOR
THOSE STUDENTS WHO ARE HOMELESS.
I THOUGHT THAT'S A GREAT IDEA SO
I MEAN WITH THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE THEY GO WELL SENATOR WE
DON'T NEED TO DO THAT BECAUSE
EVERY STUDENT HAS AN OFFICIAL
RESIDENCE BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
REGISTER WITHOUT OFFICIAL
RESIDENCE -- WE KNOW THAT'S BALK --
AND AND WE HAVE IT WE HAVE A
SERIOUS PROBLEM AND ALL THIS IS.
IS TRYING TO HELP PEOPLE WHO ARE
IN NEED AND IS GOING TO BE
SLOPPY.
AND THEY HAVE CHALLENGES BUT I
MEAN IT IS MORALLY I THOUGHT
FEEL COMPELLED THAT THAT THAT
YOU KNOW WE WE WE ABSOLUTELY
HAVE HAVE TO DO IT.
SO -- SO I I COMMEND YOU FOR
THAT IN SOME OF THE PROPOSAL
FIRST OF ALL BY THE WAY ALL THE
ALL YOUR COMMITTEE MINUTES
EXCELLENT I MEAN I THINK IT
MAKES A BILL.
YOU SAID A WEEKEND AND I THINK
IT MAKES IT BETTER -- WHAT AS
WELL?
PRIVATE CONVERSATION YOU NEED --
I JUST ADDED YOU I'M SO SORRY
DID THAT.
SO SORRY DO THAT.
ANYWAY.
IT LIKE THEY'RE GREAT BUT YOU
KNOW THE I THINK THE POINT I
THINK I THINK THE MORE THING IS
THE THE POINT IS THAT THE SENSE
IT'S IN THERE.
HAVING PEOPLE OFTEN I DON'T
THINK THEY'RE GONNA OFTEN AND
THE OTHER THING I THINK THIS
COULD BE AN EDUCATIONAL
PROPOSITION FOR THE GENERAL
PUBLIC BECAUSE I THINK A LOT OF
THE STUDENTS BECAUSE I FIGURE I
DON'T EVER SAY I WAS HOMELESS
ALMOST BUT I HOP.
I SLEPT ON CHARACTERS FOR ABOUT
THREE MONTHS -- IN MY COLLEGE
DAYS.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO ALLOW THE
GENERAL PUBLIC TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT.
THE HOMELESS IMPACT IS BECAUSE I
DON'T THINK AS THE THESE ARE
THESE ARE GHOST PEOPLE THEY'RE
DOING WHATEVER THEY CAN TO
SURVIVE THEY'RE NOT MEN LEO HILL
THEY'RE NOT THE PEOPLE WE SEE ON
THE STREETS AND SACRAMENTO OR
OTHER PLACES.
AND IT'S VERY PREVALENT AND AND
I THINK POLICIES IN PLACE SO WE
ADDRESS THE OVERALL.
PROGRAM SO IS MUCH AS IT PAINS
ME TO VOTE FOR THE BILL TODAY
BECAUSE I WISH WE DIDN'T HAVE TO
DO IT IT'S IT'S IT'S A NEED IT'S
A NEEDED BANDAID -- AND I WILL
BE SUPPORTIVE THANK YOU CENTER
THANK YOU CENTER WILK WE ALL
JUST LEARNED THAT WE SHOULD NOT
TELL YOU ANYTHING A CONFIDENCE.
WHY WE LOVE COMMITTEE HEARINGS
WHO IS LEARN SOMETHING NEW?
BEFORE YOU CLOSE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN AND I DO KNOW YOU LOVED
ALL THE AMENDMENTS.
I DO.
I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE ONE
KNOWS THERE IS NINE MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE BUDGET -- TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THOSE MONIES
CAN BE USED FOR ALL THE
PROGRAM'S LINED OUT IN THIS BILL
WITHOUT WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- AND
THEN AGAIN REALLY THANK YOU FOR
THE CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'VE HAD
IN THAT OUR COMMITTEE OUR THAT
OUR STATUS OF HAD -- THE BILL
DOES WEEKEND MY ORIGINAL INTENT
TO MAKE EVERY COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DO THIS BUT I THINK IT'S ALSO
GOOD TO PROVIDE AN INCENTIVE TO
DO MORE OF TRYING TO ACTUALLY
GET PEOPLE OUT OF THEIR CARS
WHICH THE AMENDMENTS ARE.
ARE YOU KNOW THAT THAT'S THE
GOAL OF THE AMENDMENTS -- THIS
ENCOURAGE MORE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TO DO MORE IN TERMS OF
RAPIDLY HOUSING IN HOTEL
VOUCHERS AND AND OTHER PROGRAMS
TO TRY TO GET.
THEIR STUDENTS OUT OF THEIR CARS --
BUT FROM TALKING TO A LOT OF THE
HOMELESSNESS LIAISONS AT
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ACROSS THE
STATE ONE OF THE BIGGEST
PROBLEMS THEY HAVE.
IS THEY DON'T KNOW WHO'S
HOMELESS -- AND STUDENTS ARE OUR
EXCHANGE THEY SHOULDN'T BE
BECAUSE SOCIETY'S FAULT BUT
STUDENTS ARE SHAME TO COME
FORWARD AND SAY THAT THEY'RE IN
THE SITUATION -- AND SO WE NEED
TO BREAK DOWN THOSE WALLS OF OF
STIGMATIZATION.
ABOUT STUDENT HOMELESSNESS WE
NEED TO CREATE A SYSTEM WHICH
THIS DOES IN WHICH THE
AMENDMENTS ALSO FURTHER ON YOU
KNOW THAT EFFORT. TO TRY TO
ENCOURAGE STUDENTS. TO TO COME
IN AND ASK FOR HELP AND WE NEED
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO DO A
BETTER JOB OF TELLING OUR
STUDENTS WHAT HELP IS AVAILABLE
I LOOKED AT THE WEBSITES OF FOR
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN MY
DISTRICT IN AROUND MY DISTRICT
ONE OF THEM -- INDIAN CEMETERY
COUNTY IT HAD A DROP DOWN IT
SAID SOMETHING TO THE EFFECT OF
HOUSING ASSISTANCE.
AS AWESOME GREAT UNDER STUDENT
SERVICES YOU CLICK ON THE DROP
DOWN HOUSING ASSISTANCE I
CLICKED ON IT AND WHAT IT WAS
WAS A GLORIFIED CRAIG'S LIST
PAGE.
ARE YOU LOOKING FOR AN APARTMENT
OR DO YOU HAVE AN APARTMENT TO
RENT.
THAT'S NOT THE HOUSING
ASSISTANCE THAT OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS NEED -- AND AND
SO -- WE WE THEN AND NOT SURE
YOU BROUGHT THE ISSUE OF WAGES.
A STUDY CAME OUT TODAY MY
DISTRICT COVERS TWO DIFFERENT
COUNTY SAN MATEO COUNTY SANTA
CLARA COUNTY IN SAN MATEO COUNTY
YOU HAVE TO MAKE AND I'M JUST
TRYING TO REMEMBER OFF THE TOP
OF MY HEAD BUT I THINK WAS A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR. TO
AFFORD A TWO BEDROOM HOUSE OR
APARTMENT.
IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY IT'S IT
WAS ABOUT A HUNDRED FOURTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR THAT'S
INSANE -- THE MASTER PLAN WAS
ALLUDED TO AND I AGREE IT IS
COMPLETELY ANTIQUATED WHICH IS
WHY THE DAY I JOIN THE STATE
ASSEMBLY I CREATED A SELECT
COMMITTEE ON THE NINETEEN SIXTY
MASTER PLAN FOR HIGHER EDUCATION --
AND HELD HEARINGS ALL THROUGHOUT
THE STATE LAST YEAR TO IN
SACRAMENTO ONE IN SAN JOSE ONE
FRESNO ONE OF RIVERSIDE WHERE I
HEARD FROM SO MANY STUDENTS
ABOUT THE BASIC NEEDS IN
SECURITY THEY'RE FACING THE
FIRST ISSUE WAS.
HOMELESSNESS THE SECOND ISSUE
WAS FOOD AND SECURITY AND THE
THIRD ISSUE WAS A LACK OF ACCESS
TO MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ON
CAMPUS.
AND THAT COMPRISE 95% OF THE
COMMENTS THAT I HEARD FROM
HUNDREDS OF STUDENTS ACROSS THE
STATE -- AND AND I KNOW SOME
COMMUNITY COLLEGES SAID HEY WE
GOT SNOW WE'RE WE'VE GOT HUNDRED
DEGREE WEATHER AND AND THIS
ISN'T SAFE.
THE STUDENTS ARE DOING THIS
TONIGHT.
THIS BILL DOESN'T CREATE
STUDENTS SLEEPING IN THEIR CAR
THIS BILL TRIES TO PROVIDE A
SAFER PLACE FOR THEM TO DO WHAT
THEY'RE ALREADY DOING -- AND IF
WE CAN FIND AN EVEN BETTER
OPTION AND THE STATE NEEDS TO DO
A BETTER JOB OF FUNDING THAT
BETTER OPTION THAN A FULLY
SUPPORTED I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR BILL THAT YOU'RE DOING.
TO TO UPDATES FINANCIAL AID FOR
COMMUNICABLE STUDENTS CAUSES
DESPERATELY NEEDED -- THE THE
AND AND TO TO GET YOU KNOW.
MAKE CLEAR TO EVERYBODY.
HI AND I IMAGINE NOBODY ELSE IS
GOING TO VOTE YES ON THIS BILL
AND THEN SAY OKAY WE SOLVE THE
PROBLEM -- THIS IS REALLY A
BANDAID A SHORT TERM TRIAGE
SOLUTION -- WHILE WE WORK ON ON
THE LONGER TERM -- ISSUES SO --
AND I LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH
EVERYBODY INCLUDING FOLKS WHO
DON'T LIKE THIS BILL TO ADDRESS
THEIR CONCERNS TO WORK ON THOSE
ISSUES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR PAN MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM SIX EIGHTY THREE OH TO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
JUDICIARY LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE WILK AYE WILK AYE
CHANG CHANG I DO NESTLE RUSSELL
AYE GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN.
PAN AYE.
THE BILL HAS ENOUGH VOTES TO GET
OUT BUT WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN
FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS TO ADD ON
THANK YOU GENTLEMEN FOR BEING
HERE WE APPRECIATE YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WELCOME VERY MUCH.
YOU'RE WELCOME AND I THINK YOU
HAVE ANOTHER BILL ASSEMBLY
MEMBER.
THIS IS ITEM.
SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE TWENTY ONE
BEGIN WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS -- THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT AB FIVE
TWENTY ONE TODAY THIS BILL WOULD
TASK THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA FIREARM VIOLENCE
RESEARCH CENTER WITH RESEARCHING
DEVELOPING IMPLEMENTING AND
EVALUATING EDUCATION AND
TRAINING PROGRAMS. FOR HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS ON PREVENTING
FIREARM RELATED HARM AMONG
PATIENTS.
CALIFORNIA EXPERIENCES
UNACCEPTABLY HIGH RATES OF
FIREARM RELATED DEATH AND INJURY.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE
CENTER FOR THE CENTERS FOR
DISEASE CONTROL AND PREVENTION
REPORTED THREE THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY FOUR FIREARM
RELATED DEATHS IN CALIFORNIA.
INCLUDING ONE THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED TEN SUICIDES AND ONE
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED THIRTY
FIVE HOMICIDES. FOR THE MORE
MASS SHOOTINGS ARE CHANGING THE
CHARACTER OF PUBLIC LIFE IN THE
STATE.
JUST LAST NOVEMBER MASS SHOOTING
A BORDERLINE BAR AND GRILL IN
THOUSAND OAKS CALIFORNIA
RESULTED IN TWELVE DEATHS.
LAST YEAR THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF PHYSICIANS PUBLISHED A
POSITION PAPER THAT RECOMMENDS A
PUBLIC HEALTH APPROACH THE FARMS
RELATED VIOLENCE.
IN THE PREVENTION OF FIREARM
INJURIES AND DEATHS.
WHILE MANY HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS
RECOGNIZE THE RESPONSIBILITY TO
HELP PREVENT FARM RELATED INJURY
AND DEATH.
MANY CITE A LACK OF KNOWLEDGE
REGARDING WHEN AND HOW TO
COUNSEL PATIENTS.
AS A PRINCIPAL BARRIER TO ACTION.
A POSITION STATEMENT ADOPTED BY
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN STATED THAT EXPANDED
EDUCATION AND TRAINING ARE
NEEDED. TO IMPROVE CLINICIAN
FAMILIARITY WITH THE BENEFITS
AND RISKS OF FIREARM OWNERSHIP
SAFETY PRACTICES AND
COMMUNICATION WITH PATIENTS
ABOUT FARM VIOLENCE.
AB FIVE TWENTY ONE RECOGNIZES
THAT HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS ARE
UNIQUELY POSITIONED TO HELP
PREVENT FIREARM RELATEDHARLEM.
AND AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA FARM VIOLENCE
RESEARCH CENTER IS UNIQUELY
QUALIFIED TO EQUIP THEM WITH THE
EDUCATION TRAINING AND RESOURCES
NEEDED TO IDENTIFY PATIENTS AT
RISK FOR SUCH HARM.
PROVIDE EVIDENCE BASED
COUNSELING TO MITIGATE RISK AND
INTERVENE IN SITUATIONS OF IMAGE
OF IMMINENT DANGER.
WITH ME TODAY IS DOCTOR GARREN
WHEN A MUTE WHEN YOU.
THE DIRECT I ALWAYS GET IT WRONG
THE DIRECTOR FOR THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA FARM VIOLENCE
RESEARCH CENTER -- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE
READY.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS GOOD MORNING
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME --
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN
MENTIONED FIREARM VIOLENCE IS A
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM IN
CALFORNIA WE HAVE NEARLY AS
MANY DEATHS FROM GUNSHOT WOUNDS
AS WE DO FROM CAR CRASHES IN
THIS STATE.
AND IS A PRACTICING EMERGENCY
PHYSICIAN.
LIKE MY CLINICAL COLLEAGUES I AM
WELL AWARE OF THE IMPORTANCE OF
PREVENTION MOST PEOPLE WHO DIE
FROM GUNSHOT WOUNDS DIE WERE
THERE SHOT DOESN'T MATTER HOW
GOOD THE MEDICAL CARE SYSTEM IS.
THESE PEOPLE ARE JUST DEAD FROM
MOVES THAT ARE NOT SURVIVABLE.
SO PREVENTION HERE IS HAS
IMPORTANT AS IS PREVENTION OF
DEATHS FROM CANCER AND HEART
DISEASE FROM MOTOR VEHICLE
CRASHES THEMSELVES.
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MENTIONED
THERE'S BEEN A SURGE OF INTEREST
ON THE PART OF HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS NOT JUST HERE IN
CALIFORNIA BUT NATIONWIDE TO GET
OFF THE SIDELINES. TO GET INTO
PREVENTING THE PROBLEM THAT THEY
TREAT ACUTELY AND TREAT THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THEY DON'T KNOW
WHAT TO DO THIS IS NEW TO
MEDICINE IT'S NEW TO THE HEALTH
PROFESSIONS.
AND THE PROPOSAL IS TO CREATE
THE CURRICULUM AND THE MATERIALS
AT THE OUT REACH SYSTEM TO A
QUICK HEALTH PROFESSIONALS IN
CALIFORNIA TO TAKE ON THIS
IMPORTANT NEW JOB AND ALSO TO
SET A MODEL.
FOR HEALTH PROFESSIONALS AND
ORGANIZATIONS IN OTHER STATES
WHICH QUITE FRANKLY MODEL
SETTING IS ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT CALIFORNIA DOES BEST -- I
WILL MAKE JUST ONE OBSERVATION
AND THEN FINISH.
THIS INTEREST IS NOT ON THE PART
OF HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
THEMSELVES ARE CENTER HAS JUST
RECENTLY COMPLETED A SURVEY OF
THE GENERAL PUBLIC IN CALIFORNIA.
AND WE FIND THAT MORE THAN 90%
OF CALIFORNIANS AND MORE THAN
80% OF CALIFORNIA'S GUN OWNERS
SUPPORT CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS AND
PATIENTS ABOUT FIREARMS SAFETY
WHEN IT'S RELEVANT WHICH IS WHEN
WE RECOMMEND THOSE CONVERSATIONS.
CONVERSATIONS OCCUR THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU SIR
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MICHELLE RIVERA EMERGENCY NURSES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
MORNING DOCTOR DONALD LYMAN WITH
YOUR LOCAL MEDICAL SOCIETY ZERO
SACRAMENTO VALLEY MEDICAL
SOCIETY IN SUPPORT.
DR MARK HORTON SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
HEALTH ASSOCIATION NORTH
REPRESENTING OUR HUNDREDS OF
PUBLIC HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
THROUGHOUT NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT.
AMANDA WILCOX ON BEHALF OF BRADY
CALIFORNIA UNITED AGAINST GUN
VIOLENCE IN SUPPORT.
TIM MADDEN REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS IN SUPPORT.
SERRA BENEDICT ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN FOUNDATION FOR SUICIDE
PREVENTION AND SUPPORT.
MEDIA ONE REPRESENTING AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS CALIFORNIA
DIVISION WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL WAS
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SIR ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
SENATOR PAN.
THANK YOU I'M AT THE END THANK
YOU AS A MEMBER FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD AND THIS
REALLY IS ABOUT HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS BEING WITH THE
COUNCIL FAMILIES ABOUT HOW TO
KEEP THEIR LOVED ONES SAFE --
BOTH AT HOME AND OTHER PLACES I
BELIEVE -- AND DOCTOR MANY IT'S
MORE THE EXPERT BUT I BELIEVE --
ACTUALLY -- TODDLERS -- SHOOT.
THERE THE PEOPLE ARE SHOT BY
TODDLERS AT LEAST WEEKLY.
AND UNITED STATES.
SO THINK ABOUT THAT TODDLERS
WERE ABLE TO GET ALL THE GUN AND
SHOOT SOMEONE WEEKLY.
I THINK WE CAN PRESUME THAT WAS
NOT INTENTIONAL.
BUT THE FACT THAT THEY COULD
ACCESS TO A GUN AND AND BE ABLE
TO PULL THE TRIGGER AND OF THE
LOADED AND THAT WOULD ACTUALLY
SHOOT SOMEONE IS SOMETHING.
THAT WE SHOULD GIVE PAUSE TO AND
I THINK CERTAINLY IS --
PEDIATRICIAN -- THEY KNOW THE
AMERICAN CAT PEDIATRICS HAS
GUIDELINES ABOUT COUNSELING
FAMILIES ABOUT SAFETY THIS IS
REALLY WHAT IT'S ABOUT AND I
APPRECIATE BRING THE BILL
FORWARD AND GENTLY HAPPEN TO
MOVE IT TO PROTOTYPE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER PAN SENATOR
WILK.
A AT THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I
VERY KHAMIS'S PROPOSAL SURPRISED
THAT WE HAVEN'T DONE IT SOONER.
AND I'M HAPPY POOR READING THE
ANALYSIS THAT YOU'RE NOT HAVING
TO TAKE ANY -- COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS ON THE ALTHOUGH I
THINK YOU DO SO I THINK YOU'RE
PRETTY HAPPY WITH IT SO I'LL BE
SUPPORT OF THE BILL TODAY.
THE SENATE THANK YOU CENTER WORK
I CAN'T WAIT TO ONE OF YOUR
BILLS COME.
BE LOOKING FOR THAT.
THANK YOU MEMBERS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE
THANK YOU THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR PAM AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE TWENTY
ONE THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
PUBLIC SAFETY LEYVA AYE LEYVA
AYE WILK.
WILK I CHIANG CHIANG AYE LASSELL.
RUSSELL AYE GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN
CAN I THE BILL HAS ENOUGH VOTES
TO GET OUT WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN
FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS TO ADD ON
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AS OF THE MOMENT GONZALEZ YOU
HAVE A FILE ITEM NUMBER.
ELEVEN AB SEVEN SEVEN THREE
BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO START BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS.
AB SEVEN SEVENTY THREE WILL HELP
QUIPPED YOUNG ADULTS TO BECOME
ENGAGED CITIZENS BY REQUIRING
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO IMPLEMENT
VOTER EDUCATION PROGRAMMING FOR
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS.
I'LL REMIND FOLKS THAT SO MANY
OF US LEARNED HOW TO VOTE BY
GOING WITH HER PARENTS ARE
LEARNED FROM OUR PARENTS IN
TODAY'S HIGH SCHOOLERS THERE ARE
SO MANY WHO HAVE PARENTS WHO ARE
IN ELIGIBLE TO VOTE OR HAVE
NEVER VOTED THEMSELVES.
AND SO WE HAVE DONE TREMENDOUS
EFFORTS TO REGISTER TO PRE
REGISTER TO ENGAGE THESE VOTERS
BUT WE'VE NEVER TOLD THEM WHAT
THEY'RE GOING TO BE DOING.
SO THE MECHANICS OF VOTING CAN
BE SCARY FOR PEOPLE WHO AREN'T
FAMILIAR WITH THIS WITH THE
SYSTEM NOT GETTING IT RIGHT CAN
BE SCARY.
OUR YOUNG VOTER SHOULD KNOW HOW
TO REGISTER TO VOTE WHAT THE
DEADLINES WHAT DEADLINES EXIST
HAD RETURNED A BALLOT TO COUNTY
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS HAD ACQUIRE
LANGUAGE ACCESS MATERIALS AND
INFORMATION ON THE RIGHT TO THE
VOTER HOW TO GET NONPARTISAN
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT'S ON THE
BALLOT.
THESE ARE SIMPLE THINGS TO TEACH
BUT CAN MAKE A WORLD OF
DIFFERENCE FOR YOUNG VOTERS.
AB SEVEN SEVENTY THREE WILL
ACCOMPLISH THIS BY REQUIRING THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND THE SECRETARY OF
STATE TO DEVELOP EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMMING FOR IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE LOCAL LEVEL.
LOCAL COUNTY ELECTIONS OFFICIALS
WILL ALSO BE REQUIRED TO ENSURE
THAT PROGRAMMING IS SPECIFICALLY
TAILORED TO THE ELECTION SYSTEM
IN THAT COUNTY AS WE KNOW COUNTY
BY COUNTY OR BALLOTS LOOK
DIFFERENT.
THEY NEED TO KNOW WHAT TO EXPECT
WHEN THEY FIRST WALK INTO THE
VOTING BOOTH.
IT'S NO LONGER ENOUGH TO JUST
SIMPLY REGISTER VOTERS WE NEED
TO LITERALLY TEACH YOUNG PEOPLE
THE MECHANICS OF VOTING AND
DIDN'T DEMYSTIFY THE ENTIRE
ELECTRICAL ELECT WORLD PROCESS.
I HAVE SOME WITNESSES HERE WITH
ME TODAY.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN WELCOME LADIES
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY
TO MINUTES EACH.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF MY BUT IT US ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION A CO SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL.
AT FIRST LIKE TO START BY
THINKING AT THE MOMENT.
GONZALEZ FOR HER LEADERSHIP ON
THIS MEASURE -- IN THE RECENT
YEAR IN RECENT YEARS THERE HAVE
BEEN SIGNIFICANT STATEWIDE
EFFORTS AIMED AT INCREASING
VOTER REGISTRATION AMONG YOUNG
ADULTS SUCH AS MANDATING HIGH
SCHOOL VOTER EDUCATION WEEKS AND
ALLOWING SIXTEEN AND SEVENTEEN
YEAR OLDS TO BE REGISTERED TO
VOTE.
HOWEVER FROM THE STATE
REPRESENTS BECTIVE -- THE
SUPERINTENDENT BELIEVES WE CAN
DO MORE TO SUPPORT OUR SCHOOLS
AND EDUCATING STUDENTS ABOUT
VOTE THE VOTING PROCESS MANY OF
THESE NEW VOTERS.
MAY NOT BE AWARE OF THE NEW WAYS
THEY CAN CAST A BALLET AND MAY
NOT UNDERSTAND OR HAVE
DIFFICULTIES UNDERSTANDING.
THE BALLOT AND VOTING PROCESS AB
SEVEN SEVENTY THREE WILL ALLOW
VOTERS WILL ALLOW STUDENTS TIME --
I'M SORRY.
MANY OF AB SEVEN SENATE THREE
WHAT ENHANCE CALIFORNIA'S VOTER
EDUCATION EFFORTS AND PROVIDE
STUDENTS WITH THE KNOWLEDGE
NECESSARY. TO BECOME BALLOT
BALLOT LITERATE AND ELECTORALLY
ENGAGE CITIZENS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS GOOD
<c.magenta>ORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS</c>
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
PATTY HER ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
DIEGO UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IS
A PROUD SPONSOR OF THE BILL.
WE THINK THAT THIS BILL
COMPLIMENTS THE EARLIER BILL
THAT YOU HEARD BY IT AS A MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS -- WE'D LIKE TO
START THAT ENGAGEMENT EVEN
EARLIER IN OUR HIGH SCHOOLS WE
BELIEVE THAT AB SEVEN SEVENTY
THREE AND THE COMPONENTS OF IT
REALLY PROMOTE TWO THINGS WITH
THAT OUR YOUNG OUR YOUNGEST
VOTERS. ONE IT PROMOTES A SENSE
OF SELF AGENCY AND AND IT ALSO
PROMOTES THEIR SENSE OF
ACCOUNTABILITY AND COMMUNITY AND
RESPONSIBILITY TO OUR LARGER
DEMOCRACY AND BECAUSE OF THAT WE
ASK FOR YOUR AYE BUILT.
THANK YOU WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ERICA HOFFMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT WE ARE
DRIVE OUT THANK YOU.
ERIC HARRIS WITH DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
IF SOMEONE THE LONGER BE HAVE A
SECRETARY STATE ALEX BUT THE AND
SUPPORT.
ALOHA ANOTHER PLAN HERE
REPRESENTING NEXT IN CALIFORNIA
AND SUPPORT.
AND YOU MISS FISHER WITH THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT ISRAEL POSITION TO
THE BILL.
SEEING AND HEARING THAT WILL
COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR PAN.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
COMMENTS CONCERNS NONE ASSEMBLY
ONE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE BILL HAS
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR PAN MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
IN LEVIN AB SEVEN SEVEN THREE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO ELECTIONS AND CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENTS LEYVA.
BY LEYVA AYE WILK AYE WILK I
CHIANG CHANGE I THE WRESTLE WITH
US SO I GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN.
PAN HI.
THE BILL HAS ENOUGH VOTES TO GET
OUT BUT WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
MEMBERS TO ADD ON ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BLOOM.
COME ON DOWN YOU HAVE FILE ITEM
TWELVE WHICH IS AB EIGHT TWENTY
NINE BEGIN WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS AB EIGHT TWENTY
NINE PERMITS THE CS USED TO
AWARD DOCTORATE DEGREES IN
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY. TO COMPLY
WITH CHANGING PROFESSIONAL
STANDARDS.
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPISTS OR TEASE
SUPPORT CHILDREN WITH LEARNING
DISABILITIES PEOPLE RECOVERING
FROM INJURIES.
AND OLDER ADULTS EXPERIENCING
COGNITIVE FIVE AND PHYSICAL
CHANGES.
AS WITH MANY HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONS CALIFORNIA HAS A
SHORTAGE OF TEAS AND TO IN FACT
RANKS FORTY FOURTH IN THE NATION
IN ACCESS TO OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPISTS.
CURRENTLY SEVENTY SIX OF THE
NINETY SIX OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY
MASTER'S DEGREE PROGRAMS IN THE
COUNTRY ARE TRANSITIONING TO A
DOCTORATE DEGREE PROGRAM.
INCLUDING ALL OF CALIFORNIA'S
PRIVATE PROGRAMS.
SO AB EIGHT TWENTY NINE WILL
PROVIDE CALIFORNIANS WITH AN
AFFORDABLE OPTION AT THE CS USE
FOR STUDENTS PURSUING A CAREER
IN OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY.
THE COST OF ATTENDANCE AT THE
CSU FOR AN OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY
DEGREE IS FOUR TIMES LESS.
THAN THE AT THE STATE'S PRIVATE
INSTITUTIONS IN WITH A PROJECTED
GROWTH OF AN IN EMPLOYMENT BY
24%.
OUR ABILITY TO OFFER THESE
PUBLIC PROGRAMS WILL GREATLY
IMPACT THE SUPPLY OF HIGHLY
SOUGHT AFTER HEALTH CARE
SPECIALISTS. TO TESTIFY AB DR
TERRY PERALTA THE CHAIR OF
DEPARTMENT OF OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPY AT CSU DOMINGUEZ HILLS.
AND MAGGIE WHITE WITH THE CSU
OFFICE OF THE CHANCELLOR.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE
READY.
WONDERFUL THING GUESTS AND
REMEMBER.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE AYE MAGGIE
WHITE WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY OFFICE OF THE
CHANCELLOR.
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TODAY TO SPEAK ON AB EIGHT TO
NINE ARE CSU BOARD OF TRUSTEES
SPONSORED LEGISLATION.
WE'RE VERY APPRECIATIVE OF ALL
THE INFORMATION SHARED IN THE
ANALYSIS AND WE WILL KEEP THIS
BRIEF.
I'D LIKE TO TURN OVER TO OUR
EXPERT DR TERRY PERALTA WHO CAN
SPEAK TO THE SUCCESS AND
SIGNIFICANCE OF THESE PROGRAMS.
THANK YOU PM WHEN YOU'RE READY.
YES GOOD MORNING EVERYONE -- MY
NAME IS SAID DR TERRY BROUGHT
THE GOT THE POINT I CHAIRED
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY DEPARTMENT
AT CAL STATE DOMINGUEZ HILLS FOR
TEN YEARS NOW.
I'VE BEEN AN OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPIST FOR TWENTY YEARS I'M
REALLY HAPPY TO BE HERE BECAUSE
I REALLY FEEL THAT CALIFORNIA'S
DESERVE -- PUBLIC ACCESS ACCESS
TO PUBLICLY FUNDED ADVANCED
EDUCATION AND OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPY.
AS YOU KNOW THE CSU HAS THE ONLY
PUBLIC BACK TO CARRIER IN
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY IN THE
STATE.
IN BETWEEN THE TWO PROGRAMS OF
THE MINGUS HILLS INSANITY STATE
WE CURRENTLY GRADUATE 30% OF THE
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPIST EDUCATED
IN CALIFORNIA.
OUR GRADUATES HAVE A NINETY
SEVEN AT LEAST PASS RATE ON THE
NATIONAL CERTIFICATION EXAM.
THIS AUTHORITY WOULD ALLOW US TO
CONTINUE THE GREAT SUCCESS OF
OUR MASTERS LEVEL PROGRAMS.
AND ARE VITAL COMMUNITY
PARTNERSHIP WHILE MEETING THE
WORK FORCE DEMAND FOR DOCTORATE
LEVEL EDUCATION AND
SPECIALIZATION.
ACROSS THE NATION 80% OF
MASTER'S PROGRAMS ARE CURRENTLY
TRANSITIONING TO OFFERING A
DOCTORATE TO MEET THE DEMAND FOR
THIS LEVEL OF EDUCATION.
AS EVIDENCED BY THE MANY LETTERS
OF SUPPORT SUBMITTED BY OUR
COMMUNITY PARTNERS WHICH INCLUDE
ALAMEDA HEALTH SYSTEM TORRANCE
MEMORIAL MEDICAL CENTER AND MANY
OTHER REGIONAL CLINICS BUT FOCUS
ON SPECIALTY CARE.
ARE CSU STUDENTS ARE HARD
WORKING HIGHLY SKILLED AND EAGER
TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
WE BELIEVE THE HEALTHCARE FOR
WORK FOR SHOULD REFLECT OUR
POPULATION THAT'S WHY AND
AFFORDABLE PUBLIC DEGREE IS SO
IMPORTANT NOT JUST FOR STUDENTS
BUT FOR THE STATE.
THE COST OF TUITION OF
CALIFORNIA'S PRIVATE MASTER'S
PROGRAMS IN OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY
RANGES FROM 850-002-10030.
THREE THOUSAND AT CSU THE TOTAL
COST OF TUITION FOR A TWO AND A
HALF YEAR MASTERS PROGRAM IS
ROUGHLY.
NINETEEN THOUSAND WE ANTICIPATE
THAT THE DOCTORATE LEVEL DEGREE%
YOU WOULD CONTINUE TO BRING
SIGNIFICANT COST SAVINGS TO OUR
STUDENTS.
WE ARE VERY PROUD TO OFFER A
PUBLIC BACK TO A CAREER IN THIS
IMPORTANT HEALTH CARE FIELD.
AND WE KNOW THAT OUR STUDENTS
AND GRADUATES ARE CHANGING LIVES
THANK YOU AND WE ARE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY OF YOUR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL IN THIS IS
IN SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBER I'VE I'VE
BEEN ALL TOMORROW ON BEHALF OF
THE OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING INTERESTED OVER
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND OCCUPATION
THIRD PERSON CALIFORNIANS STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING AND HEARING THEN WE'LL
COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS.
THE BILL THANK YOU SIR WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU -- AS MANY OF YOU --
MAY KNOW I'VE LIVED WITH AN
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPIST FOR THE
LAST FORTY YEARS AND SO ON HER
BEHALF AND ON BEHALF OF ALL THE
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPISTS AND
CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SIMPLY MEMBER THE BILL
HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR WELL
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ITEM TWELVE AB EIGHT TWENTY
NINE THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA I LEAVE THE
AYE WILK AYE WILK AYE CHANGE.
CHIANG I'D WRESTLED GLAZER
MCGUIRE PAN.
WE BELIEVE THAT BILL OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS TO ADD ON
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALRIGHT.
WE ARE HERE IN SENATE EDUCATION
LOOKING FOR AUTHORS.
WE'RE LOOKING FOR ASSEMBLY MAN
[inaudible]
TOO MURATSUCHI.
RIVAS THREE OF US AND LOW AND
MCCARTY
.
IF.
YOU WANT.
WELL MY A A VICE CHAIR HAD AN
EXCELLENT IDEA THAT WE SHOULD DO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR WHILE
WAITING SO I THINK WE SHOULD DO
THAT.
ON CONSENT TODAY IS ITEM FIVE AB
TWO THIRTY SIX ITEM SIXTEEN AB
TWELVE SEVENTY EIGHT ITEM.
TWENTY AB FOURTEEN TEN ITEM
TWENTY ONE AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY
THREE CONSENT AS AMENDED I AM
TOO AB.
TWENTY EIGHT ITEM THIRTEEN AB
EIGHT FIFTY TWO WHAT THE MEMBERS
LIKE TO TAKE ANYTHING OFF OF
CONSENT.
IS THERE A MOTION ON THE CONSENT.
THANK YOU THE CONSECUTIVE HAS
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR WILK MAN
I'M SICK SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL LEAVE THEM HI.
I WILL I WILL I CHANGE CHIANG
.
A SALUTE AS A WOMAN MURATSUCHI
COME ON UP.
THANK YOU.
AND YOU'RE GONNA BE PRESENTING
ITEM NINE A. B. SEVEN TWENTY
WITH THE RECOMMENDATION -- DO
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS SO
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
PLEASE PROCEED.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR.
I AM HERE 2% -- ASSEMBLY BILL --
SEVEN TWENTY WHICH IS A BILL
SUPPORTED BY MANY COMMITTEE
COLLEGES AS WELL AS BY OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS.
THIS BILL IS PROPOSING A
COMMONSENSE FIX TO THE
COMMUNICABLE IS FUNDING FORMULA
FORMULA THAT WE ADOPTED LAST
YEAR. TO ADDRESS THE UNIQUE
SITUATION FACING COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WITH PUBLIC SAFETY
TRAINING PROGRAMS FOR
FIREFIGHTERS AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS.
ALMOST HALF OF ALL COULD
CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE CALLS
DISTRICTS HAVE INSTRUCTIONAL
SERVICE AGREEMENTS WITH THEIR
LOCAL PUBLIC SAFETY AGENCIES. TO
PROVIDE OVER FIFTEEN THOUSAND
FIREFIGHTERS AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS WITH ONGOING
PROFESSIONAL TRAINING.
LAST YEAR THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED A NEW COMMUNICATIONS
FUNDING FORMULA THAT
UNFORTUNATELY PROVIDES LESS
FUNDING FOR THESE PUBLIC SAFETY
TRAINING PROGRAMS.
AB SEVEN TWENTY CALLS FOR THESE
PUBLIC SAFETY PROGRAMS TO BE
FUNDED OUTSIDE OF THE NEW
FUNDING FORMULA SO THAT WE CAN
SUPPORT OUR FIRST RESPONDERS
WITH THE TRADING THAT THEY NEED.
I AM PLEASED TO HAVE DOCTOR
CAROL GOLDSMITH THE PRESIDENT OF
FRESNO CITY COLLEGE -- AS WELL
AS LIEUTENANT TOM ROW NOW WITH
THE FOR THE FRESNO POLICE
DEPARTMENT REGIONAL TRAINING
CENTER -- HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER GOOD
AFTERNOON WELL NOT QUITE YET
GOOD MORNING WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT TWO MINUTES EACH PLEASE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND THANK
YOU HONORABLE SENATORS FOR
LISTENING TO THIS BILL TODAY.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO THINK US
SENATOR WILK FOR CO SPONSORING
THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THAT SUPPORT WE APPRECIATE
IT.
MY NAME IS CAROL GOLDSMITH AND
I'M THE PROUD PRESIDENT
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST COMMUNITY
COLLEGE IN FRESNO.
AND AS I'M HERE TO SUPPORT OF AB --
SEVEN TWENTY BEING ABLE TO FULLY
FUND THE INSTRUCTIONAL SERVICE
AGREEMENTS WITH OUR PUBLIC
SERVICE AGENCIES.
AS THIS MAY BE A PARENT
OVERSIGHT OF OUR OF FUNDING
FORMULA WHICH WE ARE ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF THE FUNDING FORULA
CURRENTLY -- TAKES OUT --
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTS THIS
PARTICULAR TRAINING PROGRAM ALL
WE'RE ASKING FOR PARITY IN THIS
OP PARTICULAR RESPONSE SIMILAR
TO WHAT WE'RE DOING FOR
INCARCERATED -- PROGRAMS KNOWING
THAT EDUCATION DOES MATTER FOR
OUR INCARCERATED ADULTS AND WE
WANT TO CONTINUE TO THAT.
AS WELL WE WANT TO CONTINUE OUR
DUAL ENROLLMENT WERE ASKING FOR
PARITY FOR THIS PARTICULAR --
BILL.
AS YOU MAY KNOW CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES PROVIDE THE
INITIAL AS WELL AS THE POST
CERTIFIED TRAINING FOR OVER 90%.
OF A PUBLIC SAFETY WORKERS IN
THE STATE.
HAS OVER 90% OF YOUR FIRE POLICE
AND FIRST RESPONDERS EMT
PARAMEDICS THIS IS INCREDIBLE
PUBLIC SAFETY ISSUE -- JUST FOR
FRESNO CITY COLLEGE TO PUT A
LITTLE CONTEXT INTO WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT OVER THE LAST
THREE SEMESTERS -- WE HAVE
TRAINED AFTER CERTIFICATION FOR
FIRE ALONE OVER TWENTY THREE
HUNDRED FIREFIGHTERS THROUGHOUT
OUR AREA.
MATTER OF FACT MANY OF THE
FIREFIGHTERS THAT HELPED PUT OUT
THE RECENT FIRES AT JUST NORTH
OF US.
THANK YOU HAVE GONE THROUGH OUR
TRAINING.
IT'S INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT WE
CONTINUE TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
THIS SERVICE.
SOME OF THE TOPICS THAT A RANGE
FROM -- THAT WE PROVIDE.
ADVANCING NOT ADVANCE LIFESAVING
SKILLS ADVANCE FIRE FIGHTING
WILDLAND FIREFIGHTING.
WE DO OFFICER TRAINING AS WELL
AS FIRE PREVENTION AND I THINK
WE CAN ALL AGREE CALIFORNIA
NEEDS MORE FIRE PREVENTION
EDUCATION.
LAST YEAR FOR FRESNO CITY
COLLEGE -- IN TERMS OF OUR
POLICE ACADEMY POST
CERTIFICATION WE EDUCATED AND
TRAINED FOUR THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED SEVENTY TWO OFFICERS.
AND THAT'S NOT JUST WITH FRESNO
PD IT'S WAS SACRAMENTO PD FOR
TULARE COUNTY PD SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT FIRST RESPONDERS ALL
OVER THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA --
AS I ASKED WERE ASKING FOR OUR
POLICE AND FIRE COMMITTEES TO
PLEASE -- BE TREATED AS THOUGH
WE HAVE WITH OUR OTHER ADS
SPECIAL POPULATIONS IN PRISON.
SO THE WHILE THE BILL HAS
WIDESPREAD SUPPORT AND A HOST OF
CONTINGENTS -- CONSTITUENCY
GROUP APPROVALS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS TOM
ROJOS MENTION EMILY TEN WITH
FRESNO POLICE DEPARTMENT AND I
HAVE OVERSIGHT OF OUR TRAINING
CENTER.
OUR TRAINING CENTER PROVIDES
INSTRUCTION CLASSES FOR PARKS ME --
TWENTY JUST UNDER THREE THOUSAND
OFFICERS EACH YEAR.
AND YOU MAY OR MAY NOT KNOW BUT
THE FEBRUARY OF SEVENTEEN POSTS
THE PEACE OFFICER STANDARDS AND
TRAINING GREATLY REDUCED THEIR
REIMBURSEMENT FUNDING FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT TRAINING IT WAS DUE
TO BUDGETARY ISSUES BUT IT DID
HAPPEN.
I'M AS A RESULT OF THAT AGENCY
SUCH AS MINE OF COME HEAVILY
RELIANT ON ICY AGREEMENTS WITH
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE PARTNERS.
IF WE WERE TO LOSE THIS TYPE OF
FINDING IT WILL HAVE A DRAMATIC
IMPACT ON THE LEVEL OF TRAINING
AND THE NUMBER OF TRAINS WE CAN
PROVIDE TO OUR PERSONNEL.
AND DURING A TIME WHEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS AND DEMANDS
ARE UNDER INCREASED SCRUTINY I'M
NOT SURE IF THIS IS THE BEST
COURSE OF ACTION.
SO WITHOUT A MASKING FOR THE
CATHOLIC MANY SUPPORTER PAL
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
HE ALSO WEBSTER ATTENDED PUBLIC
AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF THE COAST
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
RANCHES SANTIAGO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT IN THE ORANGE
COUNTY COMMUNITY COLLEGE
LEGISLATIVE TASK FORCE IN
SUPPORT.
A CLOSER FOR FOR CARRY ME
PRESENT CITY COLLEGE COORDINATOR --
ALSO REPRESENTING THE TEN ICY
PARTNER AGENCIES THAT WE HAVE
AND VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA FIRE TECH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
YOUR IF YOU DIRECTOR THE POLICE
ACADEMY EFFORTS ON A COLLEGE
CAMPUS A THIRTY YEAR VETERAN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AMONG OVERSEEING ALL
THE INSTRUCTIONAL SERVICES
AGREEMENT AND THOUSANDS OF HOURS
OF TRAINING WE PROVIDE.
FOR HUNDREDS OF OFFICERS AT WORK
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY FOR CITY
COUNTY AND STATE LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AND STRONGER SUPPORT.
MORNING MY NAME IS SEAN SHOULD
KLEINIAN.
I'M A RECRUIT TRAINING OFFICER
FOR THE FRESNO CITY COLLEGE
POLICE ACADEMY.
HERE SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING LYNN WILLIAMS OUR
COACH RETURNING OFFICER FOR
FRESNO COUNTY FRESNO CITY
COLLEGE -- THESE COUNTY HERE IN
SUPPORT.
ASHLEY WALKER WITH NASA MEN ON
BEHALF OF MOUNT SAN ANTONIO
COLLEGE IN SUPPORT.
NOT TO DO IT PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA FIRED TECHNOLOGY
DIRECTOR ASSOCIATION AND
DOCUMENT FACULTY MEMBERS HERE
COLLEGE COMMITTEE CALLS DISTRICT.
IN SUPPORT.
WAS THAT EVER TO BE HAVE ME
COLDLY OF CALIFORNIANS STRONG
SUPPORT.
KEVIN TRYING TO SUPER DINNER
PRESIDENT OF FEATHER RIVER
COLLEGE IN QUINCY CALIFORNIA
WHERE I DROVE THROUGH THIRTY
MILES OF CAMPFIRES CARS TO GET
HERE TODAY AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT
TO TRAIN OUR FIREFIGHTERS.
GOOD MORNING MARLIN MARTINEZ
PRESIDENTS OF THE SILLY COLLEGE
WHERE CAMPUS THE TREES NEARLY
TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND POLICE
OFFICERS WE DO THE MAJORITY OF
THE TRAINING FOR THE LA COUNTY
SHERIFF'S.
THE LONG BEACH FIRE DEPARTMENT
THE LONG BEACH POLICE DEPARTMENT
WE ARE IN FULL SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
GOOD MORNING DINA MALONEY
PRESIDENT AT EL CAMINO COLLEGE
WHERE WE'RE DEVELOPING A PUBLIC
SAFETY TRAINING CENTER TO
ADDRESS A LACK OF SUCH TRAINING
IN OUR AREA.
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING ERIC TARNISHES
CENTER CREE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT BECAUSE OF THE CANYONS
I WANT TO THANK OUR FORMER
TRUSTEE CENTER WILK FOR SIGNING
ON AS A CO AUTHOR.
WE TRAIN LAPD LA COUNTY FIRE IN
LA COUNTY SHERIFF'S AND WE'RE IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING LINDA VON I'M
PRESIDENT OF SOUTH BAY REGIONAL
PUBLIC SAFETY TRAINING
CONSORTIUM WERE CONSORTIUM OF
EIGHT COMMUNITY COLLEGES THAT
DELIVER.
APPROXIMATELY SIX TWENTY SIX
HUNDRED FULL TIME EQUIVALENT --
STUDENT HOURS -- FOR PUBLIC
SAFETY TRAINING FULL SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
SINGING HEARING THAT'LL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS.
HEARING AND SEEING YES UNDER
WILK.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I HAVE A
FIRST DEGREE BILL THE THING THIS
FRUSTRATING TO ME IS THAT.
WE SHOULD EVEN HAVE TO BE HERE
TODAY YOU KNOW THE FACT IN
MATTER I WAS ON BUDGET FOR YEARS
I'M NO LONGER ON BUDGET I AM
THANKFUL FOR THAT.
BECAUSE BOTH THE SENATE AND THE
ASSEMBLY REJECTED THE NEW FOR
THE FUNDING FOR MEAL PLAN FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES BECAUSE IT
DIDN'T WORK.
AND LO AND BEHOLD WE GET IT IN A
TRAILER BILL AND IT.
IS NOT BAD IT HAS ALL KINDS OF
PROBLEMS IN THIS IS PROBABLY
MOST GLARING ISSUE WITH IT SO I
RELIEF YOU SALUTE YOU FOR
PUSHING THIS FORWARD.
IN GETTING THIS IS AT DRESSES
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
THANK THANK YOU SIR FOR SIGNING
ON AS A CO AUTHOR.
THANK YOU CENTER WILK I WOULD
DISAGREE THAT THE TRAILER BILL
WASN'T VETTED BUT THIS IS A GOOD
BILL NONE THE LESS -- AS A
MEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE --
WHICH IS TO EMPHASIZE WHAT TO
SOME OF OUR WITNESSES INDICATED
THAT -- WHETHER WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT -- MAKING SURE THERE ARE
FIREFIGHTERS ARE TRAINED TO DEAL
WITH THE INCREASING NUMBER A
WILD FIRES OR WHETHER WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT -- YOU KNOW WE WE
KNOW THAT -- THE LACK OF FUNDING
FOR POST TRAINING HAS BEEN AN
ONGOING ISSUE BUT ESPECIALLY
THIS YEAR AS THERE'S BEEN SUCH
ATTENTION FOCUSED ON THE NEED
FOR MORE -- POLICE TRAINING I
THINK THIS IS A WIN WIN
SITUATION -- SUPPORT OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES SUPPORT OUR
PUBLIC SAFETY I ASKED FOR A AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SOME A MEMBER WAS A
BILL MOVED SENATOR PANDA JOY
THANK YOU CENTER PAN.
THE BILL MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. NINE EIGHTY SEVEN
TWENTY THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA LEA LE I
WILL.
WILK I CHIANG CHIANG I'D
WRESTLED GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN PAN
HI.
THANK YOU SEVEN MEMBER WILL
LEAVE THAT BILL OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS TO VOTE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY COME ON
DOWN YOU HAVE FILE ITEM.
NINETEEN AB.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE BEGIN
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS IS A BILL RELATED
TO THAT COLLEGE ADMISSIONS
SCANDAL THAT.
WE ALL SAW THIS PAST US BRING
OPERATION VARSITY BLUES ONE OF
THE ISSUES THAT I THINK RELLY
SHOOK.
CALIFORNIA AT BECAUSE THE
COACHES INVOLVE THE UNIVERSITIES
AND THE FAMILIES INVOLVED FOR
CALIFORNIANS WERE.
AT A FEW PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES IN
CALIFORNIA SOME INDIVIDUALS
APPLIED TO TO GET IN AS A
SPECIAL ADMITS -- CLAIMING SOME
TYPE OF ATHLETIC TALENT AND IT
WASN'T VETTED BY A PROPER
INDIVIDUALS WITHIN THE
UNIVERSITY AND INDIVIDUALS ARE
ESSENTIALLY -- FRAUDULENT
GETTING IN A UNIVERSITY AND
TAKING WASTE -- ACCESS FROM
STUDENTS LIKE WE SEE HERE AND
CERTAINLY THIS IS A THIS IS
WRONG IN ANY CASE -- SLOT THAT'S
TONIGHT -- IS DENIED ACCESS FOR
A QUALIFIED CALIFORNIANS SO THIS
IS A REALLY A SIMPLE MEASURE TO
MAKE SURE THEY'RE ADEQUATE
CHECKS AND BALANCES IN THE
SPECIAL -- ADMITS FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND
ALSO THESE CSU SYSTEM -- THE
UNIVERSITY -- AND THE CSU HAVE
ASKED US -- TO PROPOSED AT
OPPOSITE ENDS TODAY WHICH WE OR
OUTLINED WITH YOUR STAFF TO
EXEMPT -- STUDENTS IN THE E. O.
P. PROGRAM SO WE'RE PROPOSING TO
THAT AS WELL TODAY.
AND WITH ME TODAY ARE THREE
STUDENTS WHO WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THE CHECKS AND BALANCES ACT
BEFORE US THIS MORNING THANK YOU
THANK YOU SOME REMEMBER WE DO DO
TWO WITNESSES TWO MINUTES EACH.
BUT IF YOU WANNA DIVIDE
PERFORMANCE UP AMONGST THE THREE
OF YOU THAT WOULD BE JUST FINE
LET YOU DECIDE WHO STARTS.
OKAY CAN OFFER I'LL BE SHORT AND
SWEET -- HELLO SENATORS MY NAME
IS CUDDLES MONDAY ON AND I'M A
STUDENT OF THE SUMMER SUN -- ON
THE NATIONAL AND STATE LEVEL
LATINO MALES ARE FALLING BEHIND
ON HIGHER EDUCATION AND AND
AGREE ATTAINMENT AND AS A FIRST
GENERATION LATINO MALE.
IT WAS WITH THE EMOTIONAL
SUPPORT OF MY FAMILY PEERS A
MOTIVATED ME TO WORK HARD AND
ALLOW ME TO GET ACCEPTED INTO
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA --
I REMEMBER SPENDING COUNTLESS
NIGHTS STUDYING FOR AN UPCOMING
EXAM AND MY PARENTS ARE MADE
WITH ME THERE BY MY SIDE AND
REFLECTING NOW.
IT WAS THEIR SUPPORT THAT THAT
HELPED ME AND MOTIVATED ME.
TO TAKE TO GET PAST LIKE UP.
THE OUTSIDE DISTRACTIONS AND
WHAT FOCUS ON MY SCHOOL WORK AND
THE HELP ME BECOME A BETTER
PERSON AS WELL AS A BETTER
STUDENT.
AND I KNOW THE SAME CAN BE SAID
FOR MANY OF MY PEERS AND THEY
AND THE WHOLE POINT OF THIS IS
THAT.
A CHOIR THE AMERICAN DREAM AND
WE DO THIS AS US LET ME KNOW
IMMIGRANTS ETCETERA WE DO THIS
THROUGH THE A..
THROUGH EDUCATION AND BY
ALLOWING THE WHAT THE FAMILIES
TO PAY TO GET THEIR CHILDREN
INTO UC'S THEY TAKES LOCKED AWAY
FROM HARD WORKING STUDENTS.
COMING FROM DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR ELEVEN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FIRST AND
FOREMOST I WOULD LIKE TO THINK
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY IN
THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR TIME
THIS MORNING AND ALLOW ME TO
SPEAK ON TESTIMONY BEHALF OF THE
UCLA COMMUNITY.
AND MARGINALIZE STUDENTS AS A
WHOLE AT THE CORE A. B. THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE IS DESIGNED TO
ENSURE THAT EVERY STUDENT IS
ABLE TO RECEIVE A FAIR AND
QUALITY EDUCATION WITHOUT FEAR
HAVING THEIR MISSIONS
OPPORTUNITIES WINDOW BY SYSTEM
DESIGNED TO SERVE THE PRIVILEGED
FEW.
MY EXPERIENCE AT UCLA DURING
BOTH MY UNDERGRADUATE AND
GRADUATE TENURE SERVES AS AN
EXAMPLE OF THE BENEFITS OF AN
ISSUES SUCH AS AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION CAN DO TO SERVE UNDER
REPRESENTED COMMUNITIES.
AS AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDENT UCLA
I WAS A MINUTE IN PART THROUGH
THE AFFIRMATIVE ACTION
INITIATIVE WITH THE SUPPORT OF
THE ACADEMIC ADVANCEMENT PROGRAM
AT UCLA WHICH IS THE NATION'S
LARGEST UNIVERSITY BASED STUDENT
DIVERSITY PROGRAM.
AND GOAL IS TO CREATE ANY
MINISTER INNOVATIVE ACADEMIC
PROGRAMS FIRST GENERATION LOW
INCOME AND STUDENTS WHO HAVE
BEEN HISTORICALLY
UNDERREPRESENTED IN HIGHER
EDUCATION.
THE FACT THAT THE STUDENT CAN BE
EMITTED MERELY BASED ON THE
INCOME LEVEL OR SOCIAL
PRIVILEGES MORALLY GROTESQUE AND
REINFORCES THEIR HISTORIC
OPPRESSION OF MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES IN THIS GREAT STATE.
FOR EVERY STUDENT HAS PAID THEIR
WAY THROUGH A SPECIAL MISSION
THERE'S A FULLY QUALIFIED
PERHAPS MARGINALIZE STUDENT
WHOSE WORK TWICE AS HARD TO GET
TO WHERE THEY ARE ACADEMICALLY
AND DOES HAVE BEEN
DISENFRANCHISED FROM AN
ADMISSION OPPORTUNITY. TO
PRESERVE THEIR ACADEMIC GOALS I
CAN ATTEST TO THE DEATH INSIDE
AN OPTIMISM WITHIN EACH BREWING
ESPECIALLY BROWN'S A COLOR.
EVERY STUDENT SHOULD BE IN DOUBT
WITH THE ENABLE BE OVER
INALIENABLE RIGHT TO A QUALITY
EDUCATION WITHOUT PEER
DISENFRANCHISEMENT AB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE DOES JUST THAT.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SHOULD
LEAD BY EXAMPLE FOR THIS NATION
JUST AS WE HAVE DONE TIME AND
TIME AGAIN HI IMPLORED THE
COMMITTEE TO VOTE BY ON A. B.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE AS IT WILL
ENSURE EVERY STUDENT.
HAS THE SAME ACCESS TO A QUALITY
EDUCATION TO CONTRIBUTE TO OUR
EVER MORE DIVERSE COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU YOU TELL ME THE GREAT
ON TIME ABOUT A MINUTE LEFT.
YES GO AHEAD.
MORNING SENATORS MY NAME'S
ELIZABETH I'M CURRENTLY A
STUDENT AT UC DAVIS AND SO IN
ORDER TO YOU GET INTO UC DAVIS I
HAD TO BE BOTH OF JESUS
ACADEMICALLY AND THEIR
EXTRACURRICULAR IS.
NOT ONLY WAS ACHIEVING HIGH
GRADES IN THE HARDEST CLASSES AT
MY SCHOOL I ALSO HAD TO DO
SPORTS YEAR ROUND CITED
VOLLEYBALL YEAR ROUND ON TOP OF
WORKING VOLUNTEERING AT ANIMAL
SHELTERS SENIOR LIVING
COMMUNITIES.
AND I ALSO TUTORED A CHILD WITH
AUTISM SO I HAD TO DO ALL OF
THAT.
IN ORDER TO PROVE MYSELF WORTHY
OF BEING ACCEPTED AND SO WHEN
SOMEONE ELSE IS ABLE TO PAY
THEIR WAY AND THEY'RE TAKING
SPOT FROM SOMEONE.
WHO HAS WORKED SO HARD FOR SO
MANY YEARS AND DOESN'T GET THAT
CHANCE?
VERY WELL SAID -- HARD WORKING
YOUNG WOMAN.
IS THERE A DIGITAL SUPPORT.
OF THE THIRTY MEN RIGHT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY WHEN
I THINK THE AUTHOR FOR TAKING A
MOMENT TODAY TO MINIMIZE THE
BILL'S IMPACT ON OUR E. O. P.
PARTICIPANTS.
WE MAINTAIN A NEUTRAL POSITION
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
OUR REGULAR ME AFTER THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS TAKEN
BY THE AUTHORS OFFICE -- WE HAVE --
ONE PARTICULAR WORD THAT'S WE
THINK WE CAN WORK OUT BUT I
THINK WE'LL BE IN A POSITION
WHERE THE BILLS ARE GOING TO BE
AN ISSUE FOR US SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
HI NOELLE MORE A STUDENT AT SAC
STATE AND BOARD MEMBER FOR
ALLIANCE FOR EDUCATION SOLUTIONS
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
VERY GOOD ANYONE ELSE WANT TO
RUN UP FOR SUPPORT.
ALRIGHT IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL.
CNN WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE.
SENATOR PAN.
THAT'S IT THANK YOU A CENTER
CARD FOR BRING THIS BILL FORD I
AM CURIOUS AND OUT OF YOU KNOW
THE ANSWER SO -- THE PEOPLE
GUIDED BEFORE UNDER THE
EXCEPTION WHO HAD TO SIGN ON OFF
OF IT BEFORE WAS A JUST A COACH
OR I MEAN THAT YOU USUALLY THINK
LIKE IN A MISSION AS AN
ADMISSIONS COMMITTEE IT'S VERY
DELIVER IT AND AND SOMEONE
THOUGHT REALLY CAREFULLY OF
ABOUT IT.
I MEAN WHO WHO ACTUALLY DECIDED
BEFORE.
SENSUALLY WAS THE COACH AND IT
WITHOUT A COACH AT WORST THAT
WOULD THAT WERE BRIGHT --
FRAUDULENT MEANS AND SO THIS
WOULD BRING SAM FRANKLY
COMMONSENSE CHECKS AND BALANCES
AND HAVE A SENIOR LEVEL
ADMINISTRATOR HAVE A SECONDARY
SENATE.
YOU WOULD THINK THAT THIS SCAM
WOULD NEVER HAPPEN AGAIN BECAUSE
OF WHAT WAS.
UNCOVERED THIS SPRING BUT YOU
NEVER KNOW SO I THINK IT LOCK IT
IN CALIFORNIA POLICY TO MAKE
SURE WE HAVE -- ADEQUATE
OVERSIGHT AND THIS IS WHAT THIS
IS ALL ABOUT WELL I APPRECIATE I
MEAN I THE FACT THAT AND AGAIN
WE HAVE A LOT OF VERY TALENTED
COACHES ATHLETIC DIRECTORS BUT
THEY WOULD ACTUALLY HAVE.
ESSENTIALLY THE ALMOST SOUL SAY
ON AN ADMISSION OF A STUDENT.
AS THERE'S A LITTLE CONCERNING I
MEAN IT THAT THE THE ACADEMIC
TEAM THE PEOPLE RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE ACADEMIC SHOULD BE THE ONES
MAKING DECISIONS ON ADMISSION
CERTAINLY TEAM TO TAKE CARE OF
LOTS OF DIFFERENT FACTORS BUT
ALSO TO ISSUE RESPONSIBILITY.
TO RIGHT ONE TO ADMIT THE PERSON
THE UNIVERSITY IN THESE ARE
PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES WERE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE STUDENTS AND
SO THE IDEA THAT -- YOU DON'T
HAVE A SENIOR ADMINISTRATOR
SOMEONE WHO HELD TO BASICALLY
SAY WE ARE ACCEPTING
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE EDUCATION
OF TE STUDENT -- IS IS IS --
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT'S FOR AN
EXCEPTION I THINK IS IS
CONCERNING SO CERTAINLY --
STRONG SUPPORT YOUR BILL AND
WOULD MOVE AT THE PROPER TIME.
THANK YOU CENTER PAN ANYONE ELSE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WHICH I TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THE THE
DISCUSSION IT'S REALLY MIND
BLOWING TO THINK THAT AN
INDIVIDUAL COULD APPLY TO MAYBE --
GO TO A SCHOOL AND AND
PARTICIPATE ON THE WATER POLO
TEAM AND THE COACH COULD SIGN
OFF SAYING THIS PERSON'S AN
EXCEPTIONAL WATER POLO PLAYER
AND LITERALLY IS NO VERIFICATION
THAT STUDENT EVEN KNOWS HOW TO
SWIM.
AND SO THIS IS WHAT WE'RE
ATTEMPTING TO ADDRESS IT'S A
COMMON SENSE MEASURE AND ASK THE
RIVAL THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR PAN MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA.
LEYVA I WILL HI WILK I CHIANG
CHIANG I'D WOULD ASAL GLAZER
MCGUIRE PAN PAN HI.
THE MURMUR WILL LEAVE THAT BILL
OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS TO
ADD ON THANK YOU WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
WE ARE IN SENATE ED WE HAVE
THREE AUTHORS THAT WE ARE
LOOKING FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU.
THREE OF US AND LOW
.
WE ARE GOING TO OPEN THE ROLE ON
SOME OF THE BILLS THAT ARE ON
CALL MADAM SECRETARY.
ITEM ONE EIGHTY SIX THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO HUMAN SERVICES
WITH LATE AT THE CHAIR VOTING I
BY SURE VOTING I FOUR ZERO
CHIANG.
CHIANG AYE GLAZER MCGUIRE.
WE BELIEVE THAT BILL ON CALL.
ITEM TEN AB SEVEN FIFTY ONE THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS OF THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE FRAZIER VOTING I FOUR
ZERO GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN.
PAN I BELIEVE THAT BILLING CALLS
WELL.
ITEM FOUR AB ONE NINE SEVEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I
FOUR ZERO GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN.
I AND NUMBER [inaudible]
FOUR CAN I I BELIEVE THAT BILL
OPEN [inaudible]
I AM.
ITEM NUMBER THREE AB FORTY EIGHT
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED THE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING
I FOUR ZERO CHIANG.
CHANGE I GLAZER MCGUIRE.
LEAVE THAT BILL OPEN ARE ON CALL.
ITEM TWELVE AB EIGHT TWENTY NINE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I'D
THREE ZERO TWO ASAL GLAZER
MCGUIRE PAN [inaudible]
CAN I LEAVE THAT OPEN AS WELL
[inaudible] FOURTEEN ITEM
FOURTEEN AB EIGHT NINE SIXTY
THREE THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
ELECTIONS AND CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENTS WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
I VICE CHAIR VOTING I'D THREE
ZERO CHIANG.
CHIANG AYE GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN.
PAN I LEAVE THAT OPEN AS WELL.
ITEM FIFTEEN A. B. NINE SIXTY
SEVEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING NO.
TWO ONE CHIANG.
CHIANG NO GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN
[inaudible]
PAN I'D.
THE VET BILL OPEN AS WELL.
YES.
AND WE HAVE THE CONSENT CALENDAR
[inaudible]
CONSENT CALENDAR.
NO WE'VE ALREADY VOTED ON IT --
CONSENT CALENDAR WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I'VE I SURE VOTING I
THREE ZERO DOCILE GLAZER MCGUIRE
PAN.
PAN I COULD LEAVE THAT OPEN AS
WELL.
YES CENTER PAN.
IF DO YOU MIND IF I JUST MAKE A
BRIEF REMARK ABOUT THE ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT
TWENTY NINE NOT AT ALL.
THAT'S FOR WAITING I SO I DID
THAT FOR THE BILL.
THE I GUESS OUR MARKET WHEN I
MAKE IN THIS IS A MARKET MADE
WITH SIMILAR BILLS -- IS IS THAT
IN THE HEALTH PROFESSIONS AND I
REALIZE THIS IS THIS IS THE
CHALLENGE WE HAVE WHAT HAPPENS
IS THAT THE PROFESSOR
PROFESSIONAL ASSOCIATIONS ARE
ESSENTIALLY.
MOVING UP THE DEGREE STANDARDS.
RIGHT SO NOW WE HAVE A SITUATION
WHERE THE UNIVERSITIES IF
THEY'RE GOING TO GRADUATE PEOPLE
IN THESE FIELDS HAVE BEEN TRAIN
A LONG TIME THEY NOW HAVE TO DO
YOU KNOW MATT.
MASTERS TO DR IT'S RIGHT.
AND SO ON ONE LEVEL AND ARE
STAND WHY THE UNIVERSITIES ARE
HERE SEE ISSUES HERE TO BE
COLLEGES COME HERE AND SAY WE
NEED TO BUILD DO THESE
ADDITIONAL DEGREES -- BECAUSE
THEY'VE TRADITIONALLY DONE THE
TRAINING FOR THOSE HEALTH
PROFESSIONS BUT I AM CONCERNED
ABOUT WHY CALL THIS CREDENTIAL
CREED.
AND WHAT'S US ALSO SAYS YOU THE
CREDENTIAL CREE BY THE WAY IS
WHEN YOU DO IT DR ED ARE YOU DO
A MASTERS WAS FEES A BACHELORS
ARE NOW MASTERS THAT BECOMES A
DOCTORATE.
IT GETS MORE EXPENSIVE THERE'S
MORE BARRIERS NOW TO PEOPLE
ENTERING THOSE FIELDS AS WELL SO
A CERTAINLY I VOTED FOR THIS
BILL I VOTED FOR SOME PREVIOUS
BILLS.
THAT I REALIZE IS A LARGER
CONVERSATION AND IT'S ALSO
INCORPORATES AND IT'S NOT YOU
KNOW WE DON'T HAVE OVERSIGHT
OVER THE INDIVIDUAL PROFESSIONAL
ASSOCIATIONS THAT ARE DRIVING
THIS.
I AM VERY CONCERNED THAT WE HAVE
THIS CREDENTIAL CREEP THAT'S
GOING ON I SEE THIS ALSO MY OWN
FEEL THE MEDICINE.
AND THIS IS CREATING GREATER
BARRIERS TO PEOPLE BOTH ENTERING
THE FIELD THAT INCREASE ACCESS
ISSUES SO I JUST FELT LIKE I HAD
TO SAY SOMETHING ABOUT IT I
WASN'T HERE FOR THE PRESENTATION
BUT I'VE SAID THIS BEFORE SOME
OTHER ONES AND IT IS SOMETHING I
AM CONCERNED ABOUT.
AND THERE'S NEED TO BE A GREATER
CONVERSATION ABOUT IT THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR DALTON'S
MANAGER THANK YOU SENATOR PAN WE
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS.
THOSE ARE JUST THE SO
.
THAT'S MY JOB [inaudible]
YEAH
HOLD YOU OVER THE NEXT WEEK.
NOT BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT TO
HEAR YOUR BILL BUT WE'RE TRYING
TO BE EFFICIENT WITH OUR TME
YOU HAVE ITEM EIGHTEEN AB
THIRTEEN FORTY TWO BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WELCOME
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS -- THIS
IS TO INSURE THAT WE HAVE THE
TYPE OF OVERSIGHT WITH ATTORNEY
GENERAL ON THE SALE AND TRANSFER
OF FOR THESE.
SPECIFIC COLLEGES TO ENSURE THE
TRANSPARENCY AND COUNTY FOR
STUDENTS ON ALL IMPACTED OR
STRICTLY S. RIVAL.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT PLEASE FOR
C. TWO MINUTES EACH.
ACCORDING TO THE BILL.
NOW GET ALL RIGHT ABOVE CHAIRMAN
OF THE CENTURY FUNDATION
SUPPORTING THE BILL -- NONPROFIT
AND FOR PROFIT ENTITIES ARE VERY
DIFFERENT BEASTS AND WHEN THEY
MOVE FROM ONE CATEGORY TO THE
OTHER THERE IS -- A LOT OF
POTENTIAL FOR FUNNY BUSINESS AND
A LOT OF THE PROBLEMS THAT WE'VE
SEEN IN THE FOR PROFIT INDUSTRY --
FOR PROFIT COLLEGE INDUSTRY HAS
BEEN -- COLLEGES THAT HAD BEEN
NONPROFIT -- THOUGHT THAT THEY
WERE -- TOUGH THOUGHT THAT THEY
HAD AT A RESCUE -- FROM A FOR
PROFIT AND IT ENDED UP NOT GOING
SO ELL SO -- THIS BILL WILL
HELP TO PROTECT AND STUDENTS
TAXPAYERS THE PUBLIC IN THOSE
SITUATIONS.
GOOD THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR -- MY NAME IS NATALIE
LINES I'M AN ATTORNEY WITH
HOUSING AND ECONOMIC RIGHTS
ADVOCATES IN OAKLAND WE
REPRESENT.
HUNDREDS OF STUDENT LOAN
BORROWERS ON LEGAL ISSUES AND
OTHER ISSUES THAT THEY ENCOUNTER.
I'M HERE TO SHARE THE STORY OF
BRITNEY GREEN SHE'S A CLIENT OF
OURS YOU CAN BE HERE TO TESTIFY
BECAUSE SHE HAD TO WORK -- I'VE
TRIED TO CUT IT AND MAKE IT AS
EFFICIENT AS POSSIBLE.
MY NAME IS BRITTANY GREEN I
ATTENDED HEALD COLLEGE FROM
JANUARY TWO THOUSAND TEN TO
OCTOBER.
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN I FIRST
HEARD ABOUT HE'LL FROM
TELEVISION COMMERCIALS
COMMERCIALS.
I WANTED TO LEARN MORE ABOUT THE
PARALEGAL PROGRAM.
THE RECRUITER TOLD ME A LOT OF
THINGS THAT DID NOT TURN OUT TO
BE TRUE.
THAT MY SALARY WOULD BE AT LEAST.
FIFTY THOUSAND THAT THE CAREER
OFFICE WOULD FIND A JOB FOR ME.
THAT I WOULD BE ABLE TO TRANSFER
MY CREDITS TO EARN AN A OR A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE AND
SPECIFICALLY THAT I COULD
TRANSFER CREDITS TO CALIFORNIA
STATE.
THE RECORDED AND NOT TELL ME
THAT IT WASN'T THAT THE PROGRAM
WAS NOT APPROVED BY THE AMERICAN
BAR ASSOCIATION
I TOOK OUT FEDERAL LOANS FOR
THIS EDUCATION.
ALSO MY MOM USED MOST OF HER
SAVINGS TO COVER PART OF MY
TUITION.
BUT MY COURSE WORK DID NOT
PREPARE ME TO BE A PARALEGAL ON
JOB INTERVIEWS I WAS ASK
QUESTIONS I COULDN'T ANSWER
ABOUT SPECIFIC PARTS OF THE
PARALEGAL JOB.
AFTER I GRADUATED I SENT MANY
EMAILS TO CAREER SERVICES BUT I
ONLY GOT ONE RESPONSE.
I PLAYED TO ABOUT SEVENTY
PARALEGAL JOBS AND GOT ABOUT
FOUR TO FIVE JOB MANY INTERVIEWS
AND I NEVER GOT HIRED.
THEY WANTED AN ABA APPROVED
CERTIFICATE.
ALSO I APPLIED TO MANY
UNIVERSITIES BUT NOT A SINGLE
ONE WOULD TAKE MY CREDIT
TRANSFER CREDITS.
IS INCLUDED CALIFORNIA STATE.
THE AMOUNT I'VE PAID AND STUDENT
LOANS AN INTEREST FOR A JOKE OF
AN EDUCATION MAKES ME VERY ANGRY.
HEALED WAS SUPPOSED TO BE A
GATEWAY TO MY CAREER INSTEAD IT
WAS NOTHING BUT A SCARLET LETTER
ON MY RESUME.
THAT'S A STATEMENT ON BEHALF OF
HER AND HUNTERS ARE HUNDREDS OF
OTHER CLIENTS WE URGE YOU TO
VOTE HI ON THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU AS AN AWFUL STORY THAT
I HOPE THAT WE DON'T REPEAT HAVE
HER.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
HELLO DANIEL CANADA BECAUSE OUR
BEHALF OF THE CAL A CALIFORNIA
LOW INCOME CONSUMER COALITION WE
ARE COALITION OF A PICKERS
DOZENS OF OF LEGAL AID GROUPS
THAT REPRESENT.
FOLKS ARE SIMILAR TO THE WOMAN
WHO WAS RECENTLY DESCRIBED --
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANGELA PERRY WITH THE INSTITUTE
FOR COLLEGE ACCESS AND SUCCESS
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL IN MRS IN
SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
CNN WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONCERNS.
THANK YOU SIR WHICH IT TO CLOSE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE COMBINATION AGAIN-RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR ABOUT YOUR
QUITE WELCOME THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY CENTER GLAZER MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM EIGHTEEN A. B. THIRTEEN
FORTY TO THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO JUDICIARY LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE WILK NO WILK NO CHANGE
CHANGE -- I'D WOULD ASAL GLAZER
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE PAN -- HOLD
THAT OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBERS THANK
YOU WITNESSES.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHIU PLEASE COME
ON DOWN.
YOU HAVE A FILE ITEM EIGHT AB
SEVEN ELEVEN BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE
READY THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR -- LET ME FIRST START BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITMENTS AND I
WANT TO THANK.
YOUR STAFF AND YOUR WORK WITH
OUR OFFICE.
THIS IS A COMMITTEE THAT KNOWS
FELT FULL WELL THAT TRANSGENDER
NON BINARY STUDENTS FACE MANY
BARRIERS IN SCHOOL IN IN THE
WORKPLACE AND OUR STATE HAS
TAKEN A LOT OF STEPS TO MAKE
SURE.
THE TRANSGENDER STUDENTS WERE
CURRENTLY IN SCORE PROTECTED BUT
THE LAWS BEEN SILENT ON THE
RIGHTS OF FORMER STUDENTS WHO
MAY HAVE TRANSITIONED AFTER
LEAVING SCHOOL.
THE BILL IS SIMPLE IT WOULD
ENSURE THAT TRANSGENDER AND NON
BINARY INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE NO
LONGER IN SCHOOL HAVE THE
ABILITY TO UPDATE OLD DIPLOMA
SET TRANSCRIPTS WERE GDC.
IF THEY DO NOT HAVE AN UPDATED
DIPLOMATIST GROUP THEY CAN FACE
CHALLENGES IN APPLYING FOR
COLLEGE GRADUATE SCHOOL OR
EMPLOYMENT.
THE STATE PARTY REQUIRE SCHOOLS
TO RECOGNIZE -- THESE
INDIVIDUALS NAMES FOR GENDER
CHANGES -- WITH COURT ORDERS AND
TO UPDATE THEIR PERMANENT RECORD --
THIS BILL WOULD SIMPLY CLOSE A
GAP IN THE LAW TO ENSURE THAT
STUDENTS WHO MAY HAVE COME OUT
AFTER LEAVING SCHOOL.
HAVE THE SAME RIGHTS AND
PROTECTIONS AND WITH THAT WANT
TO TURN IT OVER TO TIM MARTIN OF
A QUALITY CALIFORNIA.
THE USER REMEMBER PLEASE PROCEED
IN MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TAMMY MARTIN ON BEHALF
OF EQUALITY CALIFORNIA WHICH FOR
TWENTY YEARS NOW HAS LED THE
GOAL IN THE STATE'S FIGHT FOR
FULL LIVE TO QUALITY OR LGBTQ.
PEOPLE ARE PROUD TO BE HERE
TODAY AS A CO SPONSOR OF AB
SEVEN ONE ONE WHICH WILL ENSURE
THAT FORMER STUDENTS WILL BE
ABLE TO OBTAIN ACADEMIC RECORDS
LIKE DIPLOMAS AND TRANSCRIPTS.
THAT ACCURATELY REFLECT THEIR
LEGAL NAME AND GENDER REGARDLESS
OF WHEN THEY GRADUATED.
WHEN THESE RECORDS DON'T REFLECT
THE CORRECT INFORMATION
TRANSGENDER AND NON BINARY
STUDENTS WHO USE THESE DOCUMENTS
TO APPLY FOR JOBS AND OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES?
ARE PUT AT RISK OF
DISCRIMINATION OR HARM.
AND THIS COMPOUNDS THE SOCIETAL
BARRIERS TO EMPLOYMENT AND
HOUSING AND THAT LGBTQ PEOPLE
ALREADY FACE.
THIS IS A COMMON SENSE BILL THAT
WILL ADDRESS THIS INEQUITY
SAFEGUARD THE PRIVACY OF ALL
GRADUATES INCLUDING TRANSGENDER
AND NON BINARY GRADUATES.
AND ENSURE THAT EDUCATIONAL
RECORDS ARE ACCURATE SO WE ARE
GRATEFUL TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU
FOR OFFERING THIS BILL AND
RESPECTFULLY URGE THE COMMITTEE
TO SUPPORT IT TODAY AS WELL
THANK YOU THANK YOU ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS IN SUPPORT.
VIDEO BORN CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
NURSES AND SUPPORT.
AMANDA DOOR COMING OFF OF EXCUSE
ME A SO YOU OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
IN SUPPORT IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED TO SEVEN
MORE WHICH I TO CLOSE WE SHARE
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU THE BILL
HAS BEEN MOVED BY CENTER CHIANG
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ITEM EIGHT EIGHTY SEVEN ELEVEN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA AYE
LEYVA AYE WILK.
WILK AYE CHANGE CHIANG I'D WITH
US ALL.
GLAZER GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE PAN.
I BELIEVE THAT BILL ON CALL FOR
MEMBERS TO ADD ON THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT WE'RE GOING TO LIFT
CALLS FOR SENATOR GLAZER TO ADD
ON PLEASE PROCEED ITEM ONE AB
SIX THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
HUMAN SERVICES WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I'VE.
FIVE ZERO GLAZER GLAZER AYE
MCGUIRE.
I BELIEVE THAT BILL ON CALL.
ITEM THREE AB FORTY EIGHT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE OF THE CHAIR VOTING
I'VE I SURE VOTING AYE FIVE ZERO
GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE.
WITH A BILL ON CALL.
ITEM FOUR AB ONE NINE SEVEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I'VE VICE CHAIR VOTING
AYE FIVE ZERO GLAZER.
PLEASE ARE AYE MCGUIRE.
LEAVE THAT PHONE CALL.
ITEM SIX AB THREE OH TO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
JUDICIARY WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
I'VE I SURE VOTING I'VE FIVE
ZERO GLAZER.
PLEASE ARE AYE MCGUIRE.
THE THAT BELONG CALL ITEM SEVEN
AB FIVE TWENTY ONE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS THE PUBLIC SAFETY WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I VICE CHAIR
VOTING I FIVE ZERO GLAZER.
PLEASE ARE AYE MCGUIRE.
WITH THAT BILL ON CALL.
ITEM EIGHT AB SEVEN ELEVEN THE
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS OF THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I'VE
FOUR ZERO TWO ASAL MCGUIRE.
PAN.
THE BILL OPEN.
ITEM NINE AB SEVEN TWENTY THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I
FOUR ZERO LIEU DOCILE GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE.
THAT BILL ON CALL.
ITEM TEN AB SEVEN FIFTY ONE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I ADVISED HER VOTING AYE
FIVE ZERO GLAZER.
GLAZER NO MCGUIRE.
WITH THAT ON CALL.
ITEM ELEVEN AB SEVEN SEVEN THREE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO ELECTIONS AND CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENTS WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
I'VE I SURE VOTING I FIVE ZERO
GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE THE BATTLE ON
CALL.
ITEM TWELVE AB EIGHT TWENTY NINE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I'VE
FOUR ZERO LASSELL GLAZER.
PLEASE ARE AYE MCGUIRE.
BELIEVE THAT BILL OPEN ON CALL
OKAY ITEM FOURTEEN EIGHTY NINE
SIXTY THREE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO ELECTIONS AND
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I'VE I SURE
VOTING I'VE.
FOUR ZERO GLAZER GLAZER AYE
MCGUIRE.
I BELIEVE THAT BILL ON CALL ITEM
FIFTEEN EIGHTY NINE SIXTY SEVEN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING NO.
THREE ONE GLAZER GLAZER NO
MCGUIRE.
THE THAT THE LONG CALL.
ITEM -- SEVENTY ITEM EIGHTEEN AB
THIRTEEN FORTY TO THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO JUDICIARY WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING
NO.
THREE ONE EDU ASAL GLAZER
MCGUIRE PAN.
YES YOU ARE.
I'M SORRY GLAZERS RIGHT YES YOUR
ITEM NINETEEN EIGHTY THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I'VE VICE CHAIR.
VOTING I'D FOUR ZERO TWO DOCILE
GLAZER GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE
[inaudible]
WE HAVE.
DO THE CONSENT CALENDAR AND THEN
YOUR NEXT TO HIS RIVAS COME ON
UP CONSENT CALENDAR WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING
I'VE FOUR ZERO TWO DOCILE GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE.
VERY GOOD WITH THE CONSENT COUNT
OPEN WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RIVAS YOU HAVE FILE ITEM
SEVENTEEN AB THIRTEEN THIRTEEN
BEGIN WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU -- MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M PROUD TO PRESENT AB
THIRTEEN THIRTEEN WHICH SIX
TWENTY SURE THAT A STUDENT'S
FUTURE IS NOT HELD HOSTAGE BY
COLLEGES.
THIS BILL PROHIBITS POST
SECONDARY SCHOOLS FROM REFUSING
TO PROVIDE A TRANSCRIPT IN ORDER
TO COLLECT A DEBT -- COLLEGE
TRANSCRIPTS ARE CRITICAL
DOCUMENTS THEY GIVE STUDENTS
MOBILITY -- TO PURSER HIGHER
EDUCATION A PROFESSIONAL LICENSE
AND EMPLOYMENT.
OF CURRENT STATE LAW AND
EDUCATIONAL POLICY ALLOW SCHOOLS
TO WITHHOLD TRANSCRIPTS IN ORDER
TO COLLECT A DEBT.
OF SCHOOLS ARE PUTTING STUDENTS
IN A PREDICAMENT WHERE THEY ARE
UNABLE TO ADVANCE THEIR CAREERS
AND GET TO A PLACE WHERE THEY
CAN ACTUALLY PAY OFF THIS DEBT.
OUR NATIONAL STUDENT LOAN DEBT
EXCEEDS ONE POINT FIVE TRILLION
DOLLARS TODAY THIS AMOUNT
EXCEEDS ALL OUTSTANDING CREDIT
CARD DEBT IN OUR COUNTRY.
AND SAY INSTEAD OF MAKING IT
MORE DIFFICULT -- WE SHOULD BE
DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
REDUCE THE BURDEN OF PAIN THESE
DEBTS OFF -- SO TO FURTHER SPEAK
ON THIS BILL I HAVE A FEW
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ON BEHALF OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE WHICH IS THE SPONSOR OF
THIS BILL I'M HAPPY TO INTRODUCE
MARTIN -- READ DOSE WHICH SORRY.
AND BERNARD -- IS CAN DARI.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY WOMAN
GENTLEMEN WELCOME TWO MINUTES
EACH [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF MARTIN
RIAZ WHICH WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S PROUD TO SPONSOR A. B.
THIRTEEN THIRTEEN WHICH
RESTRICTS POST SECONDARY SCHOOLS
FROM THE PRACTICE OF WITHHOLDING.
A STUDENT TRANSCRIPTS AS A MEANS
FOR DEBT COLLECTION WE ALSO WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
INTRODUCING THIS BILL I HAVE
BARNEY ASKING DOREY HE'S A
SUPERVISING DEPUTY ATTORNEY
GENERAL THEIR CONSUMER LAW
SECTION WITH ME.
WHO CAN DISCUSS THE NEED FOR THE
BILL IN MORE DETAIL AND ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE?
THANK YOU PLEASE PROCEED THANK
YOU -- GOOD AFTERNOON NOW -- MY
NAME IS BERNARD ASKING DARI
BARNEY I'M SUPERVISING DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
ON THE TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
ECONOMIC POTENTIAL IS LOCKED UP
IN A STUDENTS COLLEGE TRANSCRIPT.
TRANSCRIPTS ARE OFTEN THE
CRITICAL DOCUMENT NECESSARY FOR
SOMEONE TO TRANSFER TO ANOTHER
SCHOOL TO OBTAIN A PROFESSIONAL
LICENSE OR EVEN TO GET A JOB.
BECAUSE THESE DOCUMENTS ARE SO
IMPORTANT TO STUDENTS LIVELIHOOD
THE ALSO MAKE A POTENT DEBT
COLLECTION TOOL A PRACTICE THAT
SOME OF CALLED TRANSCRIPT
EXTORTION.
WE SAW THIS FIRST HAND IN THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S PROSECUTION
INVESTIGATION OF CORINTHIAN
COLLEGES WHICH WENT OUT OF
BUSINESS SHORTLY AFTER WE SUED
THEM.
CLINTON IS CONSIDERED AMONG THE
WORST OF THE WORST A PREDATORY
SCHOOLS DEFRAUDING STUDENTS AT
EVERY TURN -- TWENTY IN STRONG
ARMS STUDENTS INTO PAYING BACK
THAT'S WITH A NUMBER OF A PRESS
OF TACTICS -- THIS INCLUDED FOR
EXAMPLE PULLING STUDENTS OUT OF
CLASS TO BERATE THEM IN THE
MIDDLE -- DURING INSTRUCTION IT
ALSO INCLUDED WITHHOLDING
TRANSCRIPTS TO PREVENT STUDENTS
FROM FLEEING CORINTHIAN TO
CONTINUE THEIR EDUCATION AND
MORE LEGITIMATE INSTITUTIONS ARE
ACTUALLY LEGITIMATE INSTITUTIONS.
OUR EXPERIENCE INVESTIGATING AND
PROSECUTING FOR PROFIT SCHOOLS
IS WHAT PROMPTED THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO SPONSOR THIS BILL.
UNFORTUNATELY THE STRONG ARM
TACTICS ARE NOT CONFINED JUST A
PREDATORY SCHOOLS LEGITIMATE
INSTITUTIONS ROUTINELY WITH
WHOLE TRANSCRIPTS AS WELL.
WITHHOLDING TRANSCRIPTS
INTERFERES WITH STUDENT CHOICE
INTERFERES WITH STUDENT MOBILITY
AND THEREFORE IT HARMS
COMPETITION AMONG SCHOOLS.
IT DOES SO IN A WAY THAT
THREATENS THE LIVELIHOOD OF
STUDENTS BY BLOCKING FURTHER
EDUCATION LICENSURE AND
PLACEMENT.
THE VERY THINGS WOULD ALLOW
STUDENTS TO SUCCEED AND MAKE
ENOUGH MONEY TO PAY BACK THEIR
DEBTS.
WHICH IS WHY THIS BILL IS SO
IMPORTANT SCHOOLS ALREADY HAVE
ALL THE DATA COLLECTION TOOLS
THAT ON SECURED CREDITORS HAVE.
IN OUR EXPERIENCE THE PRACTICE
OF SCHOOLS WITHHOLDING
TRANSCRIPTS IT'S SIMPLY TOO BIG
OF AN ADDITIONAL HAMMER.
THANK YOU AND I'M HAPPY
ANSWERING QUESTIONS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
THE MANAGER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNICABLE JUST CHANCES OFFICE
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
WELCOME TO YOU EACH HAVE TWO
MINUTES ALL EVEN DECIDE WHO GOES
FIRST.
THANK YOU COMMITTEE -- IN
MEMBERS MY NAME'S TYLER I YOU
ARE SEEKING ON BEHALF OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
IS ONE OF THE BIG KNOWLEDGE AND
THANK THE AUTHOR IN THE SPONSOR
WE DEFINITELY UNDERSTAND --
WHERE THEY'RE COMING FROM WITH
THIS ISSUE WE WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE IS A AMOUNT TEEN STUDENT
DEBT CRISIS THAT EXISTS IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE UNITED STATES?
AND WE WILL CONTINUE OUR WORK TO
PRIORITIZE THAT AFFORDABILITY
ACCESS THAT WE PROVIDE TO YOU
SEE WE ALSO SHARE THE AUTHOR'S
INTEREST IN PROTECTING.
STUDENTS AND CONTROLLING DEBT
COLLECTION ABUSES BY -- SOME OF
THE BAD ACTORS THAT WE HAD HEARD --
IN THE TESTIMONY THE PRACTICE OF
WITHHOLDING TRANSCRIPTS THAT YOU
SEE FOR DELINQUENT ACCOUNTS IS A
FAIRLY COMMON -- TOOL THAT WE
USE TO US -- RECOUP OUTSTANDING
FINES -- TO THE UNIVERSITY.
THIS IS THE TOOLS.
BUT I CAMPUS IS PRIMARY LEVERAGE
YOUR DISTANCE INTO A
CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW THEY CAN
PAY BACK THE DEBT THEY OWE --
WITH THEIR DUE DILIGENCE AND
SURVEYED ALL OF OUR CAMPUS
REGISTRARS WE JUST ASK THAT WHAT
EXACTLY HAPPENS WHEN A STUDENT
IS TRYING TO ACCESS.
A TRANSCRIPT AND THEY OWE A DEBT
TO THE UNIVERSITY ALL OF OUR
CAMPUSES.
ALL OF THEM WILL WORK WITH A
STUDENT WHO IS TRYING TO ATTAIN
A TRANSCRIPT FOR ACADEMIC OR
WORK RELATED PURPOSES.
SOME EXAMPLES FOR EXAMPLE --
WHEN CAMPUS WILL DO -- ONE TIME
RELEASE -- IF THEY GIVE THE
EMAIL OF THE EMPLOYER HAD ALSO
DIRECTED EMPLOYER OTHER CAMPUSES
LET'S SAY THE AMOUNT IS TWO
FIFTY THE REQUIRED A TWENTY FIVE
DOLLAR DOWN PAYMENT AND I'LL TRY
TO FIGURE OUT A REASONABLE.
PAYMENT PLAN GOING FORWARD SO
THE THE GOAL HERE IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE NOT BURNING THE
STUDENT OR PROHIBITING THEM FROM --
MEETING WITH THEIR EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES OF THEIR
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES.
THAT IS NOT OUR GOAL OUR CAMPUS
REGISTRARS HAVE EXTREME
FLEXIBILITY TO TREAT STUDENTS IN
A CASE BY CASE BASIS OF
SOMEBODY'S COMING HERE AND THEY
SAY YOU KNOW WE NEED.
THIS TRANSCRIPT MUCH DRIVING JOB
OFFER FOR FIFTY GRAND I CAN PAY
BACK THE AMOUNT AND THREE MONTHS
GREAT LET'S FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO
IT.
IN NO WAY WOULD WE PULL ANY
STUDENTS OUT OF CLASS OR BE RATE
THEM PUBLICLY OR WHATEVER MAY
HAVE YOU -- WE WANT TO WORK WITH
STUDENTS SO -- WE JUST ASK THAT
WE CONTINUE.
TO COLLECT DEBTS IN THIS METHOD
WE THINK IT'S A BETTER OPTION
THAN WHAT WE WOULD HAVE TO DO IS
ACTUALLY SENDING THEM TO A THIRD
PARTY COLLECTIONS AGENCY WHICH
WE DO NOT WANT TO DEAL.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON I THINK IT IS NOW --
ALEX GRAYS OF THE ASSOCIATION
INDEPENDENT CALIFORNIA COLLEGES
UNIVERSITIES REPRESENTING EIGHTY
FOUR PRIVATE INDEPENDENT NOT FOR
PROFIT INSTITUTIONS THROUGHOUT
OUR STATE.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK THE AUTHORS
OFFICE AND THEIR STAFF I THINK
WE'VE HAD THREE MEETINGS TO
DISCUSS THIS BILL AND I
APPRECIATE THE TIME AND AND
THOUGHTFULNESS -- WE IS OUR
WATER INDICATES HAVING OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION I THINK
SIMILAR TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM YOU
SEE WE FULLY SUPPORT THE
IMPORTANCE OF YOU KNOW STUDENTS
GETTING THEIR DEGREE.
AND INTO THE WORK FORCE IN A
TIMELY MANNER I WITH THIS LITTLE
AS POSSIBLE -- YOU KNOW WE HAVE
A TWO THIRDS ARE CAL GRANT
STUDENTS GRADUATE IN FOUR YEARS --
WE HAVE VERY LOW DEFAULT RATES --
ON STUDENTS WHO DO TAKE OUT
LOANS -- AND ON AVERAGE OUR
SYSTEM OR PROVIDING ABOUT
NINETEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
INSTITUTIONAL GRANT AID TO TO
OUR CAL GRANT STUDENTS -- ARE
UNDERSTAND IS CONCERNED -- THIS
ISSUE STEMS FROM SOME PRETTY
AGGRESSIVE TACTICS EMPLOYED BY
SOME OF THE FOR PROFIT ENTITIES --
IN COLLECTING THESE DEBTS -- YOU
KNOW WE BELIEVE THAT WE
FUNDAMENTALLY AS NON PROFITS
HAVE A DIFFERENT -- MISSION AN
INCENTIVE IN EDUCATING STUDENTS
OUR MISSION IS TO EDUCATE THOSE
STUDENTS AND GET THEM DEGREES
IT'S NOT TO MAKE MONEY OFF OF
THEM -- YOU KNOW WE I WASN'T
ABLE IS A DECENTRALIZED SYSTEM
TO GET AN INPUT FROM ALL EIGHTY
FOUR OF OUR SCHOOLS BUT I DID
CONNECT ABOUT A DOZEN AND ACROSS
THE BOARD DATE -- SOMEBODY C.
TALKED ABOUT VARIOUS FORMS OF
LENIENCY -- WITH OTHER TACTICS --
IS EXCUSE ME MECHANISMS THEY
HAVE AT THEIR AVAILABILITY IN
RECOGNITION OF THE FACT THEY
WANT STUDENTS TO PROGRESS TOWARD
THEIR DEGREE.
SCHOOLS -- TALKED ABOUT THE FACT
THAT THEY DON'T WITHHOLD
REGISTRATION PRIVILEGES FOR
STUDENTS WHO -- DEBT BECAUSE
THEY RECOGNIZE YOU WANT THEM TO
CONTINUE ON THE PATH TO THEIR
DEGREE AND THEY CAN WORK WITH
THEM IS ARE MOVING THROUGH THE
SYSTEM TO WORK OUT ANY BAD.
PAYMENT OF DEBT THEY THEY YOU
KNOW ALSO MIGHT.
NOT WITHHOLD ANY REGISTRATION OR
WHAT HAVE YOU IF THE DEBT IS
UNDER A HUNDRED DOLLARS -- THEY
ALSO SOME SCHOOLS MENTION THAT
THEY DON'T WITHHOLD THE
CONFERRAL OF DEGREES WHICH IS
ANOTHER ECHANISM AVAILABLE TO
SCHOOLS FOR DEBT COLLECTION --
AND A NUMBER OF THEM YOU KNOW
TALKED ABOUT VARIOUS
COMMUNICATION METHODS OKAY I'LL
SKIP TO THE END I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT -- FOR COLLECTIONS ON THE
BACK AND THE CHALLENGE FOR OUR
SCHOOLS ESPECIALLY IS NOT FOR
PROFITS IS -- WE LOSE 3550% OF
THAT AMOUNT THROUGH THE NATURE
HOW COLLECTIONS ARE ARE PAID --
AND SO GIVEN THAT OUR SCHOOLS
THAT WE SURVEYED HAVE BETWEEN
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND AND AND
UPWARDS OF FIVE TO EIGHTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN UNPAID DEBT
THAT'S SIGNIFICANT -- POTENTIAL
COST TO OUR SCHOOLS AND TRYING
TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE REAL BY
STATE SUPPORT FOR STUDENTS OF
THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION SEEING
THAT WILL BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONCERNS [inaudible]
CENTER GLAZER.
BUT I WANTED TO INVITE THE
AUTHOR TO RESPOND TO THE SOME OF
THE CONCERNS HAVE BEEN RAISED IN
WHETHER OR NOT YOU SAW ANY
REASON TO DIFFERENTIATE -- AND
HOW YOUR BILL FAIL BUT COLLEGES
YOUR BILL WOULD APPLY -- TO SURE
OF YOU KNOW SO -- YOU KNOW THE
APPROACH TAT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ARE TAKEN ARE TAKING IT
REINFORCES THEIR MISSION RIGHT --
TO SUPPORT STUDENTS TO EDUCATE
STUDENTS SO I WAS EXCITED TO SEE
THAT THEY ARE SUPPORTING -- MY
BILL -- I JUST RECEIVED THE
LETTER FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA YESTERDAY -- AND YOU
KNOW THE FIRST THING -- THAT I
DID WAS LOOK AT THEIR MISSION
I'M YOU KNOW WHEN I WAS GROWING
UP YOU KNOW THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTED.
ON ACCESS TO ANYONE TO THOSE OF
US THE GROUP IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES -- TO EDUCATION AND
YOU KNOW I ALSO -- SAW STUDY
YESTERDAY THAT YOU KNOW STUDENTS
OF COLOR IN LOW INCOME GRADUATES
ARE THREE TIMES MORE LIKELY TO
TAKE ON STUDENT LOAN DEBT.
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS -- AND SO -- YOU KNOW IT
DISAPPOINTED ME ARM TO SEE THE
OPPOSITION -- I UNDERSTAND THAT
THEY IN THEIR USING THIS
TRANSCRIPT AS LEVERAGE BUT I
THINK I LIKE WHAT THEY SAY IN
THEIR LETTER IS THEY'RE USING
THE TRANSCRIPT. TO START A CALM
THE LEVERAGING OF THE TRANSCRIPT
TO START THE CONVERSATION I
THINK THERE ARE MANY WAYS AS
EDUCATORS I'M TO START A
CONVERSATION WITH STUDENTS --
THAT ARE HAVING TROUBLE PAYING
THEIR DEBT -- I THINK -- YOU
KNOW STUDENTS ARE YOU NEED THE
OFFICIAL TRANSCRIPTS TO APPLY
FOR SAY MEDICAL SCHOOL GRADUATE
SCHOOL PROTECT POTENTIALLY JOBS
AND THIS IS A LOT OF TIMES
BEFORE THEY HAVE FINISHED THEIR
DEGREE.
YOU KNOW AS YOU KNOW GRADUATE
SCHOOL APPLICATIONS ARE DUE
JANUARY FIRST -- AND IF WE ARE
WITH HOLDING THESE TRANSCRIPTS --
WERE NOT ALLOWING THEM -- TO
MOVE FURTHER IN THEIR EDUCATION
OR IN THEIR CAREER -- I THINK
THE YOU KNOW FINANCIAL LITERACY
IS IMPORTANT THAT SOMETHING THAT
THE UNIVERSITIES -- CAN WORK
WITH STUDENTS MAY BE REQUIRED
THEM TO GO TO WORKSHOPS -- THAT
WILL HELP THEM WITH THE STATE
AND PAYMENT PLAN I DON'T THINK
THAT THE TRANSCRIPTS LEVERAGING
IS THE ONLY WAY TO HAVE A COME
STATION WITH STUDENTS.
WELL I I HAVE TO THE CHAIR I I
CERTAINLY -- SUPPORT THE
INTENTIONS OF YOUR BILL I MEAN --
A STUDENT THAT HAS GONE THROUGH
SUCH EFFORTS AND TO AND TO HAVE
THIS.
PIECE OF PAPER WHICH IS SO
CRITICAL BE HELD WITH TELL THIS
IS A TRAGEDY AND SO I YOU AND
AND IN GENERAL TERMS I AGREE
WITH WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH THAT.
IS OBVIOUSLY -- YOU KNOW IMPACT.
IF YOU BELIEVE WHAT THE INS
THESE INSTITUTIONS ARE SAYING.
AT THE UC AND THEIR LETTER SAYS
IT WILL COST THEM. TEN TO TWELVE
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
AND THAT THERE'S NO FREE LUNCH
OUT THERE RIGHT AND WE WOULDN'T
WANT TO SEE THEM RAISE TUITION.
AS AN EXAMPLE IS AN EXTREME
EXAMPLE.
IF THEY'RE NOT GETTING THE
FUNDING THEY NEED TO TO PAY THE
BILLS THEN WE HAVE TO FIND THE
MONEY IN SOME OTHER WAY AND THAT
PROBABLY APPLIES ACROSS THE
BOARD SO -- IT'S IT'S A
CHALLENGE TO HOW TO WEAVE AS THE
GOOD GOALS THAT YOU'RE ADVANCE
YOU KNOW YOU'RE PROPOSING AND
THE BILL.
IT RECOGNIZE THAT IF YOU'RE
GONNA TAKE THIS TOOL WAY.
YOU KNOW WHAT OTHER WHAT OTHER
CHOICES REALLY ARE THERE AND WE
HAVE TO ON THOSE CHOICES TO
WRITE.
IF YOU WANT TO SEND IT TO A DEBT
COLLECTION AND WE HAVE NOW
CREDIT ISSUE ON THAT PERSON'S --
NAME. FOR EIGHT YEARS INTO THE
FUTURE THAT'S A CONSEQUENCE
RIGHT AND YOU KNOW YOU DON'T
WANT THAT EITHER.
I I DON'T WANT IT I'M SURE YOU
DON'T WANT IT EITHER SO.
I'M JUST TRYING TO UNDERSTAND.
HOW WE CAN ADVANCE YOUR COULD
GOALS WITH THE WITH THE
LEGITIMATE CONCERNS THAT ARE
BEING RAISED -- YOU KNOW WE HAVE
ASKED IN CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
UNIVERSITIES WE HAVE ASKED THAT
QUESTION WHAT OTHER TOOLS.
ARE THERE BESIDES THIS SOMETHING
THAT WILL -- YOU KNOW.
PREVENT -- STUDENTS FROM THEIR
FUTURE JOBS WHICH WILL HELP THEM
PAY THE STAT OFF -- AND I
HAVEN'T RECEIVED RESPONSES -- IN
IN WORKING THROUGH THIS BILL AND
THIS BILL DOESN'T PROHIBIT
UNIVERSITIES FROM COLLECTING
THAT.
IT JUST PROHIBITS THEM FROM
USING THE TRANSCRIPT -- TO
COLLECT THE DEBT ONE LAST
QUESTION THAT I'M SURE IF I
COULD PLEASE THE ANY GIVEN ANY
THOUGHT TO THE TO ANY KIND OF
DIFFERENTIAL IF THE DEBT IS
UNDER THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS.
IF THE DAD IS OUTSTANDING FOR
MORE THAN. TWO YEARS IF.
IS THERE ANYTHING THAT CAN
CREATE SOME.
PLACES FOR THE INSTITUTIONS TO
WORK AND TRY TO DEAL WITH THE
EGREGIOUS EXAMPLES -- ANY
THOUGHTS TO TRYING TO FIND A WAY
TO NARROW -- TAKE WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO TO DO BUT NOT GETTING
IN THE WAY OF OF THEM TRYING.
TO PAY THE BILLS RIGHT THAT KEEP
THE LIGHTS ON ARE YOU KNOW I'VE
THOUGHT OF THE RIGHT FEEL LIKE
AN A PARTICULAR MON IT'S HARD TO
DETERMINE RIGHT NOW THE
UNIVERSITIES.
DON'T COLLECT DATA ON YOU KNOW
HOW MANY -- OUTSTANDING DEBTS
THEY'RE USING -- I'VE ASKED FOR
IT AND I HAVEN'T RECEIVED THAT --
IN I DON'T KNOW WHERE THE
NUMBERS ARE COMING FROM THE TEN
TO TWELVE MILLION I MEAN IN THE
SAME HEARING WE'RE HEARING ABOUT
STUDENT HOMELESSNESS -- STUDENT
HUNGER -- IN EITHER OTHER ISSUES
THAT ARE ARE LEGISLATOR
CURRENTLY IS TACKLING ON AND WE
WE EVEN IN OUR CURRENT STATE
BUDGET WE ALLOCATED FUNDS -- FOR
COLLEGES TO DEAL WITH HUNGER AND
HOMELESSNESS RATE -- SOMETHING
THAT THEY HAVE REQUESTED AND YOU
KNOW WE REALLY BELIEVE IN THOSE
ISSUES AND WE'RE HELPING THEM
BUT AT THE SAME TIME -- I THINK
THIS IS OF IT'LL LOOK YOU KNOW
YOU ALSO.
PUTTING STUDENTS MORE MORE IN --
IN.
IN A PREDICAMENT WHERE THEY
CAN'T MOVE ON EITHER TRANCE FOR
TRANSFER OR YOU KNOW.
GO TO GRADUATE SCHOOL OR A
CAREER -- I JUST DON'T SEE HOW
THE SAME UNIVERSITIES ARE.
ASKING US FOR FUNDS -- TO DEAL%
WITH HUNGER AND HOMELESSNESS BUT
THEN YET ARE ALSO PART OF THE
PROBLEM.
ENTER MY OWN TIME THEN LIKE IT'S
SOME UP YOU CAN BE ON ANYBODY'S
TIME GO AHEAD [inaudible]
THANK YOU -- WELL FIRST I I DO
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THE BILL FORD AND I'M
THAT SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY BUT
I I WOULD ASK YOU TO TO TAKE A
CLOSER LOOK AT WAYS IN WHICH YOU
CAN NARROW IT WHICH IS NEVER AN
EASY THING.
BUT TO TRY TO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
THAT THESE INSTITUTIONS
CERTAINLY THE NON PROFITS AND
OUR PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS ARE NOT.
TRYING TO BE MEAN BUT THEY ARE
TRYING TO PAY THE BILLS AND AND
AND THERE'S A BALANCING ACT HERE
WHICH I KNOW YOU'RE TRYING TO
FIND THAT SPACE.
FOR I HOPE THAT YOU'LL WORK WITH
THEM -- AS IF YOUR BILL GOES
FORWARD TODAY TO TRY TO SEE IF
YOU CAN FIGURE THAT OUT AND
NARROW IT.
AND FINALLY I'M HAPPY TO SEE THE
OFFICE OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
HERE ON THIS BILL -- YOU KNOW
THERE'S ABOUT SIX OTHER.
A FOR PROFIT BILLS THAT ARE HERE
IN THE SENATE RIGHT NOW.
AND I IS THE CHAIR OF A
COMMITTEE THIS CAN HEAR SIX OF
THEM -- THE NEXT WEEK OR SO I
WOULD REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
INPUT ON THOSE AS WELL.
DOES NOT TO BE IN A SPONSORSHIP
ROLE BUT YOUR ADVICE AND
EXPERTISE AND HOW WE DEAL WITH
THE PROBLEMS THAT WE ARE SEEING.
WITH HIS FOR PROFIT INSTITUTIONS
AND I THINK WOULD BENEFIT FROM
YOUR INPUT AS WE AS WE ARE.
WITH YOUR SPONSORSHIP OF THIS
BILL TODAY THANK YOU VENTURE THE
CENTER GLAZER ASSEMBLY WOMAN
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU -- YOU KNOW THERE I
THINK.
LIKE I MENTIONED BEFORE -- THIS
BILL IS NOT PROHIBITING
UNIVERSITIES FROM COLLECTING
THAT IT'S JUST THE USE OF THE
TRANSCRIPT TO LEVERAGE LIKE AS
THEY SAY TO START THE
CONVERSATION.
I FEEL THERE ARE MANY WAYS -- AS
EDUCATORS TO START A
CONVERSATION WITH STUDENTS ON
THESE ISSUES THESE ARE STUDENTS --
THAT ARE STILL DEVELOPING YOU
KNOW I THINK STERN DEVELOPMENT
ON THEIR YOUNG -- FIRST TIME OUT
IN THE REAL WORLD FOR A LOT OF
THEM -- THAT I THINK WE HAD WE
NEED TO GO BACK TO THE MISSION
OF THE UNIVERSITIES AND THINK
HOW.
AND SEE THIS AS AN EDUCATIONAL
AND TEACHABLE MOMENT -- YOU KNOW --
I APPRECIATE -- THAT THE UC'S
ARE WORKING WITH MY OFFICE AND
THE A I CC YOU THE NONPROFIT
UNIVERSITIES AND I WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THEM -- ON THIS
BILL -- HOWEVER I BELIEVE THAT
YOU KNOW SCHOOL SHOULD BE
FOCUSING HAN HOW TO BEST SERVE
OUR STUDENTS -- AND YOU KNOW
LAST YEAR THERE WAS A BILL IN
THE LEGISLATURE -- THAT WAS
SIMILAR BUT WITH THE K. THROUGH
TWELVE SYSTEM -- YOU KNOW ALL
SCHOOL K. THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOLS
WERE ALSO USING TRANSCRIPTS TO
LEVERAGE -- IT'LL AND IN TO USE
AGAINST FOR COLLECTING --
STUDENT DEBT -- I THINK WE NEED
TO MOVE AWAY FROM THESE PUNITIVE
PRACTICES -- AND INSTEAD --
EDUCATE OUR AND SO ON AB
THIRTEEN THIRTEEN MAINTAINS A
SCHOOL AND YOU KNOW MAKE
ELEVATES AT HIGHER EDUCATION.
IN OUR STATE -- THERE'S NOT A
NUMBER OF TOOLS TO ADDRESS
OUTSTANDING DEBT BUT I BELIEVE
WE NEED TO EVOLVE AND HOW WE
APPROACH ON COLLECTING THE STAT
IN.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS
MEASURE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY WOMAN DO WE
HAVE A MOTION.
THANK YOU.
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
CENTER CHIANG MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ITEM
SEVENTEEN AB THIRTEEN THIRTEEN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
JUDICIARY LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE WILK CHANG CHANG I'D
RUSSELL GLAZER.
PLEASE ARE AYE MCGUIRE PAN.
I BELIEVE THAT BILL ON CALL AND
GET SOME MORE MEMBERS HERE TO
VOTE THANK YOU ASSEMBLY WOMAN.
SENATOR REQUIRE WE ARE LOOKING
FOR YOU.
CENTER PAN WE HAVE I THINK JUST
A COUPLE BILLS SO WE'RE GONNA
OPEN THOSE FOR YOU TO VOTE ON
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON THOSE BILLS.
I AM SEVENTEEN AB THIRTEEN
THIRTEEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO JUDICIARY WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I ADVISED HER NOT VOTING.
THE WOOD ASAL MCGUIRE PAN.
HI CAN I BELIEVE THAT BILL ON
CALL THANK YOU SENATOR.
ITEM EIGHTEEN AB THIRTEEN FORTY
TO THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
JUDICIARY WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
I VICE CHAIR VOTING NO -- THREE
TO ONE ASAL MCGUIRE PAN.
HI CAN I VERY GOOD BUT WILL THE
THE BILL ON CALLS WELL CENTER
PAN THOSE ARE ALL THE BILLS THAT
YOU NEED TO ADD ON TO THANK YOU
SO MUCH [inaudible]
OKAY.
OKAY ITEM EIGHT AB SEVEN ELEVEN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I
FOUR ZERO THOUGH DOCILE MCGUIRE
PAN.
THANK YOU CENTER PAN
THE ROLE ON
OUR BILLS THAT ARE STILL OPEN
ITEM ONE EIGHTY SIX THE MOTION
IS TO PASS HUMAN SERVICES WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I BY SURE
VOTING I SIX ZERO MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE HI SEVEN ZERO THAT BILLS
OUT.
ITEM THREE AB FORTY EIGHT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I'VE I SURE VOTING I SIX
ZERO MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE SEVEN ZERO THAT
BILLS OUT.
ITEM FOR AB ONE NINE SEVEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I'VE I SURE VOTING I SIX
ZERO MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE SEVEN ZERO THAT
VOTERS THAT BILLS OUT.
ITEM SIX AB THREE OH TO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
JUDICIARY WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
I'VE I SURE VOTING I SIX ZERO
MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE HI SEVEN ZERO THAT BILLS
OUT.
ITEM SEVEN AB FIVE TWENTY ONE
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED PUBLIC
SAFETY WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I
VICE CHAIR VOTING I SIX ZERO
MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE SEVEN ZERO THAT
VOTERS OUT BILLS OUT.
ITEM EIGHT AB SEVEN ELEVEN THE
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I'VE I SURE VOTING AYE
FIVE ZERO DO DOCILE MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE SIX ZERO THAT WILL
BILL IS OUT.
ITEM NINE EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I
FIVE ZERO BLAST ALL MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE SIX ZERO THAT BILLS
OUT.
ITEM TEN A. B. SEVEN FIFTY ONE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I'VE I SURE VOTING I FIVE
ONE MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE. SIX ONE THAT BILLS
OUT.
ITEM ELEVEN AB SEVEN SEVEN THREE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO ELECTIONS AND CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
I'VE I SURE VOTING I SIX ZERO
MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE SEVEN ZERO THAT
BILLS OUT.
ITEM TWELVE AB EIGHT TWENTY NINE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I'VE I SURE VOTING I FIVE
ZERO TWO LASSELL MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE SIX ZERO THAT BILLS
OUT.
ITEM FOURTEEN AB NINE SIXTY
THREE THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
ELECTIONS AND CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT TO THE CHAIR VOTING
I'VE I SURE VOTING I SIX ZERO
MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE SEVEN ZERO THAT
BILLS OUT.
ITEM FIFTEEN AB NINE SIXTY SEVEN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING NO.
THREE THREE MCGUIRE MCGUIRE I'M
FOR THREE THAT BILLS OUT.
ITEM SEVENTEEN A. B. THIRTEEN
THIRTEEN THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO JUDICIARY WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING I VICE CHAIR NOT
VOTING FOR ZERO WILK -- ASAL
MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE. FIVE ZERO
THAT BILLS OUT.
ITEM EIGHTEEN AB THIRTEEN FORTY
TO THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
JUDICIARY WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
I VICE CHAIR VOTING NO.
FOUR ONE DO ASAL MCGUIRE MCGUIRE
AYE. FIVE ONE THAT BILLS OUT.
ITEM NINETEEN AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS OF THE
CHAIR VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING
I FIVE ZERO TWO ASAL MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE SIX ZERO THAT BILLS
OUT.
IN SECOND WONDER NOW.
CONSENT CALENDAR WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I ADVISED HER VOTING I
FIVE ZERO DOCILE MCGUIRE MCGUIRE.
SIX ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
OUT.
THANK YOU EVERYONE THANK YOU --
COMMITTEE THANK YOU TO OUR
AUDIENCE